RIGHT WE WILL NOW.
OPEN OUR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
[inaudible] FIVE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY IN THE JUDICIARY
[inaudible]
ON I HAVE SOME -- CHANGES IN THE
AGENDA THAT I WILL READ A MOMENT
BUT LET'S TAKE A ROLL CALL FIRST.
CENTER SKINNER HERE CENTER MORE
LUCK WITH CENTER ABOUT.
A GREAT SO THE SUBJECT OF OUR
HEARING TODAY'S PRIMARILY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND WE'RE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE OR ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVE YOUR FIRST YEAR
HERE.
I'M IN BEFORE YOU COME UP TO THE
TABLE.
I WON IT ON THE AGENDA THAT YOU
HAVE BEFORE US BEFORE YOU ACCUSE
ME SHOWS.
ON ISSUES ONE THROUGH ELEVEN AS
VOTE ONLY WE WILL NOT BE VOTING
ON THOSE TODAY.
AND WE WILL NOT BE VOTING ON
TODAY BECAUSE THE IF IF YOU WERE
TO HAVE LOOKED AT THE DETAIL ON
THOSE ITEMS.
THE IN TOTAL WHILE THEY ALL
RELATE.
TO BILLS THAT WERE PASSED IN
TOTAL THE REFLECTED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
INCREASE. TO THE DEPARTMENT'S
BUDGET.
AND WHAT I'VE ASKED STAFF TO DO
IS TO GIVE ME A LITTLE MORE
ANALYSIS BECAUSE WHEN WE WENT
BACK.
AND WE LOOKED AT THE U. PROBES
ANALYSIS ON THE POTENTIAL COSTS
FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
BILLS.
THERE WAS THE GREAT DEAL OF
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN.
THE ASSESSMENTS THAT WERE GIVEN
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OR
BY OTHER OFFICES.
VERSES WHAT'S PRESENTED TO US
TODAY SO I WANTED -- TO HAVE
STAFF DIG A LITTLE DEEPER ON AND
FOR EXAMPLE IF WE TAKE THE ITEM
ISSUE TO ON THE SEX OF BENT SEX.
OFFENDER REGISTRATION.
I'M.
THAT BILL.
WOODS ULTIMATELY HOPEFULLY
REDUCE THE WORKLOAD OF DOJ
BECAUSE THE BILL.
CHANGES UP UNTIL THAT BILL WAS
PASSED CALIFORNIA'S SEX REGISTRY
WAS LIFETIME FOR EVERYBODY ONE
SIZE FITS ALL.
AND NOW BILL ADJUSTED IT SO THAT
YOU HAD PEOPLE ON SOME PEOPLE IN
TEN YEARS SOME PEOPLE TWENTY OR
SO -- IN OTHER WORDS LAST TIME
ON THE REGISTRY.
AND WHEN THE BILL PASSED IN THAT
VERY FISCAL YEAR.
OR WAS IT LAST YEAR ALWAYS
FORGET BUT WHATEVER.
WE APPROVED TEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR DOJ AND SOME POSITIONS
BECAUSE WE KNEW THAT THERE WOULD
BE.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'D HAVE TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO BE ON SOFTWARE
THAT THE COMPUTER I. T. I T. IN
ORDER.
TO THE APPROPRIATELY
ADMINISTERED THE CHANGE AND THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME ON GOING F. T.
E. ASSOCIATED.
OUR BUT THE ITEM THAT'S ON THAT
WOULD ONLY WOULD INCREASE ON TOP
OF WHAT WE HAD ALREADY APPROVED
THIRTY SEVEN NEW F. T. EAT.
AND WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE NUMBER
OF SEX OFFENDERS WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY -- HUNDRED
THOUSAND HUNDRED THOUSAND FIVE
ENDERS NEW PEOPLE ADDED EVERY
YEAR BUT NOW THERE WILL BE
PEOPLE BEING TAKEN OFF EVERY
YEAR.
SO ANYWAY I ASKED STAFF TO GET
INTO THE LITTLE MORE DETAIL.
ON THOSE DIFFERENT -- ITEMS
VERSES ARE TRYING.
TO I GO INTO THE WEEDS ON THEM
EACH INDIVIDUALLY DURING THIS
HEARING SO WE WON'T BE VOTING ON
THEM.
BUT I WANTED TO RAISE THE ISSUE
THAT.
I SO AT LEAST THE DEPARTMENT
KNOWS WHY WE AREN'T BECAUSE OF
THINGS LIKE LOOKING AT THE
REQUEST FOR THE SEX OFFENDER
REGISTRATION AND KNOWING WHAT WE
APPROVED LAST YEAR.
AND THE B. C. P. DOESN'T
NECESSARILY.
INCORPORATE ANY DISCUSSION OVER
HOW WOULD USE THE FUNDS WE ARE A
PROVIDED.
AND WHY.
YOU KNOW WHAT TO Y. ON TOP OF
THAT THIS NEW -- REQUIREMENT IS
SO ANYWAY THAT'S WHY I WANT TO
EXPLAIN THAT.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE ON OUR
LIST FOR DISCUSSION ITEMS TO
ISSUES AROUND THE DNA. ONE OF
THEM IS JUST THE BACK FILL ON
DNA IDENTIFICATION FUND WHICH I
THINK WE DO NEED TO DISCUSS.
AND THEN THE SECOND ONE IS
AROUND -- IT'S AN IMPLEMENTATION
COST REALART SLATED TO A. B.
[inaudible]
FIFTEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND THAT
ONE HIS.
WHILE IT'S NOT A HUGE
EXPENDITURE.
IT'S SIMILAR IN TERMS OF FITTING
INTO THE ITEMS THAT YOU SEE ONE
THROUGH.
ELEVEN ON SO I'M IN A MOVE THAT
TO THAT LIST THAT STAFF IS GOING
TO GIVE US MORE ANALYSIS ON
BEFORE WE DISCUSS SO I'M
REMOVING IT FROM THE DISCUSSION
AGENDA THAT'S ISSUE.
EIGHTEEN AND THEN FINALLY OUR
OVERSIGHT ITEM WHICH IS ISSUE.
FOURTEEN I'M AND THAT'S ONE THAT
ONE IS OVERSIGHT THE REST OF
THEM WERE BCP'S I'M GONNA MOVE
TO THE END OF IT GEN.
RATHER THAN TO BE OUR THIRD
DISCUSSION ITEM [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- SO WITH THAT.
WE WILL START.
WITH OUR THE GENERAL AND WHOEVER
ELSE YOU WOULD LIKE TO BRING TO
THE TABLE -- AG MISSOURI.
AND ON A OVERVIEW AN UPDATE ON
DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- ONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CHANCE TO BE WITH YOU -- I HAVE
A TEAM THAT'S HERE WITH ME AS
WELL.
IN THE EVENT THAT YOU WANT TO
PROBE DEEPER IN CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
BUDGET AND WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE.
IF I CAN START BY SAYING -- A
BIG THANKS TO ADJUST THE
PERSONNEL THE MEN AND WOMEN OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT TO THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE.
ALONG WITH FORMER GOVERNOR BROWN
NOW GOVERNOR NEWSOME FOR THE
WORK WE'VE ALL DONE GATHERS A
TEAM TO TRY TO PROVIDE
CALIFORNIANS WITH THE PROTECTION
AND SAFETY THAT THEY EXPECT.
AND ALSO TO BE ABLE TO SAY THAT
WE ADVANCE THEIR RIGHTS AS BEST
WE CAN TO DEFEND THEM.
AND ALL THE THINGS THAT MAKE
CALIFORNIA SUCH A GREAT PLACE
AND NOW THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
I LIKE THE I LIKE JUST A FEW
THINGS AND THEN -- THIRTEEN ANY
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS YOU MIGHT
HAVE -- IT'S I THINK IMPORTANT
TO POINT OUT SOME OF THE WORK
THAT SOME OF OUR PARTICULAR
TEAMS ARE DOING BECAUSE OFTEN
TIMES IT IS -- NOT KNOWN BY THE
PUBLIC JUST HOW MUCH WORK THEY
DO.
OUR FOR IN.
SIXTEEN WHICH I SERVICES MOST OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT OF
PROSECUTORIAL AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- AND DOES
SO WITHOUT CHARGE.
TESTED MORE THAN -- TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE
GETS LAST YEAR.
WE ARE UP TO DATE AND HAVE NO
BACKLOG WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TESTING OF THOSE VERY IMPORTANT --
EVIDENCE GETS.
OUR TAX RECOVERY AN UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY TEAM.
WHICH GOES OUT AND TRIES.
TO MAKE SURE WITH WERE THROAT
VOTE FOR THOSE WHO ARE TRYING.
TO UNDERCUT OUR ECONOMY NOT PAY
THEIR FAIR SHARE TAXES NOT A
FAIR WAGES.
DO THINGS IN THE WRONG WAY WHICH
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
BUSINESSES THAT ARE TRYING TO DO
IN THE RIGHT WAY.
THAT TEAM -- WHICH WERE COVERED
BY THE WAY SOME SIX AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR.
IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT IT NOT
BE PAID AND WOULD HAVE OTHERWISE
HAD BEEN COVERED BY OTHER
TAXPAYERS.
THAT TEAM LAST YEAR BUSTED A AN
OPERATION THE OWNERS AND
OPERATORS OF AN OPERATION CALLED
RAINBOW BRITE WHICH WAS AN ADULT
AND CHILD CARE FACILITY IN THE
BAY AREA.
THAT FACILITY THAT WAS
SUPPOSEDLY JUST TAKING CARE OF
ADULTS AND CHILDREN WAS ALSO
TRAFFICKING IN WORKERS IT WAS
DEALING WORKERS WAGES.
AND IT WAS TRAFFICKING
INDIVIDUALS FOR SEX I AND IN
SOME CASES SOME OF THESE
EMPLOYEES -- WERE BEING RAPED --
THIS OPERATOR OF THIS ADULT AND
CHILD CARE FACILITY ALSO WAS
FOUND TO POSSESS FIREARMS IN
SOME CASES MAINTAINING FIREARMS
AT THE CHILD CARE CENTER -- OUR
OUR TAX RECOVERING UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY TEAM.
BUSTED THAT OPERATION AND WE
INTEND TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WITH YOUR SYSTEMS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE GOING AFTER THOSE
WERE TRYING TO DO THINGS THE
WRONG WAY.
THE DISADVANTAGE THOSE WANTED
WITH THE RIGHT WAY AND
COMPLETELY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
MANY WOMEN WHO WORK IN THE STATE
AND DESERVE TO BE PAID TO WRITE
WAGES.
OUR BUREAU FIREARMS AGENTS
CONTINUE TO DISARM DANGEROUS
INDIVIDUALS -- QUICK EXAMPLE IN
A JINT OPERATION WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT LAST FALL.
OUR AGES BECOME BIRD -- SEVEN
ASSAULT WEAPONS FIFTY SIX
HANDGUNS TWENTY ONE SHOT GUNS
TWENTY FOUR RIFLES THREE LOWER
RECEIVER OF THE WEAPON.
ON TOP OF THAT HE'S MORE THAN
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION. FIFTY HIGH CAPACITY
MAGAZINES ARE AND THAT WAS IN
JUST ONE OPERATION WITH.
THE LA COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT.
WE HELP SEVEN PUBLIC FORMS
RECENTLY OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS DEALING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT
THE NEW LAW THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE PASSED.
THAT WILL -- NOT ONLY BE A
LANDMARK -- STATUTE FOR
CALIFORNIA BUT FOR THE ENTIRE
NATION NO ONE ELSE HAS DONE THIS.
AND WE ARE NOW IN THE PROCESS OF
TRYING.
TO FORMULATE THE REGULATIONS
THAT WILL BE USED TO IMPLEMENT
ENFORCE THAT LAW THAT WILL GIVE
PEOPLE.
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS OVER THE
INTERNET AND YOUR USE OF THE
INTERNET.
WE'RE FIGHTING IN COURT AS WE
SPEAK TO DEFEND [inaudible]
CALIFORNIA'S.
CLEAN CAR STANDARDS AND THE
NATIONAL CLEAN CAR STANDARDS
THAT NOW -- PREVAILED THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY.
AS A RESULT OF OUR TEAMS WORK.
THERE ARE SOME THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND DREAMERS --
APPLICANTS INTO THE DOCK A
PROGRAM WHO CONTINUE TO HAVE
STATUS -- BECAUSE OF THE WORK
THAT WE DID -- IN PROTECTING THE
DOC A PROGRAM FROM ELIMINATION
PURSUANT TO PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ORDER -- WE SECURED SIGNIFICANT
AND IN SOME CASES HISTORIC
SETTLEMENTS AGAIN SOME OF THE
BIGGEST NAMES IN AMERICA A
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILLION AND A
HALF DOLLARS -- AGAINST THE
CALIFORNIA GAS UNDER TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AGAINST.
BRITISH PETROLEUM ENERGY.
SEVENTY EIGHT A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS AGAINST FIAT CHRYSLER.
AND THERE ARE MORE.
AND WE CONTINUE TO DO ALL THIS
AS WE CONTINUE TO DEAL WITH ANY
EXTERNAL THREATS COMING FROM
OUTSIDE CALIFORNIA'S WELL.
WE FOR EXAMPLE PREVAILED IN OUR
LAWSUIT CHALLENGING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S ATTEMPT TO ADD
A QUESTION ON THE STAND THE
QUESTIONNAIRE THAT WOULD DEAL
WITH IT IS A SHIP.
THAT WOULD HAVE HAD A MAJOR
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIANS IF WE
HAVE A AN UNDERCOUNT OF OUR
SENSES COMING UP NEXT YEAR.
AND WE CONTINUE TO CHALLENGE AT
THAT WILL GO BEFORE THE SUPREME
COURT SOON.
WE CHALLENGE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S UNLAWFUL
ATTEMPT TO FORCE CALIFORNIA. TO
ENFORCE IMMIGRATION LAWS AS
EXCERPTED COACH AND AS A RESULT
WE WERE ABLE TO PROTECT SOME
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN.
JAG FUNDING THAT GOES TO OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
AND WE WERE.
ABLE TO INTERCEDE IN A CASE THAT
PROTECTS THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
AND AS OF TODAY THERE ARE TWENTY
ONE STATES.
THAT ARE IN THIS FIGHT TO
PROTECT THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
FROM ELIMINATION.
IT'S THANKS TO THE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FORM I
JUST WITH THIS -- LEGISLATURE --
BUT WITH OTHER.
AGES THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND
IN MANY OTHER WAYS.
WORKING WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITY -- ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WERE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE SOME OF THIS WORK.
SO WE HOPE TO BE A CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD WE'D LIKE TO
CONTINUE THAT.
PROGRAM THAT LETS US RETRIEVE
WEAPONS FROM THOSE WHO HAVE LOST
THE RIGHT TO POSSESS THEM.
A STRONG APPS PROGRAM HE MADE
EVEN STRONGER -- WE ISSUED A
REPORT THAT OUTLINED SEVERAL
WAYS THAT WE COULD DO SO I TO
CONTINUE GETTING ILLEGAL WEAPONS
OFF OUR STREETS.
WE NEED TO INVEST IN THE APPS
PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES AN INCREASE OF TWENTY
SIX POSITIONS THAN FIVE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT.
THE GROWING APPS WORKLOAD AND TO
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT WE
MEAN BY APPOINT WORKLOAD.
INGEST SOME TEN YEARS.
KNOWN FIREARM OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE THAN DOUBLED.
GOING FROM SOME NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND OR SO IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO TODAY'S
NUMBER OF TWO MILLION FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY SIX AS OF
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN OUR AGENTS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ARE
NOT HINDERED BY JURISDICTIONAL
BOUNDARIES LIMITATIONS SO THAT
IN THE PROCESS OF TRYING TO
DISARM A DANGEROUS INDIVIDUAL WE
HAVE TO STOP.
IF WE CROSS THE COUNTY BORDER
AND THAT'S WHERE THE WORK OF THE
STATE DOJ AGENCY SO CRUCIAL -- I
SHOULD MENTION THAT THE BUREAU
FORENSIC FORENSIC SERVICES.
WHICH HAD DONE YEOMAN'S WORK IN
TRYING TO HELP SOLVE CRIMES.
IS RUNNING INTO DIFFICULTY
BECAUSE THE DNA ID FUND WHICH IT
RELIES ON FUNDING HAS BEEN
DEPLETED AND CONTINUE TO GO DOWN.
BUT THE WORK THAT WE DO ON
BEHALF OF HUNDREDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PROSECUTE.
PROSECUTORIAL AGENCY.
WOULD WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WE'RE NOT FOR THE WORK
THAT WE DO.
IN OUR FRANTIC UNIT TO TRY TO
HELP THEM SOLVE CRIME TO PROVIDE
THE EFFORTS TO MOVE FOR THE
PROSECUTION IN THE CASE AND WE
DO ALL OF THAT AS I SAID EARLIER.
WITHOUT CHARGING ANY THESE LAW
ENFORCEMENT FOR PROSECUTORIAL
EIGHT THESE A PENNY FOR THE WORK
THAT WE DO GET -- DOING THE
FRIENDSHIPS WORKED ON THAT.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING WHICH WE
CONTINUE SEE GROW CALIFORNIA IS
GROUND ZERO FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
WE HAVE THE MOST ARTS BITES AND
WE HAVE THE MOST INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE.
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WE'RE TRYING TO CONTINUE TO BEEF
UP OUR EFFORTS TO GO AFTER THAT.
HIDEOUS CRIME.
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT.
TRAFFIC WHICH COULD INCLUDE
LABOR [inaudible] FOR COMMERCIAL
CHECKS.
BUT WHAT WE FIND MOST OFTEN
INDICATES WE TRIED TO DEAL WITH --
ARE THOSE OF YOUNG GIRLS MOST OF
THEM OFTENTIMES UNFORTUNATELY
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN WERE
BEING DRAFTED BUT I DID MANAGE
THE CASE OF RAINBOW BRITE.
WHICH WAS -- THAT.
ADULT AND CHILD CARE CENTER THAT
WAS TRAFFIC.
EMPLOYEES AND SO WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO THAT WORK AS B.
C. NECESSARY WE HOPE THAT YOU
WILL HELP US AS WE CONTINUE WITH
SOME OF THE MAJOR
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WE'VE BEEN
HANDED BY.
THE LEGISLATURE THE GOVERNOR WE
NEED MODERN MODERNIZE OUR
FIREARMS IT SYSTEMS SO WE NEED
TO GO AFTER THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE.
RIGHT ANYMORE TO POSSESS WEAPONS.
WE WANT.
TO BE ABLE.
TO TELL THE AMERICAN TO THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC THAT WE WILL
FORCEFULLY -- INSURE THEIR
RIGHTS IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
MANAGING THE REGISTRATION OF
KNOWN.
SIX NEW TIERED SYSTEM THAT
MANAGER YOU MENTIONED AND WE
EVEN WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE MISSION REGULATE.
THE MAJOR LEAGUE SPORTING EVENT
RAFFLE PROGRAMS.
AFTER PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S REALLY SERVING THE PEOPLE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND FINALLY AND AS ALWAYS AS
IT'S IMPORTANT STRESS I JUST THE
EXCELLENCE OF THE WORK THAT ARE
YOU J. PERSONNEL PERFORM --
UNDER VERY CHALLENGING
CIRCUMSTANCES IT ALSO POINT TO
MENTION THEY DO THEY DO THIS
UNDER VERY CHALLENGING
[inaudible]
INDIVIDUAL CIRCUIT.
OUR ENTRY LEVEL DIVISIONAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS ARE PAID
APPROXIMATELY 44% BELOW THE
AVERAGE SALARY OF CALIFORNIA'S
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
OUR FORMER YOHJI CRIMINOLOGIST
PARALEGALS IN OUR OFFICE WHO HAD
MOVED ON TO SIMILAR POSITIONS
WITHIN LOCAL AGENCIES OR PRIVATE
FIRMS.
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO DOUBLE THEIR
SALARIES WHEN THEY LEAVE OUR OUR
SHOP.
AND OUR HIGHEST SALARIES FOR OUR
SENIOR ATTORNEYS.
WHO DO TRULY COMPLEX LITIGATION
REACHING THE SUPREME COURT?
THEIR SALARIES ARE COMPARABLE TO
WHAT LAW SCHOOL GRADUATES FROM
THE PRIEST RISKY JUST LAW SCHOOL
COULD MAKE IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
IN THEIR FIRST YEAR.
OUT OF WHAT.
AND SO IT'S A CHALLENGE THAT'S
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY TO NOT NLY
TALK ABOUT THE SUCCESSES OF OUR
PROGRAM TO TALK BOUT THE
CHALLENGES BUT ABOUT HOW WE NEED
TO MOVE FORWARD AND AS I SAID AT
THE VERY BEGINNING.
MOVING FORWARD PARTNERSHIP SO
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- LOOK
FOR TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE AND AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE TO HELP THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BE ABLE TO SAY THAT IT IS THE
BEST DEPARTMENT JUSTICE IN THE
LAND.
THANK YOU M..
MR BASURA [inaudible]
I'M.
I HAVE A NUMBER OF COMMENTS R
QUESTIONS BUT LE LET MY
COLLEAGUES IF YOU.
CENTER MORE LOCK.
IF YOU'RE GONNA LET ME START.
GET A WARM UP FOR YEAH THEN
MADAM CHAIR OF GOOD TO SEE YOU
ATTORNEY GENERAL DISCERN.
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO
YOUR OFFICE -- SIX WEEKS OR SO
AGO THANK YOU PROJECTED
[inaudible] TO ADD.
DISCUSS APPS THE ARMS AND
PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM.
IT'S ALL START THERE WAS SOME
SOME CONCERNS -- HAVING ALSO HAD
THE JOY OF BEING A DEPARTMENT
HEAD IT IS A BIG JOB IT IS FULL
TIME.
NOTE AND YOU KNOW THIS IT'S A
BIG JOB YOU JUST LISTED JUST.
MAYBE JUST A FRACTION OF WHAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON SO YOU INHERIT
A SENIOR STAFF.
AND AND YOU STEP IN AND
HOPEFULLY THEY HAVE TAKEN CARE
OF MOST OF THE KINKS BUT A YOU
KNOW STATING THAT. 44% -- ARE
PAID BELOW INDUSTRY AVERAGE --
IN WE KNOW THAT SOME OF YOUR
SENIOR.
LAWYERS ARE ARE ARE MAYBE IT
STARTLED STARTING LEVEL. FOR SO.
AS A DEPARTMENT HEAD -- ONE WHY
DID THAT HAPPEN IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU INHERITED OR IS IT
JUST SOMETHING.
THAT SENIOR MANAGEMENT WASN'T
WORKING ON OR OR WHAT ARE THE
BARRIERS OR WHAT WE'RE THAT.
EMISSIONS THAT THAT OCCURRED.
AND THANKS FOR THE QUESTION AND
I NAM THE MEN AND WOMEN AT THE
BAR MAJOR SPECIES -- PROBING.
I I'D SAY IT'S BEEN IT'S BUILT
OVER TIME AND AS YOU KNOW AS AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS RUN AN OPERATION.
I DON'T HAVE TO CONTROL THE
SALARIES FOR FOR THE PEOPLE.
BARBARA JUSTICE THAT'S DONE BY
DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
HAVE AND SO WE TAKE THEM WITH
THE SALARIES THAT THEY GET BASED
ON THEIR NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
DIFFERENT AGENTS.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED OVER TIME I
THINK ESPECIALLY DURING THE TIME
THAT WE HAD A REALLY?
MASSIVE BUDGET DEFICIT IN THE
STATE WHEN WE HAD A AND ECONOMIC
TURNDOWN WAS.
WE DIDN'T KEEP PACE.
AND SO ONE OF THE WAYS THAT THE
STATE WAS ABLE TO SAVE SOME
MONEY.
IN THE BUDGET TO MAKE UP FOR
SHORTFALLS WESTON NOT INCREASE
OUR AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS PROBABLY MORE CUTE
THAN OTHER AGENCIES AS OUR
ARCHERY FOR DOUBLE GO TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
MOST OTHER STATE AGENCY LAWYERS
DON'T.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
GETTING.
TOP NOTCH IN EVERY RESPECT ARE
YOUR J. AGENTS.
THERE ARE NOT MANY.
YOUR TO GO.
SEEK OUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
DANGEROUS. TO TRY TO DISARM
THAT'S WHAT OUR AGENTS DO EVERY
DAY.
BUT IN THE PROCESS OVERSIGHT.
THE SALARIES STOP BEING
COMPETITIVE.
OUR AGENTS FOR EXAMPLE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE OF THE
CHANGEIN PENSIONS.
TODAY IF AN AGENT IF AN OFFICER
FROM ANOTHER AGENCY COMES UNDER
THE OLD THE OLD PENSION SYSTEM.
THEY WOULD LOSE MONEY COME AND
WORK FOR US UNDER THE NEW
PENSION SYSTEM.
SO IT'S TOUGH TO RECRUIT
OFTENTIMES ESPECIALLY WHEN
SALARIES LOWER AND PENSION.
BENEFITS WOULD TAKE A HIT SO DO
YOU.
WELL AT ALL TOGETHER.
YES SO MUCH OF OUR WORK AS A
BERNESE OCCURS IN THE BIG CITIES.
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW TOUGH IT IS
TO RECRUIT A PARALEGAL.
SAN FRANCISCO.
AT THE STATE -- SALARIES FOR A
PARALEGAL WE JUST CAN'T COMPETE
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR MAKES IT
TOUGH.
SO THEN THE CENTER MORE LIKE THE
POLISH SO I JUST WANTED HIM TO
IT. TWO AT ON THIS VERY QUESTION
IF YOU COULD EXPAND.
AND THEN YOU PROCEED JUST.
ORTIZ AGENTS THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO ALL PART OF
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT IN
ISN'T THIS THE THE I MEAN THIS
IS NOT A SALARY SCHEDULE THAT IS
1100% DETERMINED BY A FIX.
SO IF YOU COULD JUST SPEAK TO
THE FACT THAT THEY ARE PART OF A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT ALL
THE FACT EVERYONE OF THE
PERSONNEL WHETHER IT'S THE
ATTORNEYS. FOR THE PARALEGALS OR
THE AGENTS ARE ALL PART OF A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING --
AGREEMENT AND SO THEY ARE.
FIXED WITH ALL THEIR OTHER
COLLEAGUES IN THE SAME
CLASSIFICATION.
IN THAT THEY NEGOTIATED GOSHI
YEAH AND THAT'S GOING TO MY
POINT MANAGER I DON'T NEGOTIATE
WITH THEM THAT'S I DON'T EVEN
COULD CONDUCT THE NEGOTIATION
WITH THEM.%
AND I DON'T GET TO CHANGE THAT I
GET.
WHAT THE NEGOTIATIONS?
RESULTED IN.
AND BY WHAT THE YOUR OFFICE
DOZEN NEGOTIATE WITH THEM SORRY
IT'S DONE BY THE BOSS GO AHEAD.
IF THEM BY THE HUMAN RESOURCES
AGENCY FOR THE STATE THEY GOT
BECAUSE IT STATEWIDE IT'S NOT
JUST THE O. J. AGENTS WERE PART
OF THAT CLASSIFICATION STATUS
DOJ ATTORNEYS WERE PART OF THE
ATTORNEYS -- BARGAINING UNIT
IT'S STATEWIDE AND SO THEY ARE
STATEWIDE BARGAIN DIRECTLY WITH
THE STATE AGENCY IN CHARGE WITH
THAT.
WELL THEN IF IT'S A STATE WHY
WELL.
JUST.
IT'S HARD.
IT'S HARD TO PRECIADO THAT THE
ISSUE FOR US ROUTE WITH
RETENTION IS.
THE SALARY AND BENEFITS.
WHEN THE ENTITY?
THAT THE IF THEY'VE NEGOTIATED
THE SALARY AND BENEFITS AND IT'S
NOT A FIXED SALARY SCHEDULE THAT
THE STATE IS DETERMINED.
AND IT'S NOT EVEN SOMETHING THAT
THIS COMMITTEE COULD TRY TO
CHANGE BY TRYING TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH MORE RESOURCES IT WOULDN'T
GO TO SALARY.
I POINT THAT OUT SIMPLY TO
DEMONSTRATE HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
SOMETIMES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
WHETHER IT'S RETRIEVING WEAPONS.
OR FINDING THE SKILLED ATTORNEYS
WE NEED.
WITH CREAM COURT.
OPINION I JUST WITH THE
RESOURCES THAT WE GET TO DO OUR
JOB.
FROM YOU BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO
COMPLY.
WITH THE OUTSIDE SECTOR WHEN YOU
GOT A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT THAT SETS THE TERMS OF
EMPLOYMENT PAY AND COMPENSATION.
CENTER MORE LIKELY THAT YOU GET
TO MANAGE THROUGH THAT COULD YOU
STILL HAVE TO GET THE JOB DONE.
HE BROUGHT BUT SHOULD LOWERS SO
THEN YOU WERE WORK WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT A. P..
IN.
THAT THAT YOU HIGHER.
INDIVIDUALS THAT REQUIRE A
COLLEGE EDUCATION AS A MINIMUM.
WHICH MAKES IT DIFFICULT -- SO
IS THERE A DIFFERENT WAY TO LOOK
AT HOW WE PURSUE THIS BECAUSE
YOU MENTIONED IN OUR OUR
DISCUSSION THAT.
YOU KNOW IF WE GET IT ALL DONE
AT THE FRONT END THAT WOULD BE
MUCH MORE HELPFUL THAN YOU
COMING BACK IN THE MAKING THE
THREE CONTACT YEAH.
SO THEN.
INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT HIRING
STAFF.
IS THERE A WAY FOR YOU TO SAY TO
A POLICE DEPARTMENT.
YOU TAKE CARE OF IT.
AND BILL IS THE TIME.
AND THEN WILL REIMBURSE YOU AT
THEIR HOURLY RATE.
IN THAT WOULD.
MAYBE TAKE CARE OF YOUR MANPOWER
SHORTAGE WHAT REMEMBER EVEN IF
WE WERE TO GO THAT ROUTE.
THEY'RE BILLING RATES ARE HIGHER
THAN OURS SO WE HAVE TO END UP
PAYING MORE FOR THE SAME SERVICE.
AND THEY ARE LIMITED BECAUSE
WHAT YOU'RE JUST PAYING AN
HOURLY RATE YOU WOULD BE PAYING
FOR A FULL TIME EQUIVALENT U. F.
TO EASE SO YOU'RE.
RIGHT BUT IF YOU WANT TO GET THE
SAME PRODUCTION OVER ONE HOUR
FOR ONE DAY OR ONE YEAR IF YOU
STILL ARE PAYING MORE PER HOUR
PER.
MONTH PER YEAR.
WHAT WE COULD DO AND THIS IS
WHERE THAT WE TO GETTING DIED
THIS PAST YEAR AND WHEN WE
ISSUED A REPORT?
FOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT THERE IS THIS
ABSOLUTELY.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO FOR MORE
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BECAUSE AS AS YOU JUST MENTIONED
CENTER WE SHOULD NOT BE TRYING
TO RETRIEVE WEAPONS WELL AFTER
THE DANGERS PERSON HAS BEEN.
ON THE STREETS OR WHO KNOWS
WHERE WITHIN CITY CALIFORNIA WE
SHOULD RETRIEVE THAT WEAPON WHEN
WE HAD THE PERSON IN CUSTODY.
AS BEST WE CAN SO WORKING BETTER
WITH THE COURTS WORKING BETTER
WITH PROSECUTORS AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE SHOULD TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT BEFORE.
WE THAT PERSON LEAVES ARE.
OFFICIAL GRASP.
WE'VE TRIED TO REMOVE THE WEAPON
FROM SOMEONE WHO'S CLEARLY LOST
THE RIGHT TO POSSESS IT.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE
COORDINATION WHICH REALLY
SHOULDN'T COST.
OF TOO MUCH MONEY I THINK THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT FOLKS WILL
TELL YOU WE'RE GONNA NEED
SOMEBODY.
TO SHIFT SOME OF OUR RESOURCES
TO DO THIS WORK WITH YOU.
BUT THAT'S ABSOLUTELY WILL BE A
FOR MORE EFFICIENT WAY THAN JUST
HIRING UP A BIGGER FORCE.
I WANT TO AFFIRM YOU FOR STAYING
CURRENT.
THANK YOU A LARGE NUMBER EVERY
YEAR BUT WE'RE STILL.
WE STILL WE STILL GOT A CRACKED
THE BIG NOT THAT JUST KINDA
LINGERS SO -- HOW ARE YOU DOING
ON YOUR I. T. SOFTWARE YOU ALSO
BROUGHT THAT HAPPEN AGAIN AND
THAT SOMETHING YOU'VE INHERITED?
SO WHAT DO YOU AS A NO.
EXCELLENT MANAGER GOING TO DO TO
GET THROUGH THAT.
AQUA I'M GONNA SIT HERE TALK TO
YOU OUGHT TO SEE IF YOU'LL HELP
ME BECAUSE WE ARE USING.
A IT EQUIPMENT THAT -- I THINK
EVEN BILL GATES WAS IN A BILLION
OR AT THE TIME THAT WE STARTED
USING THIS EQUIPMENT AND SO --
IT IT IS EXTREMELY OBSOLETE AND
IT DOES SLOW THINGS DOWN BUT
IT'S A BIG SYSTEM.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO TRACK SO MANY
DIFFERENT DATA POINTS.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU JUST
SORT OF BY THE NEW COMPUTER AND
WE BUT WE WILL NEED TO MOVE
BECAUSE IT JUST THE VOLUME OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT ENTER INTO THE
APPS SYSTEM OR COULD.
HAS GROWN AND WE NEED TO TRY TO
KEEP PACE AND THE BETTER WE CAN
DO IT TO EFFICIENCY FIRST JUST
STAFFING UP.
THE BETTER ALL THIS WILL BE.
AND THEN I'M.
WE HAD A  KID A A A BILL AB
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE BY SOON CHIU.
WHICH REQUIRED THE POSTING OF A
SIGN IN A PREGNANCY CLINIC THAT
SAID THE STATE PROVIDES.
THE FOLLOWING SERVICES SORT OF
CONTRARY TO WHAT.
THEY WERE DOING FOR LIKE TELLING
A CHEVY DEALER TO PUT AFFORD.
SIGNER LOBBIED DOWN THE STREET
OR SOME YOU JUST SEEMED AWKWARD
[inaudible]
BUT BUT WE DO BILLS AND THEY GET
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR AND THEN
THEY GET LITIGATED AND THIS BILL.
WAS LITIGATED ALWAYS OF THE
STATE THE US SUPREME COURT.
AND SO THAT COMES AT A AT A COST
IN IN SO.
WE HAD ANOTHER BILL THIS WEEKEND
ONE OF MY COMMITTEES AND I'M
KIND OF LOOKING AT IT LIKE ALL
THIS IS GOING TO GO DOWN THE
SAME ROAD.
AND AT THE END OF THE DAY WE'RE
GOING TO SPEND A WHOLE LOT OF
MONEY BUT I DON'T THINK WE KNOW
[inaudible]
AS LEGISLATORS.
HOW MUCH WE'RE INCURRING?
FOR A CASE LIKE THIS IS THERE IS
THERE LIKE A RANGER AND AMOUNT
THAT YOU WOULD.
KNOW HOW MUCH WE WE ALLOCATED TO
THIS PARTICULAR [inaudible]
CASE ANY TIME YOU HAVE TO DEFEND
A LINE CORD IT STARTS TO ADD UP
ESPECIALLY IF YOU GO UP THE UP
THE LADDER.
IN IN APPEALS AND CERTAINLY IF
YOU'RE GOING ALL THE WAY TO THE
US SUPREME COURT THAT DOES THAT
AND EXPENSE -- WE ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CONSULT AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON VARIOUS MEASURES ESPECIALLY
IF WE ARE.
INFORMED ABOUT THE OF THE
PARTICULAR LEGISLATION SO WE CAN.
PROVIDE SOME OF OUR A SENSE
ABOUT THE THE CONSTITUTIONALITY
OF SOME OF THESE PROVISIONS.
BUT WHEN YOU DO GO ALL THE WAY
TO THE SUPREME COURT YOU WILL
END UP IN A SPENDING GOOD MONEY --
FORTUNATELY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS I JUST PENSION
ARE TURNING.
ON HIS CLASS THE AS THAT'S
LITIGATING AGAINST US -- OUR OUR
LEGAL BILL IS USUALLY A LOT
SMALLER EVEN THOUGH WE WE HAVE.
JUST AS CAPABLE OF NOT MORE
CAPABLE FOLKS BUT NO DOUBT THERE
ANYTIME YOU HAVE TO DEFEND THE
LAW.
AND IT'S CONSTITUTIONALITY YOU
CAN START SPENDING SOME MONEY.
WELL WE WILL.
WE I HEAR THE WHISPERS ON THE ON
THE ON THE CHAMBER FLOORS LIKE
OTHER THE OPTICS IS I CAN'T VOTE
AGAINST THIS BILL.
BUT I KNOW IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BUT HOW DO YOU VOTE NO AND THEN
OFTEN DOES AND AND NOW WE'RE
SPENDING MONEY SO. FOR THE FOR
A. B. SEVEN SEVEN FIVE WHAT DO
WE SPEND TEN MILLION FIVE
MILLION ONE MILLION.
OR THE ACTUAL LEGISLATION THAT
ACTUAL BILL AND HOW WHAT WAS THE
COST YEAH DEREGULATION MAYBE I
SHOULD ASK DIFFICULT DIFFERENTLY.
AT YOUR RUNNING UP ONE OF THE
LARGEST LAW FIRMS IN THE NATION
DO THEY PREPARE TIME REPORTS WE
DO AT WE WE BILL IN DIFFERENT
WAYS -- FOR EXAMPLE ON THE
CRIMINAL SIDE SINCE WE DO ALL
THE APPELLATE WORK.
IT'S A DIFFERENTPROCESS THAN ON
THE CIVIL SIDE WHERE IT'S IT'S
MUCH MORE LIKE WHAT YOU SEE INA
LAW FIRM.
IN THE BILLABLE HOURS ON THE
PUBLIC RIGHT SIDE BECAUSE HE'S --
CASES USUALLY THAT TAKE QUITE
SOME TIME TO MOVE THROUGH THE
PROCESS -- IT'S IT'S GONNA BE
DIFFERENT BUT BUT FOR THE MOST
PART YOU CAN TRACK THE COST
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO REPORT -- OUR
COST TO THE STATE AND SO THERE
IS A WAY TO TRY TO DETERMINE
WHAT SOME OF THESE.
MEASURES WOULD COST.
THE TOTAL WOULD DO IT.
WHAT A COSTA WE KNOW WHICH OF
THE DRIVER KNOW FIRST ONE
PARTICULAR CASE I COULD GET BACK
TO I DON'T KNOW OFF THE TOP OF
MY HEAD?
BUT I COULD GET BACK IF YOU LIKE
ON I I'M JUST YOU JUST I'M JUST
SO I CAN KIND OF SEE OKAY.
FOLKS THIS IS GOING TO COST US.
YOU KNOW YOUR NAME YOU KNOW DO
WE JUST HAD A GOOD HEADLINE IN
THE IN THE SACRAMENTO BEE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE GOTTA DO THIS FOR
YOU KNOW DOESN'T MATTER WE GOTTA
GET UP BY THIS ONE ALWAYS.
YOU KNOW IN AND I GET IT BUT
IT'S LIKE.
BAG I REPORTS TAXPAYERS OPEN ON
A NO OVER.
SPENDING.
WE HAD ANOTHER REASON ISSUE --
WHERE THE GOVERNOR'S DECIDED TO
REPRIEVE? SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN WHATEVER THE NUMBER
IS OF INDIVIDUALS ON DEATH ROW
FOR THE TIRED TIRED TERM.
OF HIS GOVERNORSHIP SO I'VE.
KIND OF CURIOUS YOU HAVE TO HOLD.
THE WIND YOU KNOW TO BE THE
WORST OF THE WORST THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU WENT THROUGH A
PRETTY ELABORATE PROCESS AND
WHEN I WAS GOING THROUGH THE
GREAT RECESSION WE WOULD DEBATE
R. D. A.'S SAYING REALLY HAS
BEEN OTHER MILLION DOLLARS.
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES.
TO GET THE DEATH SENTENCE AND SO
NOW IT'S ON HOLD AND I'VE.
I I'M JUST CURIOUS IF YOU'D LIKE.
TO LET ME KNOW.
YOUR POSITION AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS.
SO THE THE GOVERNOR HAS THE
POWER. TO ISSUE THE REPRIEVE --
OR TO COMMUTE OR DEPARTMENT.
AND HE USED THE POWER HAS OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION TO ISSUE
THE REPRIEVE.
IN THE FORM OF A MORATORIUM FOR
ALL OF THOSE WHO SIT ON DEATH
ROW -- THAT MEANS THAT DURING
HIS TERM OR UNTIL HE CHOOSES TO
KEEP THAT QUARTER FORCE
[inaudible]
THAT.
HE HAS THE ABILITY THE POWER.
TO ENSURE THAT NO ONE WILL MOVE
TOWARDS ACTUAL EXCEPT EXECUTION
WHO SITS ON DEATH ROW.
HOW THAT?
PLAYS OUT MOVING FORWARD.
AFTER.
GOVERNOR LISA FINISHES HIS TIME.
IT REALLY DEPENDS ON WHAT THE
NEXT GOVERNOR DOES OR WHAT THE
PEOPLE THE STATE CALIFORNIA SAY
BECAUSE WITHIN OUR CONSTITUTION
WE HAVE THE PROVISION THAT
PROVIDES FOR THE DEATH PENALTY.
AND TO THIS DAY THE THE COURTS
INCLUDING THE US SUPREME COURT
HAVE NOT HELD THE DEATH PENALTY
TO BE UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
NOW YOU HAVE HAS TO BE
ADMINISTERED WAYS EXECUTED IN
WAYS THAT KEEP US WITHIN
CONSTITUTIONAL BOUNDS.
CROONING UNIT IF YOU'RE A USUAL
PUNISHMENT FOR EXAMPLE BUT AT
THIS STAGE CALIFORNIA HAS.
A PROVISION IN ITS A
CONSTITUTION THAT PROVIDES FOR
THE DEATH PENALTY AND A HAPPY
FALLS ON THE I'M A JUSTICE IS A
MENTIONED EARLIER WE DO ALL THE
APPELLATE WORK.
SO THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OF
THE WANT TO PROSECUTE THE CASES
IT AT TRIAL.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT TO SEEK OUT THE
DEATH PENALTY.
WHEN THAT CASE IS DONE IF THE
DEFENDANT IS FOUND GUILTY?
AND FOUND GUILTY AND SENTENCED
TO DEATH.
THOSE CASES SHOULD THEY BE
APPEAL BY THE DEFENDANT.
OR SHOULD THE DEFENDANT TRIED --
TO HAVE THAT.
A CASE REVIEWED THOSE CASES AND
GO BEFORE THE APPELLATE COURTS.
AND AT THAT POINT THE DOCTOR
FROM THE JUSTICE OUR JOURNEYS
TAKE OVER THE CASES.
THERE ARE SEVERAL CASES SEVERAL
HUNDRED CASES THAT ARE STILL
WORKING THEIR WAY THROUGH THAT
PROCESS.
AND IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY --
TO PROVIDE THE COUNCIL IN IN
THOSE CASES AND WE ARE DOING
THAT.
AND WE'VE GOT PROBABLY THE MOST
NOTORIOUS OF THEM ALL RIGHT HERE
IN THE SACRAMENTO AREA SO
[inaudible]
WHO?
YOU WANNA PINE ON THAT.
YOU MEAN THE THE SERIAL KILLING
ALL THE STATE OR THE STICKER
HE'S GOING TO THE PROCESS I
BELIEVE THE DESCRIPTOR ANYTHING
HAS -- CALL FOR THE THE DEATH
PENALTY IF HE IS ULTIMATELY
CONVICTED.
THAT WOULD WORK ITS WAY THROUGH
THE PROCESS WHAT IT MEANS GIVEN
THE GOVERNOR'S MORATORIUM IS
THAT -- SHOULD ANY INDIVIDUAL.
WHETHER TO GO THE STATE KILLEARN
OR ANYONE ELSE.
MOVE ALL THE WAY TO ON TO DEATH
ROW.
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS WOULD
UNDER THE MORATORIUM.
NOT AT THIS DURING THE THE TERM
OF GOVERNOR HE SAID.
NOT BE ACTUALLY EXECUTED.
I THINK MADAM CHAIR THOSE ARE
ALL MY QUESTIONS FOR NOW BUT I
DO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
INTERRUPT YOU WHEN YOU'RE ASKING
YOUR IT WOULD BE FINE
[inaudible]
IN ABOUT -- YES -- I JUST WANT
TO SAY PROPOSED CHAIR RUNS THE
MEETING AND THE MAJORITY PARTY.
POINT TO CHAIR AND YOU CAN
ALWAYS TRY TO BECOME SURE BY
GETTING A MAJORITY OF YOU FOR
MEMBERS SELECTED OKAY.
ATTEMPT AT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
THAT POINT BECAUSE THE CHAIR IS --
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN INTRIGUED BY
THE DEFINITELY A AND AND I NEVER
REALLY.
FROM THE LA -- AND OTHER SOURCES.
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE COST OF
WHAT IT COSTS TO HAVE DIFF ROLE
[inaudible]
AND THE THINGS YOU MENTIONED THE
APPEALS -- ALL THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS -- BECAUSE I GET ASKED
THAT A LOT YOU KNOW PEOPLE ASK
ME WHAT WHAT IS THE COST. TO TO
OPERATE THAT AND I WOULD THINK
THAT IT COSTS MONEY TO PUT
SOMEBODY IN -- PHYSICAL FACILITY
OR SAN QUENTIN AND THERE'S A BIG
THIRTY YEARS SO -- WOMEN AND
SHALL CHILLER.
AND I'VE TALKED TO BOTH.
I'VE BEEN TO BOTH PLACES MANY
TIMES IN ALSO.
I KIND OF BEEN IN THERE AND SEE
THE FACILITIES -- AND THEN THE
LEGAL COSTS THOUGH EVERY EVERY
DEATH ROW INMATE PROBABLY HAS A
LAWYER I ASSUME RIGHT IS NOT THE
REQUIRED THANKS.
AND WE HAVE TO PAY FOR A CLEAR
THE TAXPAYERS.
SO THEN YOU HAVE LAWYERS TO DO
THE APPEALS AND SO FORTH.
AND THEN THERE IS -- HEARINGS IN
THE JUDGE'S CHAMBERS AND THEY
HAVE TO THAT COSTS MONEY SO SO
I'M KIND OF INTERESTED IN --
JUST WHAT HAS ANYBODY EVER
FIGURED OUT THE OVERALL COST OF
THE SEVEN I THINK IT'S SEVEN
HUNDRED THIRTY OR SO.
PEOPLE. TO THE TAXPAYERS A
CALIFORNIA.
IS THAT -- I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYONE HAS DONE THAT I'M
INTERESTED NOT SEE I I'M THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE SO.
I GOT ASKED THAT KIND OF
QUESTION I THINK IT'S ON THE IF
IF YOU TO WORK WITH THE LA ALL
AND TRY TO MAKE SURE WE COVER
EVERY COST ME WE CAN COME UP
WITH SOMETHING.
AND ITS ONGOING -- AND EVERY
YEAR.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME ALSO IN HIS --
MORATORIUM STATEMENT.
OUTLINES QUITE A BIT OF THAT
ABOUT THE OFFICE AND THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT I NEVER SEEN LIKE THE
WHOLE PITCHER PUT TOGETHER IN.
ONE THANK YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE EVER SEEN
THAT ARE THE ONLY -- IS.
ATTEMPTED TO PULL SOMETHING
TOGETHER BUT IT SEEMS LIKE IT
SEEMS LIKE -- THE TAXPAYER
EVERYBODY KEEPS ASKING ME THIS
OKAY SO I JUST.
MAYBE MAYBE CAN WORK WITH -- ARE --
ILIO ANOTHER STAFF THE BUDGET
STAFF THEY COULD PULL SOMETHING
TOGETHER SO WE CAN SEE ALL THE
MAKE SURE HAS EVERYTHING IN IT
YOU KNOW LIKE BALL ACOSTA --
BECAUSE IT THE THE AVERAGE
TAXPAYER YOU KNOW THEY DEBATE
WHETHER OR NOT WE SHIP THE
DEFINITELY NOT BUT THEY ALWAYS
OUT US.
EVERY TIME.
WHAT IS THE COST GENERAL WHAT IS
THE COST?
NO I I WAS FIGURING YOU KNOW.
SOMEBODY TOLD ME ONCE IT WAS
LIKE FOR A FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR PER INMATEBUT
I YOU THINK IT'S HIGHER SEE
EVERYBODY DEBATE.
SO I DON'T KNOW I MEAN WE FIND
IT IN THE BALLOT ANALYSIS OF THE
PROPOSITION TO END THE DEATH
PENALTY YEAH BUT THE BUT I I I
SAW THAT THE DEAD INCLUDE
EVERYTHING SEE THAT'S THE WHOLE
THING ABOUT THE BALLOT BALLOT
PROPOSITION.
BECAUSE THERE WERE SOME OTHER
CLASSES MORNING COMMUTED SO I I
KIND OF I KIND OF I THINK THAT
THAT SHOULD BE -- THAT SHOULD WE
SHOULD GET.
YOU KNOW LIKE WHAT IT COSTS NOW
OKAY THEM JUST [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
SAYING THAT THAT SOME NAY WE CAN
WORK ON HERE MADAM CHAIR AND
MISTER ATTORNEY GENERAL OF I HAD
I HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS ON THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUES -- WE'RE
FINDING OUT IN THIS COMMITTEE
THAT OF THE POLICE HAVE TRAINING
IN TERMS OF USE OF FORCE.
OUR FROM POST.
BUT THEN WE FOUND OUT IN THIS
COMMITTEE THE MOST POLICE FORCE.
HAVE.
TRADING OF USE OF FORCE THAT'S
NOT.
PART OF CLOSE THEIR THEIR THEY
HIRE CONSULTANTS.
TO DO THE USE OF FORCE TRAINING
AND WE ALSO FOUND OUT THERE'S NO
[inaudible]
SYSTEMATIC -- LICENSING -- STATE.
QUALITY CONTROL KIND OF THINGS
ON THE TRAINING OF USE OF FORCE.
AND I'M INTERESTED IN THAT
BECAUSE I I AUTHORED THE BILLS
ON THE TRAINING.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND THE PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES THAT WAS
PASSED AND NOW WE HAVE A
COMPONENT IN THE POST TRAINING.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND ABLE TO
RECOGNIZE -- OF SOMEBODY WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS OR AUTISM OR OR
SOME KIND OF CONDITION LIKE THAT
SO THEY'LL BE ABLE.
TO UNDERSTAND AND THEN DEVELOP.
OF WAYS OF HELPING.
US SOMEBODY WITH THAT KIND OF
CONDITION SO I'M I'M -- OF I
THINK THAT WAS -- ONE OF MY
LANDMARK BILLS THAT I DID.
SO BUT I AM BUT I'M GONNA LOOK
AT POST A SEE THIS USE OF FORCE.
IS SORT OF CONFLICTING.
MAYBE WITH THE OF MENTAL HEALTH
BECAUSE IF.
IT RELIES TOO MUCH ON INSTINCT
IT COULD WIPE OUT THE LOGICAL
KIND OF EVALUATED AND THAT A LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL ISSUES
BEFORE THEY USE FORCE.
AND AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE BILLS ON
THE SUBJECT HERE.
BUT CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION --
DO YOU THINK THAT -- HOW DO YOU
DO WITH YOUR STAFF ON THE USE OF
FORCE?
DO YOU THINK THAT WE OUGHT TO
HAVE -- HIGHER LEVELS OF
PROTOCOL OR TRAINING OR THESE
OUTSIDE TRAINERS SHOULD THEY BE.
YOU'RE ALSO QUALITY CONTROL
SYSTEM OR WHAT WHAT IS YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT ISSUE.
THERE IS A GREAT QUESTION
BECAUSE YOU HAVE LIKE OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE WITH WEAPONS
YES -- SO -- WHAT WHAT IS YOUR
WE WE TRY TO MAKE USE OF THE --
THE BEST PRACTICES THAT ARE OUT
THERE THAT WE KNOW OF AND WE TRY
TO INSTITUTE THOSE AS BEST WE
CAN WE JUST FINISHED -- THE
FIRST HALF OF REPORT WE DID --
INVOLVING THE SACRAMENTO POLICE
DEPARTMENT -- WHICH I BEGAN LAST
YEAR AS A RESULT OF CHIEF --
DANIEL HYNES IMITATION -- TO
EXAMINE SACRAMENTO'S -- PLEASE --
PRACTICES AND AND POLICIES AND
WE'VE IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF THE
PRACTICES THAT ARE OUT AROUND
THE COUNTRY CLICK HERE
CALIFORNIA ALREADY.
THAT SEEM TO BE THE MOST
PROMISING WHEN IT COMES TO
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
USE OF FORCE.
SO WE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TRY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TELLING FOLKS WHAT SOME OF
THE BEST PRACTICES ARE WE TRY.
TO WHAT DOES A DEFECT IN IN OUR
DEPARTMENT.
AT THIS QUICKLY AS WE CAN AS
WELL.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
FIND IS AS THIS WHOLE DEBATE
MOVES FORWARD ON USE OF FORCE
AND WHERE.
THANK YOU MAY WE TURN TO GO I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO FIND
IS THAT MORE MORE INCLUDING WITH
THE SUPPORT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE TRAINING.
THE PROTOCOLS.
ARE ARE GONNA BECOME REALLY
IMPORTANT AND ESPECIALLY SHOWING
THAT THERE WILL BE
ACCOUNTABILITY IS A RESULT OF
THAT TRAINING IN THOSE PROTOCOS.
AND SHOW TO YOUR POINT BECAUSE I
THINK YOU'RE RIGHT THERE IS NO
ONE STANDARD WHEN IT COMES TO
TRAINING.
EVERY AGENCY CAN DO WHAT IT
WANTS NOT EVERY AGENCY
PARTICIPATES IN POSTAGE
VOLUNTARY.
POST IS OUR STATEWIDE AGENCY TO
TRY TO PROVIDE THAT GUIDANCE AND
TRAINING.
AND I THINK THE MORE WE GET INTO
A STANDARDIZED SYSTEM SO THAT
EVERYONE KNOWS WHAT THIS THE
FLOOR AT LEAST OF TRAINING MUST
BE.
I THINK WE'LL PROBABLY GET
CLOSER TO FINDING A WAY TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS PEOPLE HAVE
ABOUT USE OF FORCE.
THERE'S THERE'S PEOPLE THAT.
JUST KIND OF ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
I OBSERVED IS THERE'S PEOPLE FOR
THESE ON REGISTERED ALL KHôNG
TRAINERS.
THERE'S PEOPLE THAT ARE BROUGHT
IN FROM OUTSIDE A CALIFORNIA
THEIR THEIR THEIR PEOPLE THAT
ARE NOT FAMILIAR WITH CALIFORNIA
LAWS.
YOU KNOW THAT WE APPROVE.
AND THEN THEY TRAIN LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON THE USE OF FORCE
BASED ON OF CURRICULUM THAT THEY
DEVELOP AND THEN THEY FOR MEN
AND TRAIN OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
CALIFORNIA.
PEACE OFFICERS -- ON THE USE OF
FORCE THEY HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE OF
OR VERY LIMITED YOU KNOW NO
CREDENTIALED KNOWLEDGE OF LOS.
AND THAT KIND OF DISTURBS ME A
LITTLE BIT OKAY.
BECAUSE HOW CAN THEY TRAIN
SOMEBODY ON USE OF FORCE WITHOUT
KNOWING WHAT THE CALIFORNIA LAWS
OR AND AND THEY MAY BE DIFFERENT
THAN.
IN GEORGIA OR FLORIDA OR SOME
OTHER PLACE.
AND I DON'T I DON'T I DON'T
THINK.
THEREIS ANY REGISTRATION
QUALITY CONTROL.
YOU KNOW I I SEE SOME OF THE
VIDEOS IS SERVE LIKE.
YOU KNOW SUBJECTIVE.
YOU KNOW THINKING.
WARY IF YOU THINK SOMETHING'S
GOING TO HAPPEN AND YOU BETTER
ACT FAST BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU
COULD BE IN DANGER YOUR PERSONAL
SAFETY.
SO THIS KIND OF FACTORS ARE VERY --
VERY IMPORTANT -- AND AND I
THINK THE PUBLIC IS CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS AND WE HAVE LAWS ON
THIS COMING UP -- I I WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR INVESTIGATION OF
THAT THE UNREGISTERED.
PEOPLE THAT COME IN THERE'S NO.
AND PERHAPS YOU COULD ADVISE US
ON A PROPER LAW THAT COULD BE
DEVELOPED.
REGARDING THAT.
I CAN ARE YOU.
RIGHT OFF THE BAT BECAUSE
TRAINING IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
IS LEGISLATIVE.
RIGHT CALIFORNIA STATUTE AND
THAT EACH AGENCY WHOSE ABOUT THE
PROCESS OF GETTING THE TRAINING
AND THE AND THE START AT NEW
PEOPLE TO START UP.
BASED ON TRAINING THAT THEY
RECEIVED THAT -- I WOULD I WOULD
AGREE THAT THERE'S A NEED TO TRY
TO STANDARDIZE THE TRAINING THAT
WE UNDERSTAND THAT ANYONE WHO
WORKS LAW ENFORCEMENT CALIFORNIA.
AS ESSENTIALLY RECEIVED LEAST
THAT MINIMAL AMOUNT THAT WE
THINK WOULD BE REQUIRED BEFORE
YOU START -- PATROLLING STREETS.
WHETHER YOU COULD ACTUALLY
STANDARDIZED IT.
IN A WAY BY STATUTE IS ANOTHER
QUESTION BECAUSE WITH YOUR RURAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY VERSES LA
COUNTY.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE DIFFERENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT APPLY AND
ALTHOUGH I THINK IF SO LONG AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS AND
UNDERSTANDING THAT WERE WHAT
WHICH WE'RE WE'RE MOVING TOWARDS
THE BEST PRACTICES.
AND THOSE BEST PRACTICES HAVE TO
BE NEW ONES FOR THE DIFFERENT.
NEEDS AND CIRCUMSTANCES OF EACH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY AND I
THINK WE'LL GET THERE AND I
THINK YOU'RE GONNA HAVE THE
SUPPORT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
YEAH I THINK OF MY IDEAS LIKE
SOMEBODY OUGHT TO BE LOOKING AT
THESE CURRICULUMS THE MAN.
RON YOU KNOW YOU DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY COME IN FROM
DIFFERENT PLACES.
AND THEN SOMEBODY ELSE SAY WELL
THAT'S OKAY THAT ONE MEETS OUR
STANDARDS.
I WAS ON SOME KIND OF PROCESS
FOR THAT YOU KNOW.
AND I WILL SAY THAT THERE IS A
LOT OF PROFESSIONALISM IN THIS
AREA WHERE YOU HAVE.
A NUMBER OF ENTITIES AND
AGENCIES THAT HAVE TAKEN ON THE
TASK OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
THOSE BEST PRACTICES AND SO YOU
CAN TURN TO SOME REALLY -- NOT
JUST DOWN TO FOLKS WHO HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF EXPERIENCE IN THIS
FIELD BUT WHO SHOWN THAT THEY
CAN PRODUCE THE PRODUCT WHEN IT
COMES.
TO A BEST PRACTICES YES OKAY I
HEARD I HADN'T -- PASS LAWS HERE
AND WE EXPECTED FORCE ONE OF OUR
LAWS THANK YOU AND AND YOU'RE
THE ONE THAT SAYS AS TO DO A LOT
OF ENFORCEMENT -- SOMETIMES WE
PASS LAWS IN AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES DECIDE THEY DON'T WANT
TO ENFORCE OUR LAWS.
OKAY OR OTHER AGENCIES THEY DO
THAT AND ONE OF THE LAWSUIT WAS
PASSED YOUR THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES HAVE PUBLICLY STATED
THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO FORCE.
IS SB -- FIFTY FOUR THIS IS OUR
STATE LAW REGARDING --
IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR SOMEONE FOR
SPACES THAT DON'T WANT TO
ENFORCE THE PUBLIC HAS STATED.
THEY WON'T ENFORCE THE LAW.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE PASS
A LAW.
AND PEOPLE SWEAR TO UPHOLD THE
LAW THEY MAKE A SWEARING
STATEMENT THAT THEY HAVE TO DO
IT AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
THE SHOULD NOT QUESTION.
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.
AND IF THEY DON'T WANT TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
THE OTHER RUN FOR OFFICE AND
HELP.
WHAT WHOEVER THEY WANT TO GET
ELECTED IN AND GO THROUGH A
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS?
SO CAN YOU COMMENT ON ON SB.
FIFTY FOUR AND AGENCIES THAT
HAVE.
PUBLICLY STATED.
THAT THEY DO NOT.
WANT TO ENFORCE SB.
FIFTY FOUR IF I CAN BEGIN BY
SAYING STARTED TO CENTER
MORLOCKS POINT -- THAT SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOUR LAWS
ARE ACTUALLY CONSTITUTIONAL SB
FIFTY FOURTH PROTESTED.
RIGHT IT HAS BEEN FOUND
CONSTITUTIONAL BECAUSE IT SIMPLY
SAYS THAT THIS IN STATE
CALIFORNIA OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SHOULD BE ABLE TO
CONCENTRATE ON WHAT THE STATE
BELIEVES IT'S IT'S PRIORITIES
AND FOR US IT'S LAW ENFORCEMENT
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND NOT DOING IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT AND SO.
WE'VE ON MORE THAN ONE OCCASION
[inaudible]
IN COURT -- DEFENDED AND ONE ON
SB.
FIFTY FOUR I WILL TELL YOU
CENTER AND I'M I'M I'M I INVITE
YOU TO PROVIDE ME WITH ANY
INFORMATION ON SOME OF THESE
AGENCIES BUT MOST OF THE
AGENCIES I'VE DEALT WITH UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'VE GOT A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
THE FORTUNE SB FIFTY FOUR
BECAUSEI THINK THEY REALIZE
THAT THEY'RE GONNA LOSE THE
COOPERATION OF THE FOLKS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IF THEY'RE PERCEIVED AS TWENTY
TWO IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT --
FOR FOR ICE AND SO WHETHER IT'S
SOUTHERN PART MIDDLE PART UPPER
PART OF THE STATE I THINK MOST
LAW ENFORCEMENT SAYS HEY YOU
KNOW WAT.
IF THIS IS A LOT GOING TO TRY TO
DO IT NOW THERE ARE CERTAINLY
ARE ROGUE YOU KNOW YOU GOT YOUR
FREE AGENTS SOMETIMES A WHAT DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENTLY.
WELL THAT'S A PUBLICLY SO I'M
KIND OF LIKE.
AND LISTEN TO THEIR THEIR
ELECTED OFFICIALS RIGHT
SHERIFF'S EVEN -- SO THEY MAKE
STATEMENTS I MEAN IT'S IT'S LIKE.
IT'S PRETTY WELL KNOWN THAT.
CERTAIN SHARES OF SAID.
THEY DON'T WANT TO FORCE SB
FIFTY FOUR AND EVEN IN CASES
WHERE PUBLIC COMMENTS HAVE BEEN
MADE BY CERTAIN ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
PRACTICAL APPLICATION.
IT'S NOT BEEN THE WITH THE DEED
IS NOT CONFORM TO THE WORD AND
SO BUT WE MADE IT VERY CLEAR TO
ALL THE AGENCIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
SB IFTY FOUR SO LAW THE STATE
AND IT'S OUR JOB TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S BEING ENFORCED AND SO
YOU HAVE A LOVELY VIEW OR SOME
KIND OF PROCESS TO REVIEW --
CASES THAT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN THE INTERACTION WITH THE
IMMIGRATION -- IS THERE A WAY TO
AUDIT.
OR OR TO LOOK AT THOSE CASES.
WHERE COMMUNICATION WAS GIVEN --
REGARDING -- FROM FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT REGARDING YOU KNOW
PEOPLE THAT MAYBE AT A PARKING
TICKET OR TRAFFIC TICKET OR
THOSE KIND OF OFFENSES THAT.
WE PUT IN SB FIFTY FOUR IS NOT.
PERTINENT.
WE PUT THE SERIOUS CRIMES OF
COURSE IN THERE.
TO ALLOW THAT KIND OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERACTION BUT SOME
OF THESE OTHER CRIMES SERVE LIKE.
ROUTINE TRAFFIC TICKETS.
OTHER TIMES A MINOR MINOR ISSUES.
WE A WE HAVE PUT OUT THE WORD WE
PUT OUT GUIDANCE IS FIRST AND
FOREMOST TO SAID TO GIVE.
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE CALIFORNIA A SENSE OF
HOW -- THE WAS IT SHOULD BE
ENFORCED AT LEAST GIVING THEM
GUIDANCE AS TO HOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WILL
EXPECT THEM TO BE ENFORCED.
AND THEN WE WILL -- TAKE ON ANY
MATTER IF SOMEONE BRINGS --
INFORMATION TO OUR ATTENTION
THAT MAY SHOW THAT WAS MAY NOT
BE -- ENFORCE THE WAY THEY
SHOULD ARE NOT BEING IMPLEMENTED
THERE WAS A TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
AS WELL.
AS LONG FIRST REQUIRED TO
DISCLOSE [inaudible]
IF THE GAVE INFORMATION TO ICE
THE ARMY TO CLOSE THIS CLOSE IN
FROM YOU KNOW THAT THEY WERE.
GIVING INFORMATION TO ICE.
ARE THEY REQUIRED TO GIVE THAT
INFORMATION OR IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT COULD BE.
THE SALMON -- I'D I KNOW NOTHING
THAT AFFIRMATIVELY REQUIRES THEM
TO DISCLOSE BUT THEY HAVE TO
RECORD ALL OTHER ACTIVITIES AND
SO THERE WOULD BE A RECORD OF
ANYTHING THEY'RE DOING AT LEAST.
MAYBE DOCTOR SAYING BUT
CERTAINLY ANY ACTIVITIES THAT
THEY'RE UNDERTAKING THEY
PROBABLY HAVE RECORDS OF WHAT
THEY'VE DONE BECAUSE YOU'RE
DEALING WITH.
IN MOST CASES -- INDIVIDUALS
EITHER.
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OR IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM YEAH
OKAY -- ANOTHER.
ONE AND THE LAST QUESTION I'M
SURE I JUST -- THREE THE AND
THAT'S IT THE ICE.
THE HAS CONTRACTED WITH PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS TO RUN.
FACILITIES ARE LOCATED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS A PRIVATE OWNED FACILITIES
[inaudible]
THAT.
HAVE CHILDREN OF VARIOUS PEOPLE
IN THEM OF THE DIFFERENT LEVELS --
HOWEVER WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
SUCCESSFULLY [inaudible]
EXAMINE OR DETERMINE THE QUALITY
OR ANY OF THOSE KINDS OF THINGS.
IT SEEMS TO ME IF A PRIVATE
FACILITIES LOCATED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
OF THEY'RE NOT A FEDERAL
FACILITY EVEN THOUGH THEY MIGHT
HAVE A FEDERAL.
CONTRACT AND THEY'RE MAKING A
PROFIT OR MONEY OFF OF THE
FEDERAL CONTRACT ASSUME THAT.
WHY ELSE WOULD THEY DO IT RIGHT?
THEY SHOULD -- THEY SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO OBSERVE OUR STATE.
LICENSING LAWS REGARDING THE
PROTECTION OF CHILDREN PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS -- THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS ORGANIZATION --
RECENTLY WROTE A REPORT.
THAT WE RECEIVED ON THE FACILITY
IN.
A TOWN ON A BLUE IS ADELANTE.
LARGE FACILITY THERE THAT
THEY'RE NOW TALKING ABOUT
CLOSING CITY VALENTI.
I THINK GOT A HOLE THAT RECORDS
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS.
WHERE THEY HAD CHILDREN IN A
PRISON LIKE ENVIRONMENT
[inaudible]
SO -- WITHOUT.
IS WOULD YOU RECOMMEND WHAT
WOULD YOU RECOMMEND WE DO TO
REGULATE PROPERLY THESE PRIVATE
FACILITIES.
PRIVATE PRISONS IF YOU WILL THAT
ARE LOCATED IN CALIFORNIA.
AND HOW WOULD WE WOULD WE WOULD.
WHAT WHAT WOULD YOU RECOMMEND WE
DO REGARDING THOSE TYPES OF
FACILITIES FACILITIES TO ASSURE
THE OBSERVER?
THE STANDARDS WHICH WE HAVE FOR
FACILITIES WITH CHILDREN AND ALL
THAT KIND OF THING DO YOU HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT -- YOU'VE
ALREADY IN QUITE A BIT AS YOU
KNOW -- IN PROVIDING THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO INSPECT THESE
VARIOUS CIVIL IMMIGRATION
DETENTION FACILITIES.
WE JUST ISSUED OUR FIRST REPORT --
AFTER THAT WATER PERFECT I CAN
MENTION A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
IN A SECOND YOU ALSO -- PROVIDED --
FOR RESTRICTIONS ON WHEN A LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CONTRACT.
A USING PUBLIC RESOURCES WITH
IMMIGRATION -- AUTHORITIES TO
DETAIN PEOPLE AND SO ON THE
REPORT THAT WE ISSUED AND WE DID
GO TO OTHER UNTIL AS WELL -- BUT
WE DID HAVE LIMITED -- ACCESS
BECAUSE ICE WOULD BURST
RESTRICTED HOW MUCH WE COULD DO
BUT WE HAVE.
ADDED LITIGATE THAT LAW THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED THEY
GAVE US THE AUTHORITY.
TO INSPECT THE VARIOUS I THINK
OR TEN OR ELEVEN DETENTION
FACILITIES.
AND WE HAD IT HAS SURVIVED A
TESTED IN COURT AND SO WE
CONTINUE TO INSPECT I WILL AS
YOU MENTIONED SENATOR I THINK
IT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT.
MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE MOVING
AWAY FROM TRYING TO REACH
CONTRACTS WITH ICE TO DO THE
DETENTION WORK.
BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE.
SOME LIMITED CONTROL OVER WHAT'S
DONE.
AND AND I THINK SOME OF THESE
JURISDICTIONS ARE MOVING AWAY
FROM DOING THAT.
YEAH THE DISABILITY RIGHTS SO
ORGANIZATION THAT DID REPORT
THEY HAVE A FEDERALLY.
A FEDERAL STATUTE RIGHT TO
INSPECT THOSE FACILITIES AS WELL
AS A STATE STATUTE RIGHT TO
EXPECT THOSE FACILITIES WITHOUT
HINDRANCE.
SO THEY'RE ALLOWED A MUCH
BROADER.
OF ALLOWANCE FOR INSPECTING TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT CIVIL
RIGHTS ON THE DISABILITIES KLAY --
PRESENTED -- THE INFORMATION. TO
OUR MENTAL HEALTH CAUCUS IN THE
SENATE.
THEY CAME TO OUR MEETING AND DID
A PRESENTATION ABOUT.
EXACTLY WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
IN THOSE FACILITIES AND WE WERE
SHOCKED WE WERE QUITE FRANKLY
SHOCKED AT THE WAY CHILDREN ARE
TREATED AS PRISON INMATES.
AND I THINK ESPECIALLY WITH THE
KIDS AND THE WAY THEY'RE BEING
TREATED.
WE NEED TO WE NEED TO ACT
QUICKLY TO PREVENT ANY OF THESE
FACILITIES EVER TREATED
CHILDREN'S AS PRISONERS IN IN IN
A AND TOLERABLE.
MANNER.
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AS
WELL THEY WERE TREATING PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES OF SOMEBODY
HAD A FOR EXAMPLE SOMEBODY HAD.
A MENTAL HEALTH OF TRAUMA.
REACTION TO BEING IN IN ONE OF
THOSE FACILITIES -- THEY WOULD
BE PUT IN A SHOE FACILITY AND
THEY'RE LIKE A SEGREGATED
HOUSING.
ISSUES.
EN EN OF THESE DETENTION
FACILITIES AND YOU KNOW LOCKED
IN A SINGLE CELL WUSHU FACILITY.
WHICH IS LIKE THE WORST THING
YOU CAN DO FIRST.
TRAUMA PSYCHOTIC BREAKDOWN
HAPPENING YOU KNOW YOU SHOULD
THAT SHOULD BE A MEDICAL ISSUE.
TO TREAT HIM WITH THE MEDICAL
CARE.
SO SO I THINK THE I THINK WE
NEED.
HIGHERLEVELS OF INSPECTION AND
ENFORCEMENT OF STATE LAWS.
OUR REGARDING THOSE RESOURCES I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR.
FROM YOU IN THE ADVICE OF WHAT
FURTHER WE COULD DO IN THAT AREA
IF YOU IF YOU.
I THINK THE IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT CIVIL RIGHTS THING IT
MIGHT.
THE THE AUTHORITY YOU GAVE US TO
CONTINUE DOING THE POTENTIAL
WORK IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
PROBABLY THE THE THE THE MOST
CRITICAL ASPECT OF THAT WORK IS
THE FACT THAT.
THESE CENTERS KNOW THAT.
WE'RE GONNA GO IN AND INSPECT.
AND IT.
SUNSHINE IS THE BEST
DISINFECTANT AND SO THE MORE
THAT WERE ABLE TO ASK SOME LIGHT.
ON THE CENTERS I THINK YOU'LL
FIND THAT THE CENTERS WILL TO
THE DEGREE THAT THEY HAVE EITHER
CONTRACTS OR GOVERNMENTAL OF THE
THIRTY TO DO THE DETENTION.
THEN I I THINK WHAT YOU'LL FIND
IS THAT THEY WOULD TRY TO DO THE
BEST THEY CAN.
WITH THE LAWS THAT REQUIRE THEM
TO PRO PROVIDE SOME OF THOSE
PROTECTIONS THAT YOU MENTION.
AND SO I'D SAY THAT IF YOU
CONTINUE TO JUST SUPPORT -- THE
LEGISLATION THAT NOW IS LAW THAT
ALLOWS US FOR THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
TO DO THOSE INSPECTIONS THAT
THAT WILL BE A GREAT WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT TO THE DEGREE THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE DETENTION
IMMIGRATION CIVIL IMMIGRATION
DETENTION IN CALIFORNIA.
AT LEAST WE KNOW THAT THE THE
RIGHTS AND OF PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THOSE FACILITIES WILL BE
PROTECTED AND THE CONDITIONS
WILL BE WHAT ARE EXPECTED
CALIFORNIA LAW.
DOES DOES CENTERED RAZA WHO'S
GOT A LEGISLATION -- ON THE
SUBJECT AND SHE WAS AT OUR
MEETING.
AND PASSED OUT THE INFORMATION
SHE'S GOING TO ATTEMPT.
TO WORK WITH ALL OF US SAID THAT
ARE INTERESTED IN THIS -- AS THE
LEAD IN THE SENATE ON THE
SUBJECT SO.
WE WE WE REALLY THINK THIS IS
IMPORTANT -- THIS IS GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT THAT.
THE THE CHILDREN AND JUST
EVERYBODY THAT'S IN THOSE
FACILITIES ARE TREATED.
IN A MATTER CONSISTENT WITH
CALIFORNIA LAWS THAT WE HAVE.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
CERTAINLY.
AND CENTER MORE LEFT.
YOU MAY -- YES [inaudible]
I'M YES.
THE APP S. REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ARE GOING TO END.
IS THAT CORRECT.
SO WE HAVE TO KEEP CAñADA
AUTHORIZED THE THE APPS PROGRAM
AND SO -- THE WORK WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE DOING IT AND THE
GOVERNOR HAS BEEN SUPPORTIVE.
AND SO WE NEED TO CONTINUE HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO HAVE THE APPS
IS A PROGRAM WORK WHICH ALLOWS
OUR AGENTS TO GO OUT AND AND AND
DO THIS WORK WITH THE RESOURCES
THAT WE GET.
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE
SHOULD BE OPERATING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
MAYBE WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT IT.
RICK IN OUR GIVE ME SOME MORE OF
YOUR THINKING SO I UNDERSTAND
BETTER WELL IF IF IF WE HAVE TO
WE HAVE TO RE AUTHORIZE.
AND I'M UST TRYING TO MAKE SURE
I GOT IT YOU SHOULD BE DOING THE
APP YES.
CONSTANTLY RIGHT INTO YOU GET
DOWN TO ZERO RIGHT.
RIGHT BUT YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE.
AND IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
REPORTING COMPONENT IS.
BEING ELIMINATED IN SO I'M WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A CONTINUE
SO WE HAVE THE IT'S PERFECTLY
LEGITIMATE TO ASK THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ANY QUESTIONS YOU'D LIKE
ON APPS WE DO HAVE THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO GET INTO EVEN
MORE DISCUSSION.
ON THAT ONE BECAUSE WE HAVE IT
ON OUR IT IS LITERALLY THE NEXT
ISSUE ITEM.
AND WE CAN GET INTO MORE DETAIL
WHICH I HOPE TO ALSO
[inaudible]
ON AND ONE MORE QUESTION
CERTAINLY YES THIS ONE IS THE
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY AND I'M
NOT SURE HOW LONG EIJI STAYING
BUT THIS OPPORTUNITY AS OVER
OVER VIEWS AND THEN WE'RE GOING
MORE DETAIL NO NO YOU GO AHEAD.
NO GO AHEAD GO AHEAD -- THERE
WAS A BILL THAT WAS APPROVED
LAST YEAR AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR THAT -- WOULD PROVIDE
MORE FULL DISCLOSURE YOU JUST
USED ARM.
SUNSHINE IS REALLY.
BUT IT SEEMS WITH RELATING TO SB
ALL FORTY ONE THAT YOU'RE.
NOT RELEASING INFORMATION THAT
CASE THE FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE SB
PUTS RIGHT THAT'S WHAT I MEANT.
THANK YOU FOR DYSLEXIA.
I'M SORRY MANAGER.
THAT ARE ASKED ME THE QUESTION
AGAIN PLEASE.
FULL DISCLOSURE.
FOR POLICE RECORDS AND THE REST
SEEMS TO ME THAT YOUR THIS FROM
MY READING THAT THAT YOU'RE NOT
BEING COOPERATIVE WITH THIS
SUNSHINE OPPORTUNITY -- AND THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT POINT.
BECAUSE I THINK THE THE FACT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
ACHIEVE THIS MILESTONE TO PASS.
THE THE LEGISLATION -- WAS WAS
CRITICAL. TO THAT TRANSPARENCY.
IN THE PROCESS OF PASSING THE
LEGISLATION -- THE THE NEW THE
NEW LAW NOW.
CHANGES A REGIME WE HAD BEFORE
WHERE SOME OF THE INFORMATION
THAT WOULD NOW BE DISCLOSED.
USED TO BE CONSIDERED PRIVATE
INFORMATION.
AND A QUESTION QUESTIONS BEGAN
TO BE RAISED ABOUT WHETHER.
THE THE LAW WOULD APPLY MOVING
FORWARD FROM THE DATA BECAME
EFFECTIVE.
OR IF IT WOULD APPLY TO ALL DATA
THAT'S BEING HELD INCLUDING
PRIVATE DATA THAT PREVIOUSLY HAD
PROTECTIONS UNDER LAW. FOR
PRIVACY REASONS.
I I'VE ALWAYS TAKEN THE POSITION
THAT WHEN IT COMES TO PRIVACY.
YOUR ONE CHANCE TO DO IT RIGHT
[inaudible]
IF YOU.
AND FINE BUT IF YOU DISCO SO
MUCH PRIVATE INFORMATION AND YOU
WERE WRONG.
YOU CAN'T UNRING THAT BELL.
THAT PRIVATE INFORMATION IS NOW
OUT THERE. FOR EVERYONE TO SEE
AND YOU CANNOT SORT OF PULL IT
BACK.
AND SO BECAUSE THERE WERE
CONFLICTING -- ACTIONS BY OUR
COURTED TRYING TO INTERPRET --
SB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE POSITION I
TOOK WAS THAT AS SOON AS I HAVE
A A CERTAINTY OF A POSITION FROM
THE COURTS.
I WILL DO IT WE'RE READY TO
DISCLOSE IF THAT'S WHAT THE
COURTS SAY IN FACT WE ARE RIGHT
NOW IN COURT ON A CASE IT
APPLIES TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHERE [inaudible]
STATEMENT.
THAT IF BELIEVE THAT THE
INFORMATION THE DATA THREE
TWENTY NINETEEN SHOULD ALSO BE
DISCLOSED.
SO I I HAVE A FEELING WE SEE
WHERE THE COURTS ARE GOING TO
TAKE US.
AND AS SOON AS WE HAVE.
ANOFFICIAL DECISION ON THE
MERITS WILL BE PREPARED TO ACT
BASED ON THAT MITCHELL DECISION --
THERE BEEN A NUMBER OF CASES
THAT HAVE COME UP.
SEVERAL OF THEM HAVE SAID THE
INFORMATION THREE TWENTY
NINETEEN SHOULD BE DISCLOSED.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF SAID THAT
ARE SAID TO HOLD OFF STILL AS WE
GET CLOSER TO DISCUSSING THE
MERITS OF THE CASE.
I HOPE SOON THAT WILL HAVE A OF
A RESOLUTION ON THE MERITS.
SO THAT DAHLE AGENCIES WILL HAVE
A SENSE OF HOW THEY COULD OF PUT
FORWARD THIS INFORMATION.
WE ARE FOR EXAMPLE IN THE
SACRAMENTO CASE OF THE STUFF ON
CLARK SHOOTING -- BECAUSE WE DID
THAT IN COOPERATION WITH THE
SACRAMENTO POLICE DEPARTMENT --
IN THE SECOND POLICE DEPARTMENT
AS INDICATED THAT IT'S GOING TO
PROVIDE ALL THE ALL THE RECORDS
THAT WERE USED.
DURING IT THEIR INVESTIGATION OF
THE SHOOTING -- BECAUSE WE WERE
PART OF THAT I'VE MADE THE
DECISION.
AND I HAVE THE DISCRETION TO
MAKE THAT DECISION TO DISCLOSE
IN THAT PARTICULAR CASE OF THAT
INVESTIGATION WE WILL DISCLOSE
ALL RECORDS THAT WE HAVE WERE
PRIVY TO AS WELL.
INCLUDING THOSE THAT ARE PRE.
TWENTY NINETEEN THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR [inaudible]
CERTAINLY.
I WILL A TALK ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE MORE BUT I WANTED TO
RETURN.
TO SEVEN BECAUSE THIS OPENING IS
SORT OF THE OVERVIEW.
AND WHAT I NOTE I RAISED IN MY
COMMENTS IN CHANGING THE AGENDA
THAT THERE'S ON THAT MANY OF THE
BCP'S RE RECEIVED THIS YEAR.
ARE ALL GENERAL FUND INCREASES
NOW.
YOUR DEPARTMENTS BUDGET WHICH IF
WE WERE TO ACCEPT EVERYTHING
THAT IS BEFORE US WOULD GO UP TO
ABOUT A BILLION.
IN THIS UPCOMING YEAR IT'S A
MIXTURE OF GENERAL FUND AND
SPECIAL FUNDS -- AND CERTAINLY
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED LAWS
THAT TO INCREASE YOUR WORKLOAD.
BUT INTERESTINGLY WE HAVE ALSO
PASSED MANY LAWS THAT WOULD
DECREASE YOUR WORKLOAD AND YET
WHAT THE PATTERN THAT I SEE.
IS NOT BCP'S DIRECT KNOWLEDGE
THE DECREASE IN WORKLOAD BUT
RATHER CONTINUAL ONGOING
ASSUMPTIONS OF INCREASING
WORKLOAD.
AND WHAT I NOTE FOR EXAMPLE IS
THE PERIOD.
FROM.
THE SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET TO
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WAS A
SIXTY MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND INCREASE.
SO ISN'T THE MOST SUBSTANTIAL
GENERAL FUND INCREASE SINCE.
OVER A DECADE AND THEN BE
INCREASE THAT'S BEING ASKED THIS
YEAR FOR CHEN JUST GENERAL FUND
WE'RE NOT TALKING ALL THE OTHER
SPECIAL FUNDS.
IS THIRTY SEVEN MILLION SO NOT
AS SIGNIFICANT AS THE SIXTY BUT
WHEN WE LOOK AT ALL OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT IF IF I LOOK FOR
EXAMPLE.
THE GOVERNOR IN HIS PRESENTATION
OF A BUDGET RAISES THE ISSUE
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE -- FAR MORE
UNIVERSAL EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION FOR OUR ZERO TO FOUR
KIDS.
NOW THE GOVERNOR DID NOT PROPOSE
IN THE BUDGET FINDING THAT WOULD
ENABLE THE STATE TO DO IT BUT
THE FUNDING THAT HE ID PROPOSE
TO BEGIN TO EXPAND THAT WERE ALL
ONE TIME ONLY.
AND HE DID THAT BECAUSE IN LEAST
IN HIS ARGUMENT THAT WE HE
COULDN'T PROJECT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE ON GOING REVENUES TO
JUSTIFY.
THE ON GOING EXPENSE.
SO WHY I RECESSES BECAUSE EVERY
DOLLAR SPENT IN GENERAL FUND --
WE SPEND WE AUTHORIZED IN
GENERAL IS COMPETING WITH
AGAINST EVERY OTHER GENERAL FUND.
EXPENDITURE AND SO WHEN I LOOK
AT THAT TOTAL.
AND I LOOK AT LAWS THAT WE ALSO
PASSED THAT REDUCED WORKLOAD --
I I DON'T SEE -- I DON'T SEE THE
SAME RECONCILIATION FROM THE
AG'S OFFICE.
ROGER I'M -- INTERESTED IN
LEARNING WHERE YOU THINK THAT
OUR WORKLOAD HAS GONE DOWN
BECAUSE THE SEX OFFENDER WILL
MAKE YOUR WORKLOAD GO DOWN.
AND MAYBE IN A FEW YEARS BUT NOT
RIGHT NOW KNOWN WE GAVE YOU TEN
MILLION LAST YEAR AND POSITIONS
TO ASSIST THAT AND CERTAINLY IT
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN ADEQUATE.
BUT IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT
ANOTHER SEVENTEEN MILLION IN
THIRTY SEVEN F. T. E. ON GOING
NOT ONE TIME WOULD BE NEEDED
GIVEN THAT AS YOU POINTED OUT
THE WORKLOAD WILL GO DOWN OVER
TIME.
VENTURE LIBYA AMID ASK CHRIS
RYAN WHOSE WE I DON'T WANT TO GO
IN TO GET INTO THAT WHEN IN
GREAT DETAIL THIS IS A OVERVIEW.
OKAY BUT I I I SHOULD HAVE A
SENIOR JUST IN CASE I SEE
SOMETHING THAT'S NOT CORRECT --
BECAUSE HE'S A HEAD OF OUR OUR
OUR BUDGET IS HEAD OF OUR
OPERATIONS DIVISION BUT ALSO --
IS VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE BUDGET.
WHAT I'LL TELL YOU WITH REGARD
TO THE SEXUAL OFFENDER MATTER?
BECAUSE THE TEARING SYSTEM IS
ONE WHERE WE CANNOT GET IT WRONG.
IF WE MISS CLASSIFY.
A AND OFFENDER AS OF LESS.
SERIOUS OF AN OFFENDER THAN WHAT
HE OR SHE MAY TRULY BE AND AS A
RESULT THAT PERSON IS REMOVED
FROM.
IDENTIFY LESS.
WITH NO ONE WANTS TO TAKE THE
THE THE THE CHURCH WE MAKE THE
WRONG DECISION.
AND SO BECAUSE THIS IS A TOTAL
CHANGE IN THE WAY WE CLASSIFY.
WE TALKED ABOUT WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO GET IT DONE IN THE TIME
FRAME THAT WAS CALLED FOR BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
CHRIS CAN GET INTO THE DETAILS
AT SOME POINT LATER IF YOU LIKE
BUT WHAT WE ASK FOR WAS JUST SO
THAT WE COULD MEET.
THE PHARMACIST OR OR THE REQUEST
THAT WERE MADE IN THE
LEGISLATION FOR US TO BE TO MEET.
THAT SEX OFFENDER TEARING
PROCESS.
WHICH IS A GREAT GREAT THING TO
DO BECAUSE SOMEONE WHO IS A VERY
LOW LEVEL OFFENDER HAS BEEN A
LONG TIME COULD NOT BE
CLASSIFIED.
WITH THE WORST THE WORST.
IT'S JUST THAT WE CANNOT MAKE A
MISTAKE.
AND SO WE'RE WHAT WE DID WAS WE
AT THANK YOU VERY MUCH BECAUSE
YOU GAVE US A CHANCE TO REALLY
DO IT THE RIGHT WAY.
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT IS TO BE
ASKED TO DO SOMETHING AND THEN
NOT BE ABLE TO DELIVER.
WHEN YOU BASS?
BUT I WE CAN I DON'T WANT T GO
INTO MORE DETAIL ON IT NOW
BECAUSE MY STAFF WILL HAVE LOTS
OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU WHICH YOU
CAN THEN WE CAN GO INTO DETAIL
ON IT LATER BUT CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE NONE OF US WANT TO
HAVE.
ANYBODY WRONGLY PUT ON A TWO
YEAR.
IT'S HARD TO SEE WHY WE WOULD
NEED THIRTY SEVEN NEW F. T. E.
ON TOP OF THE F. T. EITHER WE
GRANTED TO ACHIEVE THAT.
WHEN THEY'RE SAID NO MORE THAN
FOR ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND SIX
VENDORS ADDED PER YEAR BUT WE
WILL GET INTO THAT DETAIL LATER?
WE'RE GOING TO SOME OTHER ISSUES --
AND WE'LL GET MORE INTO THIS IN
THE APPS DISCUSSION BUT FOR
EXAMPLE SENATOR MORE LOCK RAISED.
THE ISSUE AROUND THE LOCAL
AGENCIES.
AND YOUR RESPONSE WAS YES IN
MANY CASES ARE LOCAL AGENCIES
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOLKS ARE PAID
BETTER THAN OUR STATE.
ON IN JUST STEPPING BACK MY
POINT ABOUT THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING THING WAS MORE THAT
IT WAS.
IT FELT TO ME LIKE WE WERE
DESCRIBING OURSELVES AS A VICTIM
OF SOMETHING VERSES OF SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE A LITTLE MORE
INFLUENCE OVER.
CERTAINLY SO THAT THAT WAS WHY I
INTERVENED IN THAT LINE OF
QUESTIONING JUST BECAUSE WAIT A
MINUTE WE'RE NOT IT'S THIS IS
NOT JUST.
THROWN DOWN ON US WE HAVE THERE
IS A ROLE WE HAVE BEEN IF WE
FEEL THAT.
THE AGREEMENT THAT WE'VE MADE
WITH THE SET OF STAFF THAT ARE
FULFILLING AN OBLIGATION WE FEEL
WE HAVE AND IT'S NOT ADEQUATE.
FOR IS NOT ADEQUATE COMPENSATION
TO RETAIN THE POSITIONS THAT
THAT SHOULD BE BROUGHT TO THE
ATTENTION BUT THAT SITE THAT'S
WHY RAISE THAT BECAUSE CLEARLY
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
SOMEWHAT FIXABLE.
NOW.
ON THE ISSUE OF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BEING PAID BETTER THAN MANY OF
OUR STATE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS IS TRUE
HOWEVER.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN MANY PLACES SEVEN ELM STREET
IS ALREADY.
JOINING IN IN ENFORCING THE APPS.
NOW.
IF WE MANDATE THAT THEY DO.
YES WE HAVE TO FULLY COVER THE
COSTS [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
IF WE ENGAGE IN COOPERATION WITH
THOSE AGENCIES THAT ARE MORE
THAN WILLING.
TO AND CLEARLY IN OUR MATERIALS
IT EVEN DESCRIBES HOW MUCH
TRAINING AND ALL.
THE YOUR OFFICE HAS DONE WITH
DIFFERENT LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES TO EQUIP THEM TO DO SO.
AND ON ANY YET WHEN DATE HAVE
BEEN DONE SIGN DONE SO.
WE HAVE NOT COVERED THEIR COSTS
WE'VE COVERED THE TRAINING OF IT.
AND WE CERTAINLY COVER YOUR
COSTS FOR UPDATING.
THE APPS WHEN THEY RETRIEVE THE
WEAPON BUT WE'VE NOT.
REIMBURSE THE AGENCY.
FOR BECAUSE WE DON'T NEED TO
UNLESS WE EITHER MANDATED OR
DIRECTLY CONTRACT WITH THEM TO
DO SO.
SO I THINK THAT.
WHAT?
MANY OF US AND WE CAN GET INTO
MORE DETAIL WE JUST DISCUSSED
THIS IN THE THE NEXT I AM BUT I
THINK ROOM.
WHAT MANY OF US ARE IN YOU MADE
THE POINT THAT [inaudible]
DEAR J..
IS BY ITS NATURE A CERTAIN SIZE.
WE DO HAVE A VERY LARGE STATE IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO IMAGINE THAT
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE.
PRESENCE OF DOJ LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN SUCH NUMBERS ACROSS THE STATE
TO BE ABLE.
TO ADEQUATELY HIT ALL THE G.
WERE HUGE STATE.
I'M FOR THAT ENFORCEMENT OF APPS.
WHEREAS WE KNOW WE HAVE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
EVERYWHERE.
AND SO THE MORE THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO ENGAGE IN THE MORE WE
CAN ENCOURAGE THEM TO DO SO.
THE BETTER BECAUSE IT HELPS
ENSURE THAT OUR OBJECTIVES IN
GETTING -- WEAPONS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THOSE PEOPLE ON THE
PROHIBITED PERSONS LAST.
ON SO I THINK.
AND I AM NOT TOO DON'T WANT --
TO INTERPRETER SPEAK FOR MY A
COLLEAGUE ON THE DICE BUT I
THINK THAT FOR MANY OF US WE
WANT TO SEE.
MORE OF THAT ENGAGEMENT.
AND WE ARE WHERE THERE MAY BE
SOME LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
LOCAL THAT REALLY DON'T WANT.
TO BUT THERE ARE MANY THAT HAVE
EXPRESSED THEY REALLY DO WANT
[inaudible]
TO AND SO.
THE END BECAUSE THEY SEE IT AS
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE PUBLIC
SAFETY OF THEIR COMMUNITIES.
SO WE REALLY WANT TO SEE THAT.
AND THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT THERE
MAY NOT BE LEGITIMATE INCREASES
THAT.
THE DOJ MAY NEED FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION BUT CERTAINLY I
WOULD NOT I CANNOT ENTERTAIN.
TRYING TO INCREASE DOJ TO THE
POINT WHERE IT WOULD ACTUALLY
HAVE ADEQUATE STAFFING CAPACITY
TO COVER THIS ENTIRE STATE.
JUST BECAUSE THE NATURE OF THE
MANAGER THE THE REQUESTED
FUNDING WHICH OF THE GOVERNOR --
INCLUDED IN THIS BUDGET DOES NOT --
TAKE US TO THE POINT WHERE WE
COULD COVER THE ENTIRE STATE.
IT'S SIMPLY RIGHTS THIS EXPAND
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE COMING
INTO THE SYSTEM.
THEN WE CAN COVER AND SO -- WE
ARE.
FOR FAR FROM GETTING ANYWHERE
CLOSE TO BEING ABLE TO TRULY
COVER THE ENTIRE STATE.
BUT I CAN -- AGREE COMPLETELY
THAT WE COULD -- WORK CLOSER
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WE
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO IN SENT
THEM TO WANT TO PARTICIPATE
BECAUSE THEY CAN ALREADY DO IT
AS YOU'VE MENTIONED IT IS I'VE
AND MANY HAVE.
MANY HAVE.
IN LIMITED WAYS.
IN VERY LIMITED WAYS.
LA COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE IS A IS
ONE OF THOSE COUNTIES ONE OF
THOSE LOCATIONS THAT REALLY DOES
WANT TO DO THIS BECAUSE IT JUST
SO HAPPENS THAT LA COUNTY HAS
THE MOST NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON THE APPS SYSTEM.
AND THEY KNOW WHAT IT MEANS FOR
THEM IF THEY'RE THESE FOLKS ARE
ROAMING THE STREETS SO THEY WANT
TO WORK CLOSE TO THAT.
BUT I COULD GIVE YOU THE EXAMPLE
OF A CASE IN RIVERSIDE.
OF AN INDIVIDUAL WHO RESIDED IN
RIVERSIDE WHO WAS ON THE APPS
SYSTEM.
SO WE WE HAD THE AUTHORITY TO GO.
RETRIEVE WEAPONS WE FOUND OUT
THAT THE WEAPONS THAT THAT
INDIVIDUAL SAID -- THAT HE
POSSESSED.
HE SAID HAT THEY WERE NO LONGER
IN THE COUNTY RIVERSIDE THEY
WERE WITH -- RELATIVES OR
FRIENDS SOMEWHERE ELSE.
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SHERIFF'S MIGHT
WANT TO WORK WITH US.
BUT THE MOMENT THEY HAVE TO GO
OUTSIDE RIVERSIDE THEY LOSE ALL
JURISDICTION.
AND SO THEY COULD WORK THIS CASE
THE WAY OUR OUR OUR AGE DID ALL
THE WAY THROUGH BECAUSE IT TAKES
WEEKS TO WORK THESE CASES.
BUT THEY HAVE TO STOP AT THE
BORDER.
AND THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO GO
OVER CRISIS TO GET -- GET THOSE
WEAPONS.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT WORRY WE
CAN'T BUT WHAT WE SHOULD DO IS
NOT TRY TO DO ALL THE WORK THAT
RIVERSIDE OR LA COUNTY WOULD
WANT TO DO FOR US WITH US.
WHAT WE SHOULD DO IS?
HAVE A NETWORK THAT WORKS
TOGETHER SO IF RIVERSIDE IS
GONNA DO SOME OF THE APPS
RETRIEVAL.
AND THEY'RE GONNA HAVE.
TO GET SOMEONE WHO'S NOW
CHRISTER COUNTY BORDER.
THEY HAVE A RELATIONSHIP THROUGH
ARE WORKING WITH THEM TASK
FORCES FOR EXAMPLE SO THAT
THERE'S NO DELAY.
WE HAD A SITUATION UP IN THE BAY
AREA WHERE AGAIN THE INDIVIDUAL
WEEK WE HAD THE INDIVIDUAL MAKE
CONTACT THE INDIVIDUAL SAID THE
WEAPONS WITH MY SISTER WHERE'S
YOUR SISTER.
IN ANOTHER CITY WAS IN A
DIFFERENT COUNTY.
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO ARRANGEMENT
WE HAD A WAIT.
TELL OUR AGENTS DROVE ALL THE
WAY IN THE BAY AREA WITH TRAFFIC
TO GO TO THAT CITY THE GOAL
LOCATE THE SISTERTO SEE IF WE
GET THE WEAPON.
AND AND SO.
IT IF WE COULD HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE CITY WHERE
THAT.
SISTER WAS LOCATED SAY CAN YOU
SEND SOME OFFICERS OUT THERE.
AT THAT POINT I THINK IT'S
LEGITIMATE FOR THAT AGE TO SAY
WE WANT THAT RELATIONSHIP
BECAUSE WE WANT TO GET THAT
WEAPON.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT PULL OUR
OFFICERS WERERIGHT NOW DOING
PATROLLING TO GET THAT WEAPON
IT'S GOING TO MOVE THE BOY FROM
SOME OF THE OTHER WORK SO I
THINK LEGITIMATELY THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO SAY.
THIS IS GOING TO TAKE SOME.
RESOURCES FOR US TO DO IT AS
WELL OTHERWISE HE BE DOING IT
RIGHT NOW.
MORE IT'S JUST THAT IT IS
RESOURCES AND WHAT WE WOULD
SUGGEST IS THAT WE HAVE A
PROGRAM AND I THINK I MENTIONED
JUSTICE CENTER MORE OUT
PREVIOUSLY WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
WE'RE CREATING THAT NETWORK.
WHICH DOESN'T COST MONEY.
IT'S THE IMPLEMENTATION WHERE
SOME OF THESE AGENCIES WILL SAY
NOW WE'RE GETTING UP REALLY
AGGRESSIVELY INTO THIS WITH YOU
WE'RE PULLING OUR OUR OFFICERS
FROM WHAT THEY WERE DOING FORTY
SOME OF THIS THAT'S COSTING US
MONEY.
AND TIME THERE'S WHERE I THINK
IT'S A IT'S A FAIR -- A NOTION
TO COME UP WITH RESOURCES FOR
THE BUT THE THE REQUEST THAT WE
HAVE FOR THIS YEAR.
IS NOT TO EXPAND TO DO IT
OURSELVES IS TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY DO.
JUST TO CATCH UP WORK AND THEN
HOPEFULLY DO A BETTER JOB OF
TRYING TO COORDINATE WITH THOSE
AGENCIES BECAUSE LA COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WAS A WE CAN'T
GO THERE ANYMORE.
SO THAT'S WHEN WE HAVE TO TAKE
OVER THE CASE WE CAN'T JUST DROP
IT.
AND SO IT'S IT'S A TIME
INTENSIVE.
LABOR INTENSIVE PROCESS THE
EARLIER WE DO IT AS CENTER MORE
LIKE MISSION THE BETTER WE ARE.
THE MORE WE CAN GET BY AND FOR
THE AGENCIES NOT JUST BOB
FORSMAN THE COURT.
THE EASIER IT WILL BE TO
RETRIEVE SOME OF THESE WEAPONS.
TOMORROW IS THE CAN GET INTO A
BIG DISCUSSION ABOUT IN A SECOND
SO I FEEL LIKE I SHOULD.
MOVE US TO THOSE BUT LET ME JUST
BRING UP TO OTHER POINTS YOU
RAISED -- THE FIVE YOUR WRIST
DESCRIPTION OF SOME OF THE WHAT
I FEEL IS VERY GOOD LITIGATION
THAT YOU'RE PURSUING AROUND
[inaudible]
THE PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S OWN
LAWS RELATIONSHIP TO A
BACKSLIDING THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN.
ARM AND CLEARLY THERE IS -- YOU
KNOW THAT TAKES RESOURCES BUT
YOU ALSO IN IN REFERENCE THE
RESOURCES FOR DEFENDING SOME OF
OUR LAWS THAT ARE.
ON IN OF THE GET CHALLENGED AND
WE KNOW THAT.
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR A LAW THAT
WE PASSED TO GET CHALLENGED.
ON AND IN SOME CASES WE SUCCEED
N. MEANING THAT WE WENT IMPROVE
IT WE PREVAIL IN COURT ARE
LOCKET SO PELTON OTHER CASES NOT.
I'M NOW THE THE DE SOME OF THOSE
LAWSUITS AND AFFECT OUR ELECTIVE
ON OUR PART.
MEANING THE AG'S OFFICE BUT SOME
ARE WE HAVE TO IN OTHER WORDS
ONCE CALIFORNIA PASSES A LAW WE
HAVE TO DEFEND IT.
N. ON SO THERE ARE YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT RESOURCES
THAT COVER KIND OF BOTH -- BUT
IF I TAKE SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
FOR EXAMPLE.
BE.
YOUR DECISION AND YOUR OFFICES
DECISION TO NOT RELEASE RECORDS
HAS NOW RESULTED.
IN THE STATE BEING SUED.
SO WE ARE NOW BEING SUED BECAUSE
WE DID NOT UPHOLD OUR OWN LOT.
NOW YOU DESCRIBED THAT.
YOUR SENSE WAS THAT GIVEN THAT.
THERE WAS -- THE LAW UNTIL SB
[inaudible]
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE CHANGED IT.
THESE INVESTIGATORY RECORDS WERE
NOT.
ALLOWED TO BE PUBLIC.
AND ONCE FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
PASSED AND WENT INTO EFFECT.
THESE RECORDS WERE ALLOWED TO BE
MADE PUBLIC.
AND THERE WERE SOME COURTS THAT
PUTS STAYS.
NOW IN THE THERE ARE SOME COURTS
TO PUT IN STAYS BUT EVERY COURT.
THAT IS HELD A HEARING.
ON THE BILL.
HAS UPHELD THE BILL.
AS WAS INTENDED BY THE
LEGISLATURE WHICH THE TERM
RETROACTIVE IT'S NOT ANY
MATERIAL TERM HERE.
BECAUSE RETROACTIVE WOULD BE.
IF I REQUESTED RECORDS IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTEEN
THE LAW IS NOT IN EFFECT IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT
THE ISSUE OF WHAT RECORDS ARE
AVAILABLE TO ME.
BECAUSE THE LAW WAS A AMENDED
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT IN
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
DEALS WITH RECORDS.
RECORDS THAT AARON AND AGENCIES
POSSESSION.
SO WITH.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AGAIN.
RECORDS THAT ARE IN THE AGENCIES
POSSESSION AS OF THE POINT THAT
THE LAWS IN EFFECT OR THAN
AVAILABLE NOW EVERY COURT SO FAR
HAS APPEALED THAT WHO HAD A ROOT
WHO ACTUALLY HELD HEARINGS.
FURTHER ON MARCH.
TWENTY NINE APPEALS COURT STATE
APPEALS COURT.
ISSUE A STATEWIDE RULING AND IN
THEIR OWN.
THEY INDICATED THAT THIS RULING.
TAKES EFFECT STATEWIDE.
UNTIL A DIFFERENT COURT OF
APPEALS.
IF ONE DOES ACCESS TO OVERTURN
THAT.
SO WE NOW HAVE.
A MARCH TWENTY NINTH RULING BY
AN APPEALS COURT.
YES YOUR OWN OFFICE ISSUED A
LETTER ON APRIL SECOND.
INDICATING YOU'RE STILL.
HOLDING RECORDS YOU ARE NOT
GOING TO BE RELEASING RECORDS.
SO UNDER WHAT SCENARIO.
GIVEN THAT WE NOW HAVE A COURT
RULING ON THIS.
DO YOU GET A GREEN LIGHT.
THE BELL CURVE -- UNLESS YOU'RE
SPEAKING ABOUT A CASE I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE CASE THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT WHERE
THE APPELLATE COURT ISSUED A
RULING THAT WAS A RULING.
THAT WAS BASED ON A PETITION FOR
A RE SENSUALLY A STAY.
IT WAS IN A AGAIN UNLESS THIS IS
A DIFFERENT CASE THIS IS THE
FIRST APPELLATE COURT -- AND IT
WAS A DECISION.
THAT WAS RENDERED ON WHETHER OR
NOT THERE SHOULD BE A STATE.
OF THE TRIAL COURT THE LOWER
COURT COURT ACTIONS.
IT WAS IN AND A RULING ON THE
MERITS OF THE CASE.
IT RULED THAT THE SUPPLIES
STATEWIDE.
AND THAT THE RECORDS WERE THAT
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE APPLY TO
REORDS IN IN AGENCIES
POSSESSION.
AS A AS I SAID F IT MAYBE
THAT'S A DECISION THAT I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH BUT IF IT'S THE
DECISION THAT I BELIEVE YOU'RE
REFERRING.
TO AND THE FIRST BILL COURT.
THEN IT IS NOT A RULING ON THE
MERITS IT WAS A PETITION THAT
WAS FILED -- BY ONE OF THE
PARTIES TO STAY THE LOWER COURT
ACTION.
AND THE THE RULING IS ON WHETHER
OR NOT.
OR IT SHOULD STAY THE LOWER
COURT ACTION YES AND THE LOWER
COURTS ACTION WAS ON THE MERITS
SO IN OTHER WORDS EVERY COURT
THAT IS HEARD IT ON THE MERITS
HAS RULED THAT THEIR RECORDS CAN
BE RELEASED.
AND SO THE APPELLATE COURT JUST
UP HELD THAT.
BRITISH ON THIS DAY ISSUE BUT IT
DID NOT RULE ON THE MERITS OF
THE CASE IT MADE A VERY CLEAR
STATEMENT.
THAT DOESN'T GO TO THE TO THE
NEED -- TO TO MAKE A DECISION ON
THE ON THE PETITION FOR THIS DAY
BUT WHAT IT DID MAKE AS I SAID
IN MY OWN -- REMARKS IS THAT IT
MADE A VERY CLEAR STATEMENT
ABOUT WHERE IT WAS HEADING.
I GET THAT.
AND SOON I BELIEVE YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE A DECISION ON THE MERITS
THAT WE CAN RELY ON BECAUSE THAT
QUIRK FUNDS AND WHAT COURT.
SORRY THERE IS COURT THAT'S IN
COURT IS GOING TO HEAR THE CASE.
THE AGAIN THE RULING BY THE
COURT DOESN'T DISPOSE OF THE
ISSUE.
THE RULING THAT THE COURT ISSUED
SIMPLY SAID WE'RE NOT GOING TO
STAY IN FORSMAN.
WHILE WE GET READY TO LISTEN TO
THE CASE.
SO IT WAS NOT A RULING ON THE
CASE ITSELF ON THE MERITS OF THE
CASE IT WAS A RULING ON A
PETITION BY ONE OF THE PARTIES A
WHERE IT WHILE WE'RE GOING TO
WHERE YOU CAN REVIEW THIS.
PUT A HOLD ON EVERYTHING THE
COURT SAID OF THE VIDEO SO THE
DIFFICULTY I'M HAVING IS THAT.
AS THE PERSON WHO IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR IN AFFECTING FORCING THE LOS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE PRESIDENT'S IN PREVIOUS IN
ALL PREVIOUS COURT RULING TO NOT
TO DO WITH JUST FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE BUT IN GENERAL AROUND THE
ENACTMENT OF LAWS.
IS AN FIVE I DON'T HAVE -- RIGHT
IN FRONT OF ME THESE COUPLE OF
CASES THAT I'M GONNA RIP
REFERENCE BUT I DID IN IT
INDEPENDENT -- COMMUNICATION TO
CITE THEM [inaudible]
THAT. EIGHT LOCALITIES WHOEVER
THAT ONE CANNOT OPT NOT TO
FOLLOW A LAW THAT WAS ENACTED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ASSUMING THAT.
THE LAW IS GOING TO BE.
THEN REVERSED BY THE COURT SO IN
OTHER WORDS THE THERE ARE
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPREME COURT
RULINGS THAT BASICALLY SAY ONCE
THE LAWS ENACTED.
EVEN IF SOMEONE SUSPECTS THAT IT
MIGHT BE OVERTURNED THAT UNTIL
THE COURT ACTS TO OVERTURN IT.
AT A LOSS TO BE RESPECTED ENOUGH
FELT.
SO.
THAT FIRST AND FOREMOST WE'VE
NOT YET HAD ANY COURT ON THE
MERITS.
REVERSE THE LOCK.
SO THE LAW IS IN PLACE IT WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
AND SO I GUESS FOR ME THE
TROUBLE IS AS OUR ENFORCER OF
OUR STATE LAWS.
WHY IS IT THAT?
YOU ARE NOT HONORING THAT LAW.
LET ME USE YOUR FRAMING OF OF
THE MATTER AND HOPEFULLY THIS
WILL EXPLAIN.
IF THIS WERE A CASE WHERE IT WAS
SIMPLY A MATTER OF INTERPRETING.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE THIS NEW LAW
AND WHAT WE DO WITH REGARD TO
RECORDS.
THAT PREVIOUSLY WERE NOT
DISCLOSED.
UNDER A PUBLIC RECORDS ACT.
I COULD UNDERSTAND.
THE CONCERN YOU RAISE ABOUT THE
THE LEGAL INTERPRETATION OF WHAT
WE WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE NEW
STATUTES.
AND HOW YOU SHOULD INTERPRET AND
YOU SHOULD WAIT FOR COURT TO
MAKE A DECISION.
BUT AS YOU SAID ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS MY JOB IS TO ENFORCE
IN A POLL TO LAWS.
THERE IS A PARTY THERE WERE
PARTICULAR WHAT'S.
THAT WERE IN THE BOOKS EXISTING
BEFORE SB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE
BECAME LAW THAT PROTECTED.
PRIVATE INFORMATION OF OFFICERS.
THAT EXISTED IN LAW FOR QUITE
SOME TIME.
THERE IS NO RULING IN ANY COURT
SAYING THAT THAT LAW IS NO
LONGER IN EFFECT NO BUT FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE REVERSE THOSE WERE
THAT WAS AS YOU POINTED OUT A
LAW THAT THE LEGISLATURE PUT SO
THAT STATUTE OF PROTECTION.
WAS PUT IN EFFECT BY THE
LEGISLATURE THE LEGISLATURE THEN
REVERSED THAT STATUTE.
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING ABOUT YOUR THAT. FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE CHANGE THE THE TYPES
OF DOCUMENTS AT A PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT.
REACH.
BUT THERE WAS NOTHING IN YOUR
BILL THAT PASSED THAT.
AS EXPRESSLY.
AND DID THE PRIVACY PROTECTIONS
THAT ALONG FORSMAN OFFICERS HAVE
HAD.
AND SO WHAT I SAID.
IN TRYING TO RESPOND TO REQUESTS
FOR THOSE PUBLIC RECORDS THAT-PRE DATED JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN IS.
THERE IS AN ISSUE BECAUSE YOU
HAVE EXISTING LAWS THAT PROTECT.
THE PRIVACY OF INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT -- FORTY TWENTY ONE THOSE
WHO -- OURS IS THE PROPONENTS
YOU YOU AND OTHERS HAVE SAID AND
DID THOSE [inaudible]
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS.
MY SENSES AND ESPECIALLY GIVEN
THAT THE STATEMENT BY THAT
APPELLATE COURT RECENTLY THAT
THAT'S WHERE THE COURTS WILL GO.
BUT I CAN'T GO BASED ON WHAT WE
THINK THE COURTS MAY DO ONCE I
PROVIDE DOES PRIVACY RECORDS OF
THOSE.
POLICE OFFICERS.
CAN'T PULL THEM BACK IF THE
COURT SHOULD ULTIMATELY END UP
RULING.
NO THOSE ARE STILL PROTECTED
BECAUSE FOURTEEN TO TWENTY ONE
DIDN'T EXPRESSLY -- REPEAL THE
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE IF I COULD IF YOU GIVE ME
ONE ONE MINUTE THE ME EXPLAIN SO
WHAT THE POSITION I'VE TAKEN.
I AM RIGHT OW BEING SUED BY THE
DRUG ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
BECAUSE THE DRUG ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY WANTS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
RECORDS PHARMACEUTICAL RECORDS
PER PRESCRIPTION RECORDS OF
CALIFORNIANS.
UNDER OUR CURE SYSTEM ARCHERS
DATABASE WHERE WE KEEP FOLLOWS
PRESCRIPTION RECORDS OF
CALIFORNIANS -- THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THEY WANT THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE
DOING SOME INVESTIGATIONS.
WE WANT TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
THOSE RECORDS.
THEY ARE TRYING TO SECURE THOSE
RECORDS THROUGH WHAT'S CALLED AN
ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENA WHICH IS
SHORT OF A WARRANT.
WE'VE GOING FOR JUDICIAL
MAGISTRATE TO GET A WARRANT. TO
GET ACCESS TO PRIVATE
INFORMATION IN OUR CURES
DATABASE OF CALIFORNIANS
PRESCRIPTION ACTIVITIES.
WE ASK D. E. A.. TO TO PROVIDE
US WITH THE THE DETAILS OF WHAT
THEY WERE PLANNING TO USE THOSE
RECORDS THAT THEY WERE GONNA
ACCESS OF CALIFORNIANS.
FOR AND TO COMMIT THAT THEY
WOULD USE IT ONLY FOR THAT
PURPOSE.
IN THEIR INVESTIGATION.
D. A. SAID NO WE DON'T NEED TO
DO THAT.
WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO GET
THOSE RECORDS TO OUR
ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENA.
I SAID YOU MIGHT BUT THERE'S A
COURT A FEDERAL COURT RULING.
THAT SAYS THAT PRIVATE
INFORMATION CAN I JUST BE
SECURED.
AT WILL AND SO WE TOOK THE
POSITION THAT WE EVEN THOUGH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES HAVE --
PRIMACY IN THESE MATTERS THAT
UNTIL COR TELLS BE THAT I HAVE
TO LET GO OF A CALIFORNIANS.
PRIVATE.
PRESCRIPTION DRUG INFORMATION
THAT I'M NOT GOING TO RELEASE IT
TO BECAUSE SOMEONE SAYS THAT.
IT'S OKAY AND SO.
IN THE IN THIS SENSE OF FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE OR IN THE CASE OF THE
D. E. A. REQUESTED --
PRESCRIPTION DRUG RECORDS.
IF I'M TOLD BY QUIRK.
THAT I MUST RELEASED I WILL BUT
UNTIL THEN I WANT TO PROTECT
PEOPLE'S PRIVACY AS BEST I CAN
MISTER MISTER.
I WILL AT IT IS AN INTERESTING
ANALOGY BUT IT IS -- NOT EVEN
APPLES TO ORANGES I WOULD CALL
IT APPLES TO A PIECE OF STEAK.
AND THE REASON IS YOU ARE
REFERENCING WHAT A FEDERAL
AGENCY WANTS FROM YOU THAT WOULD
BE POTENTIALLY IF I UNDERSTAND
CORRECTLY IN DEFIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW.
WHAT I AM REFERENCING IS A?
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW WELL YOU
FIFTY CURES YOU SAID IS PRIVATE.
SO THERE'S BEEN NO ACTION THAT
I'M AWARE OF BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
THAT WOULD SAY TO YOU.
RELEASE THOSE RECORDS TO THAT
THE D. E. A. ONCE.
THERE HAS BEEN AN ACTION BY THE
STATE LEGISLATURE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR AND UP HELD BY THE
APPELLATE COURT. TO MAKE A
CERTAIN AND LIMITED SET OF
INVESTIGATORY RECORDS NOW PUBLIC.
SO IT IS VERY DIFFICULT.
TO SET IN THIS SEAT.
AND HAVE THAT ANALOGY BE MADE AS
TO WHY THAT IS SOMEHOW SIMILAR
TO YOUR DE A CASE.
BUT SECONDARILY IT RACES.
WELL I DON'T HAVE A PARTICULAR
OTHER LAW THAT I CAN BRING UP
RIGHT NOW BUT I'M SURE IN A HALF
AN HOUR OR SO ONE WILL COME TO
ME.
THAT IT'S RATE LIKE AN ELECTIVE
DECISION AS TO WHICH OF OUR
LARGE WILL ENFORCE IN WHICH YOU
WANT SO I AM CERTAIN THAT THERE
ARE OTHER PRIVACY LAWS.
OR LAWS RELATING TO SOME ASPECT
OF WHAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
PERCEIVED TO BE A PREVIOUSLY
PROTECTED PRIVACY RIGHT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CHANGED. FOR
WHICH I AM NOT AWARE THAT THE
AG'S OFFICE THAN DID NOT ENFORCE.
SO I IT.
IS A I THINK THAT -- I WOULD
SUBMIT THAT THE AGENCY HAS PUT
ITSELF IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION IN RELATIONSHIP TO
BEING THE ENTITY THAT UP HOLD
CALIFORNIA STATE LAWS AND YET IN
THIS CASE HAS CHOSEN.
NOT TO FOLLOW.
THE LAW.
VENTURE AYE AYE I RESPECT THE
POSITION TAKEN I APPRECIATED
THAT AND I UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING.
AND I HOPE THAT YOU'LL
APPRECIATE THE POSITION I'M IN
IN TRYING TO ENFORCE OUR LAWS
THERE WERE OTHER LAWS IN EFFECT
BEFORE.
FORTY TWENTY ONE THAT PROTECTED
THE PRIVACY OF INDIVIDUALS
INFORMATION IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THOSE ARE NOT IN AYE ABLE NOT
DENIABLE BUT MOST EVERY LAW WE
ENACT.
NOT ALL BUT MOST EVERYONE WE
ON DOES.
A PREVIOUS STATUTES SO WE'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT FOR NOW --
WE'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT IN A
SEPARATE.
I APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
DISCUSSION ON ANY OTHER OVERVIEW
COMMENTS FOR GET INTO OUR ITEMS
[inaudible]
KNOWN.
I'M GLAD THE DISCUSSION OF THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY MEDICAL
CENTER IS OVER WITH WITH YOU --
I WOULD CHOOSE I HOPE THAT THAT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
I'M JUST ON ACTUALLY CENTER IT'S
ALMOST IT IN MANY WAYS --
THERE'S A SIMILARITY IN THAT --
THAT'S WHY I'M RISEN IS YEAH.
YEAH.
MY JOB IS TO BE I'M LEARNING THE
NATURE OF YOU.
AND IT'S A DELL PC VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION YOU'RE
LEARNING THE NATURE MADE THOUGH.
THE DIP THE DIFFICULTY FOR ME IS
THAT.
ONCE YOU [inaudible]
GIVEAWAY.
CERTAIN RIGHTS IN THIS CASE
PRIVACY OF YOU JUST KEPT PULLING
BACK AND SO IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE A MOVE WE MAKE A MOVE.
LIKE THAT IS THE LEGISLATURE'S
PROACTIVE IT IS BACK BENCHER AND
THAT'S WHY AT THE END OF THE DAY
WHEN THESE COURTS RULE WE WILL
BE READY TO DO WHATEVER THE
COURTS TELL US.
AND WE DON'T MAKE SURE WE DO IT
RIGHT.
A GIVEN THAT THIS IS A BUDGET
HEARING MY ONLY LAST COMMENT
ABOUT THAT WOULD BE THE FACT
THAT.
PART AS YOU RACE AND YOU WERE
THE PERSON THAT RACE THIS THAT
HE'S VERY SCORE CASES TAKE
RESOURCES AND SO THE COURT CASES
THAT ARE NOW SUING YOU ON THIS
QUESTION ARE ONES THAT YOU
ELECTED.
TO HAVE TO MAKE US VULNERABLE TO
AND YOU WILL HAVE TO USE
RESOURCES TO DEFEND IT.
WHEN YOU WOULD HAVE HAD THE
OPTION TO ABOUT FELT THE LAW?
I I APPRECIATE WE'RE SAYING I'M
JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE WE GET
A CLARIFICATION FROM THE COURTS
AND I THINK IT'S WORTHWHILE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO THIS THE
RIGHT WAY.
PEOPLE'S PRIVACY IS CRITICAL AND
IF I'M GONNA DISCLOSE PEOPLE'S
PRIVATE INFORMATION ESPECIALLY
IF YOU WANT A PROFESSION THAT
PREVIOUSLY HAD THAT PROTECTION.
I'M GONNA MAKE SURE I DO IT THE
RIGHT WAY.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO -- TO THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS.
AND I MEAN WE ALREADY HAD YOUR
UPDATE THANK YOU WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GET INTO THE APPS.
AND THE I'M SURE SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS WE'VE ALREADY RAISED.
WE WON'T HAVE TO REPEAT -- AND
CERTAINLY IN THE PRESENTATION
NOW ANYTHING THAT YOU HAVE
ALREADY RAISED WOULD APPRECIATE
ALSO IF WE DON'T REPEAT JUST SO
THAT.
ALL OF US KNOW WE HAVE A LOT
MORE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA AND WE
CAN USE OUR TIME.
JEFF IT'S OKAY WITH RIGHT YOU IN
THE COMMITTEE I WILL STAY AS
LONG AS I CAN BUT OBVIOUSLY I'VE
GOT THE EXPERTS HERE.
OKAY EXCELLENT SO.
THIS IS THE BUREAU FARMS
WORKLOAD AND APPS --
INVESTIGATIONS GO AHEAD THE
BCP'S RELATED TO IT.
MENTOR CHRIS RYAN THE CHIEF OF
THE DIVISION OPERATIONS AND THIS
PROPOSAL REQUEST. FORTY THREE
POSITIONS AND SIX POINT NINE
MILLION IN FUNDING IN NINETEN
TWENTY AND SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION ON GOING IN THE DEALER'S
RECORD OF SALE.
A SPECIAL ACCOUNT FUNDING THE
REQUESTED FUNDING WILL SUPPORT
NINETEEN NEW POSITIONS TWENTY
FOUR POSITIONS CURRENTLY.
WORKING IN THE BLANKET AND
TWENTY POSITIONS WITH LIMITED
TERM FUNDING.
THE POSITION OF AUTHORITY IS
EXPIRED SO IT'S A IT'S A
COMBINATION OF ISSUES -- GOING
ON HERE THIS PROPOSAL SEEKS A
PERMANENT FUNDING SOLUTION TO
SUPPORT THE BUREAU'S CRITICAL
TIME SENSITIVE REGULATORY
WORKLOAD WHICH CAN NO LONGER BE
TEMPORARILY ABSORBED.
AND MARTIN WHO RAN THE DIRECTOR
IS HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
I KNOW MY COLLEAGUES WE HAVE
ASKED SOME ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
ONES I GUESS THE ONE I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK BUT IS GIVEN THAT.
SOME OF THIS IS -- RELATED TO
THE DROSS.
COUNTING FUNDS WE HAVE FROM
DROST.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
AGENCY HAS THE AUTHORITY. TO
ADDRESS THE DROSS FEE BASED ON
INFLATION.
AND I DON'T SEE THAT THE AGENCY
HAS PUT FORWARD ANY RECORD ANY
MOTION TO DO SO WE DON'T YOU
DON'T EVEN NEED OUR APPROVAL FOR
THAT.
BUT WHAT I DO SEE IS A REQUEST
FOR GENERAL FUND THAT MIGHT.
AT SOME LEVEL OF IT MIGHT BE
COVERED IF THE FEE WERE ADJUSTED
TO COVER THE AND WHAT'S AT THE
INFLATION SINCE THE LAST TIME.
THE MANAGER THERE IS CURRENT
AUTHORITY TO ADJUST THE FEE --
RELATED TO THE DRESS FUND IN THE
GAS PROGRAM HOWEVER THE PROPOSAL
FOR THE GENERAL FUND TO REQUEST
RELATES TO THE APPS PROGRAM.
AND SO THE THE PROPOSAL WOULD
FIND THAT THERE IS IT AFTER
PROPOSAL -- THAT WOULD BE FUNDED
BY THE GENERAL FUND.
RATHER THAN USING THE FEE SOURCE
FROM THE DEALER RECORD OF SALE
FIND.
THAT THAT'S THE PRIMARY
DIFFERENCE WHY YOU'RE SEEING --
GENERAL FUND ASK AND THEN
THERE'S ANOTHER FUND -- FOR THE
THE THE PRIMARY ADDRESS -- FOR
ACTIVITIES IS READY TO SCRIBES
THAT THERE IS OPERATIONAL
SHORTFALL OF GROSS AND NET IT
ALSO DESCRIBES TRYING TO MAKE UP
SOME GENERAL FUND FOR THAT
OPERATIONAL SHORTFALL.
SO WHAT I'M RAISING IS.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT THE
SHORTFALL WOULD BE ONCE THE FEE
WAS ADJUSTED.
DUE TO A BASED ON THE AUTHORITY
YOU HALF.
OVER TO DO A FEE INCREASE.
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS --
WE WOULD HAVE TO INCREASE IT I
BELIEVE IT'S SIX DOLLARS RIGHT
NOW SIX OR SEVEN DOLLARS TO KEEP
UP.
I'M NOT ASKING THAT I'M ASKING
YOU FOR YOU HAVE THE AUTHORITY.
TO ADJUST THE FEE BASED ON THE
INFLATIONARY.
AND IT WOULD IT MIGHT NOT GIVE
YOU THE FULL RECOVERY BUT IT.
AND I DON'T I DON'T HAVE AN
ESTIMATE I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
WHAT THAT.
MIGHT PROVIDE YOU IN TERMS OF
REVENUE BUT IT WOULD GIVE ME
THEN A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT YOU
WOULD NEED TO AND THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN.
THAT.
REVENUE.
AND WHAT GENERAL FUND BACKFILL
WE MAY NEED.
SO.
I'M JUST I UNDERSTAND AND AND I
RELATES PRIMARILY TO THOSE
ACTIVITIES THAT OUR APPS PROGRAM
RELATED.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A DIFFERENCE
IN THE MATERIALS I HALF BUT
THAT'S OKAY BUT I THINK A WOULD
BE.
USE FOR AT LEAST.
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD APPRECIATE.
I'M GETTING SOME ESTIMATE OF
WHAT REVENUE THE DROSS ACCOUNT
WOULD RECEIVE.
IF THE FIGHT FEE WAS ADJUSTED
FOR INFLATION.
OKAY AND WE CAN WORK WITH STAFF
TO GET THAT GREAT.
GREAT CENTER MOORLACH -- I'M
JUST CURIOUS HOW YOU INTEND TO
HIRE THE TWENTY SIX POSITIONS.
SB ELEVEN YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARTIN RAN
DIRECTOR OF GIRL FARMS.
SO ARE HIRING METHODOLOGIES HAVE
CONTINUED -- AS THEY HAVE IN THE
PAST AND WE WOULD CONTINUE WERE
WERE HOPING FOR CONTRACT
NEGOTIATIONS IMPROVED -- PAY
PACKAGES THAT WILL FURTHER ALLOW
US TO BETTER RECRUIT AND RETAIN
INDIVIDUALS -- BUT EVEN IF THAT.
DOES NOT HAPPEN WE ARE DOING OUR
BEST.
TO ADVERTISE AND AND AND DO
EXAMINATIONS FOUR TIMES A YEAR
WE'RE JUST HAVING A LOT OF
DIFFICULTY NOWADAYS BECAUSE OF
OUR OUR PAY LEVELS HAD STAYED
RELATIVELY -- STAGNANT FOR SOLAR
YEARS WIPING A LOT OF AGENCIES
HAVE GRADUALLY INCREASED.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT WITH THE
PENSION SYSTEM MODIFICATIONS WE
WOULD NORMALLY ON A REGULAR
BASIS RECRUIT INDIVIDUALS THAT
WERE EXPERIENCED INVESTIGATORS
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
BUT BAY ARE GRANDFATHERED IN TO
THE PREVIOUS PENSION SYSTEM SO
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO LEAVE AND
COME TO THE STATE -- THEY WOULD
NOW COME INTO THE NEW LOWER TIER.
SO -- THAT ALSO MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US -- TO RECRUIT
AND AND HIGHER INDIVIDUALS WE'RE
STILL PROGRESSING DOWN THAT PATH
IT'S JUST A MUCH.
SLOWER PROCESS AND THERE'S FEWER
INDIVIDUALS -- TO EXAMINED
DURING THE TESTING AND SELECTION
PROCESS.
WHICH IS ALL ALREADY VERY
DIFFICULT SO THE THE FAILURE
RATE BASED ON EXAMINATIONS --
POLYGRAPH MEDICAL PSYCHOLOGICAL
THERE'S THERE'S A HIGH -- DROP
OUT RATE DURING THAT PROCESS
MANY YEARS AGO WE HAD.
UPWARDS OF TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT WOULD TAKE THE EXAMINATION.
WHEN THEY WERE OFFERED --
NOWADAYS IT'S IN THE HUNDREDS.
SO WE WILL CONTINUE WITH OUR
PROCESS TO RECRUIT -- AND GET
OUT AND EXPRESS FURTHER WHAT W
DO HOW WE DO IT HOW WE CAN HELP
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
AND TRY TO RECRUIT FOLKS OVER IT
JUST MAKES IT MUCH MORE.
DIFFICULT GIVEN THE CURRENT --
SALARY DISPARITY THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
IS IT CONSIDERED AN ENTRY LEVEL
POSITION.
WELL WE HAVE TWO POSITIONS --
THAT WE WOULD BRING IN AS ENTRY
LEVEL ONE WOULD BE -- AN
EXPERIENCED LAW ENFORCEMENT
INVESTIGATOR COULD LATERAL INTO
OUR AGENCY.
THE OTHER WHICH IS MORE OF THE
ENTRY LEVEL POSITION THAT WE
WOULD COMPETE WITH WITH LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WOULD
BE SOMEBODY WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE WITH NO LAW ENFORCEMENT
EXPERIENCE.
WE CAN BRING THEM ON AND SEND
THEM TO THROUGH A FULL POLICE
ACADEMY.
AND START THEM IN THE PROCESS AS
AN INVESTIGATOR THROUGH THAT
ROUTE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS OUR ENTRY
LOWEST LEVEL POSITION AND IT
PAYS FAR LESS THAN -- LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FOR ENTRY
LEVEL POSITIONS.
THANK YOU MAKE MANAGER
[inaudible]
THE IT DOES SEEM WHEN WE LOOK AT
THEM MATERIALS THAT THE WHILE
THE BUDGET WELL THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED A BUDGET THAT DID.
INCREASE FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF APPS
ENFORCEMENT AND INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF POSITIONS.
AS YOU'VE STATED YOU WERE ABLE.
TO RETAIN OR YOU DIDN'T ACHIEVE
THAT NUMBER OF POSITIONS SO.
I GUESS THE WHAT.
WHAT PART OF OUR QUESTION IS
TRYING TO GET AT IS IF IT REALLY
IS A PROBLEM OF THE?
SALARY -- THE STATE WIDE -- I
FORGET WHAT THE WORD IS CAUGHT
WHAT YOU KNOW WHEN THE SETTING
OF THE SALARY THAT ON THE STATE
LIST.
WHAT IT SET AT [inaudible]
IS.
ONE I GUESS WHY ISN'T THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TALKING IN
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT AN
APPROPRIATE ADJUSTMENTS.
BECAUSE YEAH CLASSIFICATION
AFTERWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU
CLASSIFICATION THANK YOU --
CLASSIFICATION RIGHT BECAUSE WE
END UP.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
THEY DON'T GET FILLED.
BUT WE DON'T NECESSARILY EACH
YEAR AS WE LOOK AT ALL RIGHT
THERE STORY -- ACT LIKE THEY'RE
STILL WORKLOAD SO WHEN WE HAD
MORE POSITIONS BUT IT'S LIKE
WE'RE ADDING POSITIONS ON TOP OF
POSITIONS BUT POSITIONS ARE AN
EVEN FELT SO WE DON'T REALLY
EVEN KNOW.
IF THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS WERE
ADDING.
ARE EITHER TOO MANY OR
INADEQUATE OR ADEQUATE BECAUSE
YOU DON'T HAVE THE THEM FULLY
STAFFED YET FOR US TO MAKE ANY
OF THAT KIND OF DETERMINATION SO
IF THE PROBLEM IS THAT
CLASSIFICATION.
A MENTOR YOU YOU'VE YOU'VE
ESSENTIALLY REPEAT WHAT I'VE
SAID TO MY TEAM AND WE SAID TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS AND THAT IS.
IS THERE SOME WAY FOR US TO
WORKING WITHIN THE REGIME WE
HAVE AND PART OF IT IS SOMETHING.
WE CAN'T DEAL WITH THAT DIRECTLY
CAUSE IS THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS IS YOUR LAST
VACATION IS AND YOU CAN GET THE
CLASSIFICATIONS CAN'T GET
ADJUSTED BY AND AND AND SO WE
BASS IS THERE SOME WAY THAT WE
COULD.
CHANGE THE CLASSIFICATIONS FOR
THESE POSITIONS SO THEY COULD BE
AT A HIGHER LEVEL SO THAT WE WE
COULD COMPETE. FOR SOME OF THE
PEOPLE MIGHT WANT TO COME AND
WORK WITH US BUT IF THEY'RE AT
THOSE LOWER CATEGORIES IT DOES
MAKE IT DIFFICULT THE OTHER
THING THAT I THINK MADE IT
DIFFICULT FOR US IF YOU'RE GOING
BACK TO THAT. TWENTY THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN PERIOD WHEN.
APARTMENT JUST GOT A A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN FUNDING
FOR THE APPS PROGRAM IS THAT IF
YOU LOOK CLOSE YOU'LL FIND THAT
MANY OF THOSE POSITIONS THAT WE
WERE PROVIDED.
WE'RE LIMITED TERM AND SO IF
IT'S ALREADY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
COMPETE BASED ON COMPENSATION
WAGES AND GO AND PENSION AND
BENEFITS.
IT WAS EVEN MORE DIFFICULT IF
YOU COULD DO WE COULD TELL UP
AND BY THE WAY WE CAN ONLY GIVE
YOU THIS POSITION FOR A YEAR SO.
AND SO IT MADE IT REALLY TOUGH
TO HIRE PEOPLE ON IT THAT'S WHY
HAVING PERMANENT POSITIONS MAKES
IT EASIER FOR US TO BRING FOLKS
SAID.
BECAUSE NO ONE'S GOING TO LEAVE
A JOB THAT PAYS MORE GIVES A
BETTER PENSION BENEFITS. TO KNOW
THAT THEIR ONLY GET TO DO FOR A
LIMITED PERIOD OF TIME.
RIGHT SO.
I AM BUT I DON'T WANT TO SOUND
CONTRADICTORY THAT I'M IN FAVOR
OF INCREASING GENERAL FUND AT AT
ALLOCATION HEARING YET I THINK
THAT HE IF WE HAD A BETTER
HANDLE ON WHAT IS THE RIGHT
CLASSIFICATION SALARY TO RETAIN
THE POSITIONS.
WE MIGHT THEN WHILE WE MIGHT SEE
AN INCREASE INITIALLY WE MIGHT
END UP.
NOT HAVING AS MUCH.
THE SAME NUMBER OF FTP NEED OVER
TIME TO MEET THE WORKLOAD
BECAUSE THE F. T. E. WILL.
BE FELT WHICH IS THE SITUATION
WE'RE IN NOW IS IT'S NOT EVEN
FILLED SO IT'S VERY VERY HARD TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE REAL.
WORK LOAD IS THE STAFF LEVEL
OUTPUT FOR THE WORKPLACE IN
STATE WE HAVEN'T EVEN FOR SHORT
[inaudible] ONE FIVE BUT WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
IN ADDITION TO THE BC PLEASE
YOUR HAVE SUBMITTED THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF BILLS GOING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS RIGHT
NOW THE MAYOR MAY NOT HAVE A A
FACTOR IN INFLUENCE ON EITHER
THE WAY WE MIGHT UTILIZE.
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ASSIST
US IN THIS PROCESS OR OTHER
ASPECTS THAT MAY INFORMED THAN
WHAT WE DO.
FINALLY ON THIS BUDGET.
ANY OTHER.
OKAY CENTER ABOUT JUST -- I'VE
BEEN ON THE COMMITTEE LONGER SO
I'VE.
AT A CENTER HANCOCK WAS A
TEACHER AND I WAS ON THE
COMMITTEE -- AT THAT POINT SO
I'VE BEEN ON THE COMMITTEE
LONGEST.
AND WE'VE HEARD THIS OVER AND
OVER HERE'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DO TO REDUCE THE BACKLOG.
GIVE US THIS MONEY AND AND
HERE'S OUR PLAN AND THEN WE
DON'T HIRE THE STAFF AND THEN
THEY COME BACK AND SAY WELL
HERE'S HERE'S OUR PLAN NOW -- WE
WANT TO DO THIS AND AND WILL
REDUCE THE BACKLOG AND WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THIS KIND OF LIKE
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AT THE END.
OF YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT OF
VACANCIES BECAUSE WE CAN'T HIRE
THE SAME THING WITH YOUR YEAR
IT'S ALWAYS THE SAME THING
[inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
I PERCY I PERCEIVE THE MODEL YOU
USE. TO ACCOMPLISH THIS TASK.
IS NOT THE RIGHT MODEL.
YOU HAVE TO REINVENT YOUR MODEL
LOOK AT MAYBE SOME OTHER WAYS OF
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF GUNS ARE
OUT THERE MAYBE -- TECHNOLOGY
TEAM.
OF YOU KNOW THERE MIGHT BE YOU
KNOW IT'S LIKE SOME REINVENTION
OF SOME NEW.
MODEL TO SOLVE YOUR PROBLEM I'D
BE HAPPY TO TO SUPPORT.
IF YOU HAD A DIFFERENT DIRECTION
I THINK THE SAME DIRECTION I
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT I MEAN
I CAN'T.
JUST EVERY YEAR UNTIL I LEAVE
YOUR DO THE SAME THING I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF NOT.
APPROPRIATE I THINK.
OF THIS ISN'T WORKING SO SO
YOU'RE.
EVERY YEAR THERE'S YOU KNOW THE
SAME NUMBER YOU HAVE X. AMOUNT
COMING IN X. AMOUNT GOING OUT
YOU KNOW.
YEAH -- THE PROHIBITED LIST OF
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO HAVE SOME
VERY BASIC WAY OF OF RUNNING
THAT BETTER.
YOU KNOW MAYBE START IN THE
BEGINNING WHERE THEY FIRST GET
ON THERE FOR HIM LISTEN GO BACK
FURTHER.
TRY TO KEEP THEM FROM GETTING ON
THE LIST A REDUCING.
THOSE PEOPLE THERE'S OTHER.
I. T. WAYS OF DOING IT I THINK
SO IT I I THINK.
I THINK YOU'RE IN MAYBE MAYBE
YOU HAVE THE WRONG GROUP OF
STAFF MAYBE YOU IN THE PEOPLE
THAT CAN ASSIST YOUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE MORE MAYBE A
OF THE LOWER LEVELS THE TECH
TEAM.
THAT DOES THE ASSISTANT OR THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT I AM I AM
CONVINCED THAT.
WE NEED TO REINVENT THIS.
PROCESS IN YOUR TEAM TO MAKE IT
WORK EFFECTIVELY.
OF THE WEATHER REASONS WHY IS
YOU KNOW WE YOU KNOW SO SOMEBODY
GETS ON THE LIST AND THEN
THERE'S TOO MUCH TIME.
BEFORE THEIR CHECK IN GUNS ARE
TAKEN AWAY IS JUST IS LIKE
[inaudible]
SELECT DMV.
THE WATER REDUCE THE WAIT TIME
YOU KNOW.
SO SO YOU KNOW IT AND IF IS THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE DOESN'T WORK.
IF -- WE HAVE TO KIND OF
REINVENT THE SYSTEM WE HAVE TO
HAVE A SO THAT'S I DON'T KNOW IF --
IF IN THE MID.
THE TIME IT TAKES.
IF WE CAN HAVE SOME.
IDEAS THAT COULD.
WORK BETTER ON THE WAY WE'RE
DOING IT NOW BECAUSE I'M KIND OF
HARD.
PRESSED TO JUST THROW MORE MONEY
AT IT I MEAN THAT'S I'M NOT I'M
NOT.
THAT'S DOES MARTIN IN A LONG
TIME RIGHT THE SAME.
JENNIFER COULD YES YOU MAY THANK
YOU MANAGER. FIVE RESPOND --
WHAT YOU JUST SAID I ESSENTIALLY
SAID ABOUT A YEAR AGO TO OUR TO
THEIR TEAM I SAID?
WE WE CAN'T EVEN.
TALK ABOUT NUMBERS AND AND HAVE
PEOPLE AGREE WITH WHAT OUR
NUMBERS REFLECT.
SO WE SORT OF STRIP EVERYTHING
DOWN INSTEAD OF MORE LIKE WAS
GOOD ENOUGH TO TO GO THROUGH
THIS WITH US WHEN WE ISSUED A
REPORT.
WE WENT THROUGH AND STRIPPED
DOWN BECAUSE WHAT BACK WINNER
BACKLOG CASES -- THERE WAS NEVER
EVEN A DEFINITION OF WHAT WE
CONSIDER THE BACKLOG AND SO WHAT
WE'VE TRIED TO DO IS ONE WE TRY
TO CLEAR THE DECKS AND MAKE IT
CLEAR WHAT WE'RE DOING.
SO WE'VE IDENTIFIED THE VARIOUS
PEOPLE WHO SIT IN THE APPS
PROGRAM AND WHY.
BUT TO YOUR POINT OF TRYING TO
MAKE THIS WORK BETTER WE WE
THINK WE IN THE PROCESS FIGURED
OUT.
WHAT WE SOME OF THESE WE NEED TO
DO AT FIRST I THINK THE THE
PERSONAL DOING A?
PHENOMENAL -- THESE MEN AND
WOMEN WHO GO OUT THERE NEVER
ONCE IN THE TEN OR SO YEARS THAT
WE'VE BEEN OPERATING.
HAS THERE BEEN AN INCIDENT AND
MORE THAN EIGHTY THOUSAND
WEAPONS HAVE BEEN CONFISCATED
NEVER ONCE HAS ANYONE GOT HURT.
WE DON'T TYPICALLY GO IN WITH
WARRANTS WE HAVE TO ASK.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET FOLKS
TO HELP US AND WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
PROSECUTIONS LIKE THIS THE THE
CASE IMAGINE AND ONLY COUNTY BUT
AS I MENTIONED TO CENTER MORE.
THERE ARE THREE THINGS THAT WE
IDENTIFIED CLEARLY THAT WE COULD
DO RIGHT AWAY AND AND SOME OF IT
WE NEED YOUR HELP WITH SOME A WE
DON'T.
WANT.
THE COORDINATING WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THAT WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO DO IT ALL BY OURSELVES
[inaudible] TWO IF WE GET LAW
ENFORCEMENT LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO JUST LET US KNOW
WHEN THEY FOR TWEET RETRIEVED A
WEAPON RIGHT NOW THERE'S NOTHING
THAT OBLIGATES THEM TO LET US
KNOW HEY WE PICKED UP THIS
WEAPON.
WE'RE WORKING THAT'S PERSON UP
WE'RE DOING ALL THE WORK WE GET
ME TO GO OUT THERE WE FIND OUT
HEY I TURN THAT IN.
A MONTH AGO.
WHENEVER FORMED IS A WE DID ALL
THIS WORK. TO FIND OUT THAT THE
WEAPONS BEEN RETRIEVED IF WE CAN
GET LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
NOTIFY US WHEN THEY RETRIEVE THE
WEAPON.
AND IN THREE AS WE SAID BEFORE.
IS GETTING THE COURTS TO WORK
WITH THIS ANDLOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN THEY HAVE.
ESSENTIALLY SAID.
YOU'RE NOW DONE OR YOU BIãU
BEEN PROSECUTED AND CONVICTED.
AND WE KNOW YOU'VE GOT A WEAPON
BECAUSE WE KNOW HAVE A WEAPON IF.
WEEKS OF TURNER CONSERVE BODY TO
YOUR POINT BEFORE WE LET THEM GO.
GET IT NOW.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO TELL THE COURTS OR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO DO ANY OF THESE
THINGS.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE COOPERATION
WOULD REALLY HAVE AS BEFORE MORE
EFFICIENT AT THE FRONT END.
IS THAT A TRIED TO DO IT
SENATORS YOU MENTIONED AT THE
BACK IN.
THE JUDGE'S SO [inaudible]
THANK.
YOU KNOW I'VE RAISE THE DIE
WAITED TO THE CHIEF.
AND DOES SOME OF THE JUDGES AND
IT'S MORE A MATTER I THINK OF
HAVING THEM INCORPORATED WITHIN
THEIR SYSTEM OF WHAT THEY'RE
DOING -- WOULD BE SURPRISED IF
THEY COULD BE IN SAY IT'S GONNA
TAKE A LITTLE MONEY FOR THEM TO
DO THAT BUT WE JUST DID HAVE
BETTER COURT COORDINATION.
AND MAKING SURE.
GOING WELL DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
JUST FELONY THERE ARE SOME --
DANGEROUS MISDEMEANOR
CONVICTIONS AS WELL AND IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE SOMEONE IS
CONVICTED COULD BE SOMEONE WHO
HAS BEEN -- ADJUDICATED BE
DANGEROUS TO THEMSELVES OR TO
OTHERS OR SOMEONE WHO HAS --
OUTSTANDING.
OUT.
OF ORDERS -- RESTRAINING ORDERS
AGAINST AND THAT GIVES US THE
ABILITY TO GO IN THERE AND
CONFISCATE THESE WEAPONS THERE'S
FELONY CONVICTION -- AS AS A
FAMILY CONDITION IS TO SEND
SINCE IS BEING.
THE THE OTHER CONVICTED AND THEN
THERE'S A SENTENCING HEARING.
BETWEEN THERE ARE.
THEY SHOULD BE BEFORE THEIR
SENTENCE.
THAT COULD BE THE THE TIME YOU
COULD ASK TO GET THE GUNS.
BUT JUST YOUR TURN YOUR GUNS N..
IRAQ IN OUR LINGO IT ALL RIGHT
IN THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
THAT BECAUSE IF THEY DON'T THEN
YOU GOT THE SENTENCING OR YOU
CAN HOLD OVER.
YOU GOT AWESOME DID YOU TURN ON
YOUR CONCEPT [inaudible]
DAHLE [inaudible]
OKAY -- GO BACK TO JAIL WE'RE
GOING TO WAIT TO DO THAT -- TO
THEY WANT ALL THOSE GUNS TURNED
ON BEFORE WE DO THE SENTENCE OR
THE OR YOU CAN SAY WELL YOU TO
AND YOU REFUSE TO COOPERATE.
YOU KNOW.
YOU DON'T HAVE REMORSE GUESS
WHAT YOU KNOW TWO MORE YEARS.
A HEARING -- YOU KNOW THERE'S
WAYS YOU CAN.
THERE'S A PERIOD OF TIME.
WHERE YOU COULD -- HAVE THE
JUDGE.
HELP WITH THE DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
AND LAW ENFORCER AT THAT.
TIME AND HIS FOLKS ARE UNDER
PAROLE.
THEY'RE HAVING TO REPORT THAT
ARE PRO OFFICERS IF WE HAVEN'T
GOTTEN THE WEAPONS YET.
THEY ARE UNDER THAT JURISDICTION
AND WE SHOULD BE A TO GET THE
COOPERATION TO GET THE WATER OUT
IN PAROLE THERE MANY WAYS A NEW
SYSTEM.
IT JUST THE COOPERATION THE
COORDINATION.
SO I KNOW.
WATER IS WHENEVER TENER VOICES
CORPORATION I THINK I YOU KNOW
YOU GOTTA HAVE EVERYBODY
[inaudible]
DOING AT YOU KNOW CROSS TEAM
COLLABORATION.
ANYWAY SO IT'S CLEAR IT'S NOT
ONLY THE MEMBERS OF THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM MANY MANY LEGISLATORS AND
NIGHT -- THAT OBVIOUSLY THE FULL
ENFORCEMENT IMPLEMENTATION OF
OUR APPS PROGRAM IS A PIE HIGH
PRIORITY.
AND SO THE FRUSTRATION IS THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN EVERY YEAR
ATTEMPTS TO EITHER PROVIDE NEW
RESOURCES ARE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO HELP ACHIEVE THAT.
AND STILL FEELING LIKE IT'S NOT
YET ACHIEVED AND OBVIOUSLY THERE
HAS BEEN NEW WORKLOAD THERE BEEN
NEW LAWS THAT ADD.
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE TO THAT LIST
BUT I THINK.
WHAT -- AS WE HOLD THIS OPEN AND
WE LOOK AT THE OTHER BILLSTHAT
ARE GOING TO LEGISLATURE WHICH
MAY AGAIN IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO
TO DO THIS PERHAPS -- IN A
BROADER MORE EFFECTIVELY HOWEVER.
THEN WILL WE CAN CONSIDER THAT
IN THE CONTEXT NOW OBVIOUSLY
WILL PRY BE ADOPTING THE BUDGET
PRIOR.
TO THESE BILLS BEING SUCCESSFUL
OR NOT BUT AT LEAST WE WOULD.
THEY MIGHT INFORM.
THE HOW WE GO FORWARD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND MANY MEN GERMAN
EXCUSE MYSELF AT THIS STAGE BUT
I THINK YOU AND MEMBERS FOR THE
RIGHT PERHAPS RIGHT BEFORE YOU
LEAVE SINCE WE ARE NOW MOVING --
TO AND WE ALREADY HAD A GOOD
DISCUSSION ON THIS BUT WE ARE
MOVING TO ISSUE FIFTEEN WHICH IS
THE SB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE I YOU NEED
TO STAY FOR THE WHOLE THING
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD OBVIOUSLY BIG
DISCUSSION BUT I WOULD SITE
SINCE I HAVE THE FIRST PUBLIC
COURT RULING DIRECTLY IN FRONT
OF ME.
THAT FOR THE REASONS STATED THIS
IS -- I AM NOW READING FROM THE
RULING FOR THE REASONS STATED BY
THE TRIAL COURT APPELLANTS
ARGUMENT IS WITHOUT MERIT.
SO BASICALLY.
THE INTEL THEY DID ROLL ON THE
MERITS.
AND I SAID IT IS WITHOUT MERIT
AND DUST.
WHILE THE RECORDS MAY HAVE BEEN
CREATED PRIOR TO TWENTY NINETEEN
THE EVENT NECESSARY TO TRIGGER
APPLICATION OF THE NEW LAW.
A REQUEST FOR RECORDS MAINTAINED
BY ANY AGENCY NECESSARILY OCCURS
AFTER THE LOSS EFFECTIVE DATE.
SO THE APPELLATE COURT
[inaudible]
RULING.
A AGAIN MA'AM CHAIR AT I I
UNDERSTAND I I KNOW THE LANGUAGE
OF THE USE IT'S JUST THAT THAT
WAS NOT A RULING ON THE MERITS
THAT WAS A RULING ON THE
PETITION FOR A STAY.
I KNOW IT SOUNDS LIKE -- STINKS
THAT BEFORE THE END OF THE DAY I
WILL BE ABLE TO FIND ADDITIONAL
LAWS THAT WERE ENACTED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAD
SOME IMPACT SOMEWHERE ON PRIVACY.
FOR WHICH ENTITIES UP HELD.
N. N. FOLLOWED AND PROBABLY HAD
SUBSEQUENT COURTS.
A RULE IN A WAY THAT EITHER
LIMITED THEM WERE OVERTURNED
THEM BUT NOTHING.
BUT UNTIL THE COURTS FINALLY
ACTED PREVENTED ANY ENTITY FROM.
FOLLOWING THE LAW AS IT WAS
PASSED BEFORE THE COURT
BASICALLY RULED ON THE MERITS TO
NOT UPHOLD THE LAW WHICH AS YOU
INDICATE THERE'S NO COURT.
YET THAT HAS RULED ON THE MERITS
TO UPHOLD IT NO COURT HAS RULED
YET TO NOT UPHOLD IT.
I THINK WE HAVE PIZZA ARRIVING
AT SEVEN MINUTES IF YOU WANT TO
STAVING COULD SHARE PROVIDES
LUNCH IF YOU WANT.
A GRACIOUS IN THE HAVE A REQUEST --
FO SOME POSITIONS AND OF COURSE --
IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE NEEDING ANY
POSITIONS RIGHT NOW GIVEN THAT.
YOU'RE NOT RELEASING RECORDS BUT
MAYBE YOU WILL SOON AND SO THEN
YES MAYBE YOU DO NEED SOME NEW
F. T. GO AHEAD.
AND WITH THIS MY MY TEAM TAKE
OVER FROM HERE MA'AM CHAIRED
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU FOR BEING.
MADAM CHAIR CHRIS RYAN AGAIN
WITH THE DEPARTMENT JUSTICE SO I
REQUEST IS FOR THREE FOR THREE
POSITIONS AND PRICING -- FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
IN GENERAL FND TO PROCESS --
THE WORKLOAD THAT WOULD BE
ACCOMPANIED WITH THIS BILL A
SPECIFICALLY IT'S FOR INCREASED
TO WHAT WE ANTICIPATE TO BE
INCREASED PR A REQUEST --
RELEASE FOR PERSONAL RECORDS
CONSISTING OF PERSONAL FILES
RECORDS TRAINING RECORDS AND
FILES AND THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS --
FILES AND RECORDS AS WELL
[inaudible]
I'M -- WHEN WE DISCUSS THIS IN
RELATIONSHIP TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS BUT THEY ACTUALLY
WERE ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR MANY
MORE POSITIONS?
IT WAS REYES THAT -- THE INITIAL
REQUEST THAT ARE GETTING BEING
RECEIVED NOW.
COVER.
ANY AND ALL RECORDS IN AGENCIES
POSSESSION AND SO OF COURSE THE
WORKLOAD RELATED TO THE INITIAL
REQUEST IS GOING TO BE FAR
HIGHER.
BECAUSE ONCE THOSE RECORDS ARE
RELEASED THEN THE ONLY RECORDS
THAT WOULD PERTAIN ARE THOSE OFF
COMPLETED INVESTIGATIONS.
AND THAT THAT WORK LOAD ONE
WOULD AND COULD VERY WELL -- NO
THAT WOULD BE LOWER -- SO WHERE
DID YOU FACTOR IN.
THE INITIAL LARGE WORKLOAD AND
THEN THE FACT THAT THE WORKLOAD
WOULD BE LOWERED IN TERMS OF
THIS REQUEST.
OUR ESTIMATE AND MARTY CAN SPEAK
MORE TO THE REAL ASSUMED THE ON
GOING NOT NECESSARILY THE THE
BIG BANG AT THE BEGINNING BUT IT
WAS THE RESOURCES NEEDED ON ON
ANNOYS ONLY TO KEEP UP WITH THE
THE REQUEST.
OKAY.
MANAGER DID INCLUDE THE ON GOING --
IN ADDITION TO WHAT CHRIS A
STATED -- THE BUREAU FIREARMS --
SWORN PERSONNEL -- WEAR BODY
CAMERAS ON EVERY ENFORCEMENT
ACTION THEY'RE THE ONLY BUREAU
THAT'S REQUIRED TO DO THAT SO
EVERYTHING RELATED TO THESE
RECORD REQUEST WILL ALSO TYING
INTO.
THE BODY FOOTAGE OF BODY CAMERA
FOOTAGE.
AND REVIEW AND REDACTION OF
CERTAIN INFORMATION THAT.
AND IN ON ON OUR CASES IT'S IT'S
VERY DIFFERENT FROM A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY MAYBE PATROL
YOU MIGHT HAVE ONE PERSON OR TWO
PEOPLE AT AN INCIDENT OR
SOMETHING OCCURS.
WE TYPICALLY HAVE THREE TO SIX
PEOPLE SO YOU HAVE CAMERAS ON
EVERYBODY'S SOUL REQUIRE THE
REVIEW OF ALL OF THOSE VIDEO
FOOTAGE.
ITEMS AND REDUCTION AND SO FORTH.
THOUGH IT IS FOR A VERY LIMITED
SET OF ITS ONLY COMPLETED
INVESTIGATIONS OF SUSTAINED.
INCIDENTS OF TAMPERING WITH.
EVIDENCE WITNESS INTERFERENCE.
ON SEXUAL ASSAULT ON THE JOB.
OR SO IN THOSE CASES.
I WOULD IMAGINE AND AGAIN WE
DON'T KNOW YET BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THE RECORDS RELEASE
BUT I WOULD.
IMAGINE THAT THERE IS NOT THAT
LARGE OF A NUMBER OF RECORDS
WITHIN DO JEEZ DOJ'S POSITION
RELATED TO THAT SORT OF THING.
AND THE OTHER USE OF DEADLY
FORCE.
IS FORCE THAT MAY BE -- MIGHT BE
SLIGHTLY LARGER AND THAT'S OF
COURSE WHERE THE BODY CAM
FOOTAGE WOULD CERTAINLY APPLY --
BUT AGAIN WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO
SEE.
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T SEEN WHAT
RECORDS ARE YOU KNOW YOU MEAN
YOUR POSSESSION DOUBT THAT WOULD
GIVE US SOME SENSE THAT WOULD
GIVE US AN INDICATOR OF WHAT
MIGHT BE NORMAL ON GOING.
SO IT'S HARD TO TO JUDGE.
UNDERSTOOD AND AND AGAIN I THINK
WE WERE TRYING TO GIVE A
REASONABLE ESTIMATE GIVE RIGHT
SPECIFIED AND WHAT WE BELIEVE
THAT THE WORKLOAD WILL BE
INITIALLY.
AND NOT FALL BEHIND ON THE
PROCESS OKAY OKAY.
I DON'T THINK LA -- INTERVIEW
ANY COMMENT ON THIS ONE NOW AND
OKAY.
GO AHEAD SENATOR ABOUT.
SO ON THE BODY CAMERAS ARE GOING
TO TREAT THOSE IS EVIDENCE OF
SOME KIND OF EVIDENCE STANDARD.
FOR THE BODY CAMERA MATERIAL.
YES -- SO IT HAVE EVIDENCE OF
RELATED STANDARD THAT'S SIMILAR
OF CRIMINAL EVIDENCE.
RIGHT YES OKAY AND THEN --
ENTERS A THE BUDGET -- OF IT IS
SENDING WITH THING ANYWHERE I
SERVE YOU'RE GONNA CHARGE FEES
FOR THIS.
BY GOV I MAKE A REQUEST IS THERE
GOING TO BE.
I I'M NOT THAT FAMILIAR WITH
YOUR BILL.
BUT ARE TEY ARE THEY PLANNING
TO HAVE A CHARGE FEES OKAY AND
YOU HAVE A OF EXPECTATION OF
WHAT THE REVENUE YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE.
THAT'S ON THIS PROPOSAL IT
RELATES TO OUR OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT YEAH.
STAFF AND SO RIGHT YOUR YOU ARE
ALLOWED THIS IS A PUBLIC RECORDS
REQUEST TO AND YOU ARE ALLOWED
TO CHARGE FEE BUT ONLY A FEW
RELATED TO THE COST OF COPYING
OF THE MATERIALS YEAH SO WHAT'S
THE WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
SITUATION WITHOUT -- TYPICALLY
WE DO CHARGE FOR PAPER -- FOR
COPYING COSTS -- BUT THERE'S
GONNA BE A LOT OF OTHER COSTS
THAT TECHNO TECHNOLOGY COSTS --
THE EVIDENCE STANDARD YOU
MENTIONED REQUIRES US TO SORT
THINGS ELECTRONICALLY -- SO MOST
OF THIS RELATES TO THOSE COSTS --
FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND AND
THE TECHNOLOGY SO IF YOU HAVE A
OF SO I COME IN I WANT SOMETHING.
THEN YOU HAVE TO DO A LOT OF
TECH WORK TO GIVE ME THAT STUFF
[inaudible]
SAVE NOW.
COPIES OF THE VIDEO TAPES --
INTACT THE GUYS UP.
TO DO SOME WORK TO PREPARE TO
GIVE IT TO THE REQUEST FOR THIS
REQUEST ARE GOING TO BE CHARGED
A FEE FOR THAT ARE.
ALSO DOING THAT OR REFILL OUR WE
TYPICALLY CHARGE FOR THE
SHIPPING COST WHICH DOESN'T
NECESSARILY COVER ALL THE
PERSONNEL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT.
ASSESS YOUR CHARGING A MUCH
REVENUE YOU EXPECT FOR THAT.
I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT CENTER BILL OR IT DON'T
HAVE THAT IN FOR THOSE.
SO THAT COULD BE PART OF THE
BUDGET.
THIS IS SOMETHING ELSE.
I WANT TO GET A CLEAR BECAUSE AN
HONOR -- WHEN SHOULD IT BE IT'S
WITH EXPLICIT?
YOU MAKE A REQUEST ON THIS --
FOR GOING TO HAVE THE REVENUE WE
SHOULD.
WILL HOPEFULLY LIKE MOST EVERY
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY IN
THE STATE THE AGENT'S OFFICE
WILL BE RELEASING RECORDS BEFORE
WE ADOPT THE BUDGET SO THAT WE
HAVE SOME SENSE OF WHAT REAL
WORKLOAD MIGHT REQUIRE -- I A
AIRED IN NOT ASKING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE APPS -- SO IF
THERE IS ANYONE HERE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE APPS.
AND MY APOLOGIES AND AND NOW IF
THERE IS A PUBLIC COMMENT NOT.
YES GO AHEAD VENTURES OKAY IF I
COMMENT ON APPS YES YES I JUST
WANTED TO ADD CLARIFICATION IF
IF THERE WASN'T CLARIFICATION ON
THE VACANCIES.
IT'S NOT THAT BAD IS A STAGNANT
NUMBER OF THE SAME VACANCIES
IT'S A VERY FLUID PROCESS. FOR
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL
THE HIRING PROCESS IS ABOUT
EIGHT MONTHS LONG TO GO THROUGH
A FULL.
INVESTIGATION OF BACKGROUND BUT
IN ADDITION TO THAT BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE LIMITED TERM POSITIONS --
UNFORTUNATELY BUREAU FARMS WAS
MORE LIKE A TRAINING GROUND WE
WOULD HIRE PEOPLE.
AND THEY WOULD MOVE ON EITHER
EITHER TO ANOTHER LONG FIRST
NATIONS SIR TO YOUR OWN RACK
RIGHT THAT'S WHERE WE SAW MOSTLY
RIGHT LOT OF YEAH SO BECAUSE WE
ONLY HAD THE LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS AS SOON AS THEY WERE
ELIGIBLE THEY WOULD PUT ON THE
TRANSFER LIST TO GO. TO A
ANOTHER BUREAU POSITION THAT WAS
A PERMANENT PENSION.
WE WERE CONSTANTLY TRYING TO
FILL BEHIND THE THE FLOW OF
VACANCIES NOT.
NOT THAT WE COULDN'T FILL OUR
VACANCIES IT WAS JUST TRYING TO
KEEP UP WITH THEM RIGHT RIGHT.
OKAY MADAM CHAIR PROVIDING
CLARIFICATION ON APPS MAY I
SUGGEST THAT OF OFFER YOU ON THE
C. P. I. CALCULATION YOU ASKED.
I THINK YOU WERE ASKING WHAT
AMOUNT COULD WE ADJUST RIGHT NOW
UNDER CURRENT STATUTE IN CPR US.
OF ADDRESS FEES AND THAT WOULD
BE SEVEN DOLLARS -- IS WHAT
WE'RE CURRENTLY ALLOWED UNDER
THE STATUTE TO COVER THE FULL
BUDGET ASK THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOW WE WOULD HAVE TO
INCREASE THE FEE TO APPROXIMATE
THIRTEEN TO FIFTEEN DOLLARS --
AND WE CAN PROVIDE THAT
RECONCILIATION THAT'S THAT'S TO
CHRIS THE STAFF.
THANK YOU JUST WANT TO READ THAT
THANK YOU FREE **** ALL RIGHT
NOW PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE
FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE ITEM BEFORE
YOU MOVE TO OUR NEXT ITEM.
ALL RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH IN
COLLEAGUES WILL NOW MOVE TOWARD
NEXT I AM COMFORTABLE.
RIGHT SO ISSUE SIXTEEN THE
DISPOSITIONS WORKLOAD INCREASE.
HE ASKED ABOUT OF WHAT ARE YOU
OKAY WITH MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
SENTENCE GREAT OKAY.
SO WE'RE NOW ON ITEM -- SIXTEEN
PLEASE PROCEED.
OKAY SO THIS IS A REQUEST THAT
FOR TWO POSITIONS AN APPROXIMATE
TWO HUNDRED AND THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- IS SIMILAR TO SOME OF
THE OTHER ITEMS THAT ARE AT THE
TOP OF THE AGENDA WHERE WE HAVE
LEGISLATION -- AND WE'RE ASKING
FOR RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT THE
LEGISLATION ON THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR I'M THERE TO FOR TWO
BILLS -- THAT WE ESTIMATED THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE THERE WAS THERE'S
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH IT --
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
THE RESOURCES [inaudible]
OKAY -- LA -- I DIDN'T CALLING
YOU AROUND APPS MOSTLY BECAUSE
WE KNEW THAT WE WEREN'T ACTING
AND WE KNEW THAT IT WAS GOING TO
BE GREATLY REVISED BY THE TIME
WE GOT IT BUT YOU CERTAINLY YOU
HAD SOME COMMENTS ON THIS PLEASE
PROCEED.
LEE -- ANY DAILY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RELATED TO THIS B. C. P. WE ARE
RECOMMENDING -- TO YOUR LIMITED
TERM FUNDING RATHER THAN ONGOING
FUNDING IS REPLACED BY THE
STATION AND WHEN WE LOOKED AT
THE FOUR PIECES THE WORKLOAD
THAT ARE LISTED AND GENDER
BEFORE YOU -- WE THOUGHT THAT
THE WORKLOAD WAS REALLY EITHER
LIMITED TERM IN NATURE OR AT
THAT THE WORKLOAD WAS UNCERTAIN
BECAUSE A REALLY RELIED ON HOW
PEOPLE WOULD REACT.
ESSENTIALLY TO THE LEGISLATION
AND SO LIMITED TERM FUNDING
WOULD PROVIDE YOU DO WITH THE
RESOURCES TO DO THE WORK BUT
ALSO TO COLLECT INFORMATION ON
THE ACTUAL WORKLOAD IMPACTS AND
TO THE EXTENT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED IN THE
FUTURE.
LEGISLATURE WOULD THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT ACTUAL DATA THAT
THEY CAN ACT ON I'M.
AND OF COURSE WE JUST THE
EXPERIENCE IN HEARD FROM THE
FACT THAT BY OUR LIMITED TERM
FINDING. FOR EXAMPLE IN THE APPS
CASE WE WERE UNABLE TO SUSTAIN
THE FOLKS THAT WE HIRED FOR AS
LONG AS WE MIGHT HAVE INTENDED
BECAUSE AS SOON AS THERE WAS A
PERMANENT POSITION OPEN THEY
MOVED OVER TO IT.
SO I THINK WE'LL AND OBVIOUSLY
HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT I AM I AM
CERTAINLY THERE IS A NUMBER OF
THE ITEMS THAT.
WE HELD.
ON THAT I FEEL WERE POTENTIALLY
ONES THAT ABSOLUTELY SHOULD BE
LIMITED TERM -- IN THIS ONE I
THINK WE'LL I WOULD ENCOURAGE
STAFF TO LOOK AT MORE TO SEE
WHETHER THAT.
WILL WORK IN WITHOUT AND THE
UNINTENDED AND EXPECT YOU KNOW
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO MAKE ANY
COMMENT YEAH MANAGER ON IN THE
BACKGROUND ON THIS PROPOSAL IN
THERE'S A THE OTHER PROPOSAL THE
WRIST RELATES TO LEGISLATION THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE HAS MANY ARE
NUMEROUS BILLS THAT COME THROUGH --
OFTENTIMES WITH VERY SMALL
IMPACT -- BUT IT WE WENT BACK A
YEAR AGO AND WE LOOK AT WHAT THE
IMPACT OF TWENTY THIRTY BILLS
PASSING THAT HAVE A MINOR IMPACT
THERE WAS A COUPLE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND SO WE'VE CHANGED OUR PROCESS --
INTERNALLY TO IDENTIFY THESE UP
FRONT WHEN THEY'RE GOING THROUGH
THE APPROPRIATIONS PROCESS WE WE
ARE YOU KNOW TAGGING THEM WITH
THE SCHOOL IMPACT.
AND THEN TO THE BEST WE CAN
WE'RE PACKAGING THEM ONLY ASK
FOR BUDGET RESOURCES -- SO THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S IN THE BACKGROUND
ON THIS OKAY.
RESHAPED THAT.
I'M.
BERMAN FINANCE YOU DO NEED TO
COMMENT OKAY ANY COMMENTS FOR MY
SMALL POTATOES WILL TAKE.
YOUR LOOK AT LIKE CAN YOU ABSORB
THIS AND WITHIN YOUR BUDGET
[inaudible]
MY COMMENT.
SENATE BILL.
ONE RICHARD PRYOR RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT WILL NOW I PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THAT.
ONE ANYTHING ON ISSUE.
SIXTEEN RIGHT WILL MOVE TO ISSUE
SEVENTEEN THE DNA IDENTIFICATION
FUND REVENUE BACK FILL.
SO THIS IS A SIMILAR PROPOSAL
THAT WAS HER LAST YEAR OKAY.
AND THIS IS A CONTINUED BACKS
BILL -- LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
INCLUDED A TWO YEAR BACK FILL
AND SO THIS IS -- TO ENSURE THAT
THE BACK FILL STAYS IN PLACE
NEXT YEAR -- THAT ALSO I THINK
THERE WAS A EQUIPMENT COMPONENT
LAST YEAR THAT'S IN A SEPARATE
PROPOSAL -- SO BOTH OF THOSE
PROPOSALS ARE ARE ARE BACK THIS
YEAR.
AND VERY MILLER'S WITH ME -- TO
ANSWER ANY OF THE LAB QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
CERTAINLY [inaudible]
OKAY -- THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES.
SOMEONE FINGERPRINT FEES WHICH I
THINK WE HAVE.
WHERE WAS THAT?
ONE THAT'S NOT ON OUR BET ON I
GUESS BY.
YOU KNOW WE WE DO YOU.
THE PASSAGE OF PROP SIXTY NINE
DID GIVE US.
REVENUE FOR THIS PURPOSE -- AND
IF I UNDERSTAND FROM THE
BACKGROUND IMAGE IT'D BE.
THAT THAT REVENUES BEEN DROPPING --
THERE'S ALSO SOME DISCUSSION
AROUND FORTY SEVEN BUT I AT THAT
WOULD ALSO INDICATE TO ME THAT
THERE IS A REDUCTION IN WORKLOAD.
SO -- CAN YOU.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
ABOUT YES WE KNOW THE REVENUES
BEEN DROPPING [inaudible]
BUT CAN CAN YOU JUST EXPLAIN WHY
THE WE STILL HAVE THE SAME COSTS.
ABSOLUTELY MANAGER THANK YOU I'M
VERY MILLER I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
THE GIRLFRIEND SIX SERVICES AND
I I UNDERSTAND THAT -- IT WOULD
SEEM LIKE.
AS THERE WAS THIS DROP IN
REVENUE THERE WAS A DROP AND
WORK WELL NO NOT AT ALL DROPS IN
REVIEWER SO SHE WAS DROPPING
WORKLOAD BUT SOME ARE -- THE THE
FACT IS WE HAVE AREAS THAT HAVE
IN FACT SEEN SOME WORK LOAD
REDUCTION BUT WE'VE ALSO SEEN
AREAS THAT HAVE HAD WORKLOAD
INCREASES AND A PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF THAT IS -- THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
CASES HAVE INCREASED
DRAMATICALLY.
AND SO WHILE WE SEE SOME OF
THESE MINOR DRUG OFFENSES
REDUCED WE DON'T NECESSARILY SEE
CHANGES IN THE DNA WORKLOAD --
IT ACTUALLY INCREASES -- MORE
THAN THE REDUCTION.
WHEN YOU SAY THE SEXUAL EVIDENCE
SAW KID WORKLOAD HAS INCREASED?
DO YOU MEAN THAT MORE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE SENDING YOUR
LAB -- EVIDENCE TO BE TESTED --
THEY SEND IN MORE EVIDENCE EVERY
YEAR WE SEE AN INCREASE IN THE
DNA REQUEST OF A HAVE NOT JUST
RELATED TO SEXUAL RIGHT BUT
YOU'RE ALLOWED.
TO YOU RECOVER COSTS RELATED TO
THAT YOU DON'T PROVIDE THAT
SERVICE FREE TO THOSE AGENCIES
NO MA'AM.
WE ABSENT WE PROVIDED FOR FREE.
WE DON'T WE DON'T CHARGE
AGENCIES FOR THAT AT ALL.
IN I BELIEVE WE DISCUSSED THIS
LAST YEAR AS WELL -- THERE WAS A
MISUNDERSTANDING BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THERE ARE SOME
JURISDICTIONS SUCH AS CONTRA
COSTA AND ALAMEDA THAT HAVE
THEIR OWN LADDERS THAT HAVE
THEIR OWN LABORATORIES.
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WE
DON'T CHARGE FOR THAT SERVICE AT
ALL [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY QUESTIONS BY MY COLLEAGUES
ON THIS.
ONE WHICH COUNTIES HAVE FALLEN
LABS THAT.
NECESSITY -- TO USING THEIR
COUNTY LABS VERSES THESE THESE
FACILITIES.
AND ARE YOU GETTING -- CERTAIN
COUNTIES TO USE YOUR FACILITY
OTHER COUNTIES NOT USING A
FACILITY.
I'M SORRY YOUR IS THERE
VARIATION.
OF USE BY COUNTY.
WELL THE MUNICIPALITIES THAT
HAVE THEIR OWN LABORATORIES USE%
THEIR OWN LABORATORY FOR MOST OF
THEIR STANDARD SERVICES THERE
ARE SOME SERVICES THAT ONLY WE
PROVIDE SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA
DNA DATA BANK.
WE WE RUN THAT -- AND WHERE THE
CENTRAL POINT FOR CODIS THE
COMBINED DNA INDEX SYSTEM AS
WELL SO THEY ALL FEED INTO THAT.
AS FAR AS YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
HOW MANY -- EVEN THOUGH THERE
ARE -- TWELVE COUNTIES --
LABORATORY SUCH AS WALMART WERE
THOSE LOS ANGELES ALAMEDA --
WHILE ANY TO HAS -- ONE SAN
DIEGO HAS TO LOS ANGELES HAS.
TO I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WANT TO
GO DOWN THE LIST BUT THEY'RE
CONCENTRATED IN THE BAY AREA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REALLY THE
BIGGEST COUNTIES YES.
SO WHICH ARE THE BIGGEST
COUNTIES WITH DONNA [inaudible]
US.
PROBABLY FRESNO IS ONE OF OUR
LARGER COUNTIES THAT DOESN'T
HAVE A LAB.
SO THEY'RE BASICALLY YOU'RE
SAYING IS THE BIGGEST COUNTIES
HAVE THEIR OWN LEVEL OF ORANGE
COUNTY SAMBAR NATO RIVERSIDE --
LA SAN DIEGO.
WHEN WE SAY BIGGEST YES MORE
POPULOUS YEAH YEAH I KNOW MALLS?
LAND MASS WE WE WILL -- WE HAD
NO POPULATION WE HAVE WE HAVE A
YOU KNOW TWELVE COUNTIES THEIR
CANCERS OF LARGE COUNTY PARK
THIS AND AND I CHIRLA SO.
THE TWELVE COUNTIES ARE MEMBERS
OF THE ARE THE ONES THAT THE
HIGHEST POPULATION.
RUSH OAK SO THEY MOST OF THOSE
HAVE.
THEIR OWN THEIR OWN FACILITIES
YES OKAY SO -- SO YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE ONES ARE POPULATED
LOWER THAT.
YES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
LOWER POPULATED COUNTIES BUT ALL
OF THEM SO.
FORTY SIX OF THE CALIBER FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES ARE OURS RIGHT
OKAY SO NOT.
SO WHAT I GET WHEN I GET FROM
YOU IS THE BIGGEST COUNTIES THEY
YES THEY ARE GETTING MONEY FROM
US.
WITH THIS BUT THE OTHER ONES.
THE DAY OF THE GET THE SERVICES
YOU DO. FOR FREE OKAY YES SO SO
HAVE YOU EVER CONSIDERED
CHARGING A MONEY.
FOR WE'VE THAT WE'VE LOOKED AT
THAT MODEL SEVERAL TIMES IN THE
PAST -- IT'S IT'S COME UP ALMOST --
OF IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS IN THE
COUNTIES THAT WE SERVE FIRST OF
ALL.
GENERALLY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
TO BE CHARGED FOR THE SERVICES
OR TO OUTSOURCE TO THEM.
AND HAVE THE MONEY.
THEY WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO AFFORD
OUR SERVICES THAT -- WELL ANY
FEAR THEY DON'T THEY'RE NOT
CHARGE ANY FEE.
NOT YOU KNOW.
THIS SITE IS LIKE IS LIKE OF THE
STATE DOESN'T CHARGE.
ANYTHING.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF CHARGING
MAYBE EVEN SOME OF THE FEET SOME
OF THEM OUT OF THE COST.
YOU KNOW OU'RE SAYING YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT EITHER CHARGE ON THERE
FOR EVERYTHING VERSES CHARGING
NOTHING IT'S WE CAN CHARGE ROOM
20% 3050%.
HAVE YOU EVER LOOKED AT THAT
KIND OF THING.
YES -- WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU
DID THAT?
WHAT HAPPENED WAS WE BROUGHT IT
OVER WITH THE CHARGE THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO DO PER COUNTY YEAH
IT DIDN'T GO WELL WITH THE LOCAL
YEAH THEY DON'T LIKE IT'S HIS --
GET EVERYTHING FOR FREE IS LIKE
A FIVE DID THAT TO MY GRANDSON
HE WOULD.
COMPLAIN TOO SO BUT YOU KNOW HOW
MAY.
IT ALSO SO -- WHAT DO YOU THINK
THE CONSEQUENCES WOULD BE IF WE
ACTUALLY?
CHARGE SOME OF THE SOME OF THE
COST.
WELL.
I CAN JUST GIVE YOU ONE A REAL
CONSEQUENCE AND THAT IS THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT WOULD
DECIDE WHAT THEY WANTED TO
SUBMIT TO A CRIME LABORATORY FOR
ANALYSIS AND VICTIMS WOULD BE
THE ONES THAT WOULD SUFFER.
YEAH YOU THINK SO I BELIEVE SO
SO IF WE DID CHARGE NOTHING WE
CHARGE NOTHING.
VERSES 20% SAY WITH A COUNTIES.
YOU THINK THEY WOULD ACTUALLY.
NOT HEY YOU BECAUSE AND IF THEY
WOULD NOT PAY YOU BECAUSE THEY
DECIDED THAT IT WAS BETTER NOT
TO PAY YOU THAN.
TO HELP AFFECT.
I THINK THAT THEY WOULD NOT
BRING ME THE EVIDENCE BECAUSE
THEY WOULD BE TRYING TO DECIDE
WHICH PIECE OF EVIDENCE WAS MORE
IMPORTANT BASED ON THEIR BUDGET.
YOU THINK SO I DO.
OKAY SO SO THE OTHER TO THE
BIGGER COUNTIES THEY DO IT ON
THEIR OWN.
WHY ONE DAY -- JUST CLOSER
FACILITIES DOWN WOULD YOU DO IT
FOR FREE.
AND THEY THOUGHT ABOUT THAT IS
YOU KNOW.
CLOSING DOWN THE LARGER YEAH HY
WOULD THEY HAVE A FACILITY IF
THEY CAN GET YOU TO FOR FREE.
I CONVENIENCE HELP WITH
SOMETHING THAT -- YOU WOULD
PROBABLY HAVE TO ASK THEM BUT
THEY STARTED THE LAMBERT I'M
TRYING TO I'M TRYING TO OF OF
FIND OUT IF YOU'RE WRONG.
ECONOMIC MODEL IS CORRECT LIKE
YOU SAYING THERE WOULD BE --
WITH THE CALL ADVERSE
CONSEQUENCES.
WELL AS THE MUNICIPALITIES AS AS
MA'AM SKINNER AND I JUST TALKED
ABOUT.
THEY SOMETIMES DO CHARGE FOR
SERVICES SUCH AS CONTRA COSTA
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY DOES CHARGE
IT'S LOCALS FOR ITS SERVICES BUT
MOST OF THOSE COUNTIES ARE RUN
THROUGH EITHER SHERIFF'S OFFICER
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY FROM THEIR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT JUST LIKE WE'RE
A LOT OF MONEY FROM.
THE STATE GOVERNMENT AND THEY
DON'T CHARGE THEIR LOCAL
AGENCIES TO DO THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING.
RIGHT.
SO -- IT'S A MATTER OF THEIR
ECONOMIC MODEL IS THE SAME AS
OURS WHEN IT COMES TO THE FACT
THEY'RE PROVIDING THE SERVICES
FOR THEIR COUNTY BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO GET THAT WORK DONE.
WHEN WHEN -- THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE REGIONAL IZED AND WENT
TO ITS.
BOTTLE OF HAVING THE
LABORATORIES IN LOCATIONS IT DID
IT DID THAT BASED ON THE FACT
THAT THEY DID NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO HAVE FORENSIC
SERVICES.
SO THOSE LOCALITIES DO THE SAME
ECONOMIC MODEL YEARS AT THREE
YEARS THREE YEARS OF WE CHARGE
OF ANYTHING THAT WOULD
[inaudible]
IN HEAVEN.
THEIR DESIRE TO USE THE SERVICES.
YES OKAY SO WHERE IS THE PROOF
OF THAT.
WHERE'S YOUR PROOF DO YOU HAVE
ANY FOR FOR THE WELL IT SENATOR
AS FAR AS PROOF I I GUESS I
WOULD HAVE TO ORDER SO I GOTTA
ASK QUESTIONS WILL HAS HAD HAVE
YOU KNOW.
I DON'T MAKE A USE CASE BUT I'D
I'D REALLY HATE TO BRING YOU A
PIECE OF PROOF THAT SAID THEY
DIDN'T TURN THIS PIECE OF
EVIDENCE AND IN THIS PERSON GOT
MURDERED SO HERE'S YOUR PROOF
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RUN THAT BECAUSE
THEY WERE TRYING TO SELL.
IT UP TO THAT GROUP THAT THE
MEASURES -- THAT'S KIND OF A
STUPID THING TO SAY BECAUSE IT
YET THE PROOF THE PROOF WOULD BE
THE PREFERRED BE THAT THEY DID
NOT DO IT BECAUSE OF A FEE IS
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
NOT BECAUSE OF THEIR OWN
INCOMPETENCE OF NOT GIVING
EVIDENCE WILL.
ABSOLUTELY IF I IF I GO OUT TO
HUMBLE COUNTY AND I DECIDED O
TRY AND CHARGE THEM FOR EVERY
PIECE OF EVIDENCE THAT I WORK
FOR THEM THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DECIDE WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
BUDGET.
AND I THINK THAT'S A MATTER OF
LOGIC NOT NECESSARILY MATTER
THEORY.
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT WELL I'VE I'VE HEARD
HEARD ENOUGH FROM YOU.
NOT HERE A LITTLE BIT FOR ME
YEAH I LOVED SO IT'S AN ORAL
ANTI -- HAS TWO LABS.
IT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION WHEN I WAS A
SUPERVISOR YEAH RIGHT AS THE
SHERIFF HAD A LAB IN THE DA HAD
A LAB [inaudible]
AND THERE WERE JUST A A LOT OF
UNIQUE HAVE POLITICAL
CONSEQUENCES OF WHO SENT WHAT TO
CODICE AND ALL THE REST AND IT
WAS.
AN UGLY LITTLE.
A FAIR THAT I STEPPED INTO --
WHEN I BECAME A SUPERVISOR OUR
LAB WAS -- IN BIRMINGHAM ENGLAND
FOR THE D. A. -- REAL
INTERESTING.
SITUATIONS ONE STORY BUT BUT WE
HAD A SET UP KIND OF A SUB
COMMITTEE.
WITH THE CEO OF THE COUNTY THAT
TRYING GET THE SHARE FOR THE D.
A..
YOU KNOW JUST TO COORDINATE HIS
WHY.
THEY EACH HAD THEIR TURFS RIGHT.
IT GOT TO BE REALLY ACCURATE --
BUT NOW THAT I'M NOT A
SUPERVISOR JAMAICA DONE IT FOR
FREE I CAN A FIRED EVERYBODY ALL
RIGHT YOU.
SO YOU HAVE THIS CHANNEL ABS.
IT READS ARE SOLELY DOWN AND SO.
YOU HAVE TEN REGIONAL
LABORATORIES WHERE ARE THEY
LOCATED IN.
MY TEN REGIONAL EPITAPH.
RICA REDDING CHICO SANTA ROSA
SACRAMENTO -- FRESNO RIVERSIDE.
RIBBON.
SANTA BARBARA.
AND SANTA CRUZ DOES THE
REGIONALS AND THOSE WHO MANY AND
JUST ONE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
WELL RIVERSIDE SANTA BARBARA --
IN SANTA BARBARA AND RIVERSIDE
WERE OKAY WE'RE GOING TO CALL
THAT OKAY.
WHAT CLOSER IN BIRMINGHAM BUT --
IT WAS VERY VERY A VERY STRANGE
SITUATION.
SO OBVIOUSLY LARGE COUNTIES HAVE
D. A.'S AT HAVE COMMENCED THEIR
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE THEIR OWN
[inaudible]
LABS -- AND THEN THERE'S ALSO
THE THAT IN THE ISSUE WAS WHY
SHOULD THE D. A. WHOSE
[inaudible]
PUSHING [inaudible]
PUSHING THESE.
CASES WHY SHOULD BABY ALSO.
DURING THE DNA LIKE THERE'S A
CONFLICT OF INTERESTS ARE YOU.
HOW DO YOU RESOLVE CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST?
IS IT.
WHAT IT WHAT CAN HAPPEN IS YOU
CAN LIE?
IS THERE WITH THE DNA SAYS THAT
YOU'RE THE PERSON AND WHEN WHEN
THAT IS NOT IN IN FACT THE CASE.
HOW DO YOU PREVENT THAT KIND OF
AGGRESSIVENESS BECAUSE I I HAD A
DA THAT WANTED TO GET A 90%?
CONVICTION RATE SO SOMETIMES YOU
CAN JUST [inaudible]
MOW DOWN.
AND GET YOU KNOW FALSE
COMPASSION OR WHATEVER HOW DO
YOU PREVENT THAT FROM HAPPENING --
AT SENATOR IF I UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION WE ARE NOT -- POLICE
OFFICERS WERE NOT INVESTIGATORS
WE RUN EVIDENCE AND PRODUCE
SCIENTIFIC RESULTS WHAT THE
INVESTIGATORS AND THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S DO WITH THAT.
THAT'S THEIR PREROGATIVE HOW
THEY USE THAT REPORT THAT WE
HAVE GIVEN THEM SO.
JUST TO CLARIFY.
THE THE BUREAU OF FORENSIC
SERVICES IS THAT AN INDEPENDENT
AGENCY ARE YOU UNDERNEATH YOUR
TRAIN GENERAL'S OFFICE WE'RE IN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
OKAY SO THAT'S WHERE I'M.
MAKING THE INFERENCE SO YOU'RE
SAYING WERE IMBEDDED BUT WERE
INDEPENDENT.
AND WE'RE JUST PROVIDING.
SCIENTIFIC DATA.
NOT.
MADE TO ORDER.
BUT I'M BIASED THAT'S CORRECT.
AT THAT'S ALL I WANTED THAT WAS
THE QUESTION APOLOGIZE FOR
UNDERSTANDING THANK YOU.
I APOLOGIZE FOR NOT
COMMUNICATING BUT WE WE JUST HAD
SOME INCIDENTS THAT I WANT TO GO
THROUGH ALL KINDS OF WAR STORIES
BUT JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
THANK YOU MANAGER [inaudible]
CERTAINLY NOW.
THE I THINK.
WE WERE TOUCHING ON SOME ITEMS
THAT IF WE LOOK AT JUST ONE
EXAMPLE.
THE WHOLE ISSUE AROUND.
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT EVIDENCE THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION AND LOTS OF
DIFFERENT BILLS TO TRY.
TO BOTH GET OUT BACKLOGS IN TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL SEXUAL
ASSAULT EVIDENCE THE DNA IS
EXTRACTED AND PUT IN A DATABASE.
SO ONE OF THE ISSUES IS WE HAVE
COUNTIES THAT.
SEND THEIR MATERIALS TO THE
STATE LAB IN EFFECT AT NO COST
TO THE COUNTY.
ON NOW SOME OF THE SOME OF THOSE
COUNTIES WORDS SENDING IT ALL.
BUT AT LEAST ONCE THE ISSUE WAS
MORE REYES YOU SAW A LITTLE MORE
BEING SENT FROM THOSE COUNTIES
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO COUNTIES
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN LABS WHERE.
IN VERY OFTEN THAT LAB CHARGES
THE LOCAL JURISDICTION IN THE
COUNTY.
SO THEN THAT.
INTO TIAS MAY BE BECAUSE OF THE
COST ISSUE LESS WILLING OR MORE
SELECTIVE ABOUT WHAT THEY SEND
WHICH WAS FOR YOURCONCERN.
THAT THEN IF.
THEN WE DON'T HAVE.
FULL DATA BUT IT WOULD APPEAR
THAT SOME PLACES LIKE THAT WHERE
IT WAS A COST TO THEM.
WOULD LEAVE THE EVIDENCE ON THE
SHOPS.
SO YOU KNOW WE OBVIOUSLY DON'T
WANT THAT BUT NOW WE HAVE THIS
KIND OF ODD SITUATION WHERE.
WE KNOW THAT IT COSTS US MONEY.
TO EXTRACT THE DNA AND GET IT
INTO THAT.
DATABASE.
THERE'S A COST.
BUT THEN WE'RE HAVE A ON LEVEL
PLAYING FIELD IN TERMS OF WHO
PAYS FOR IT.
YES THE TAXPAYER ULTIMATELY PAYS
FOR IT BUT IN SOME CASES IT'S
THE STATE WIDE TAX PAYER PAYING
FOR A WHOLE SET A COUNTIES AND
IN OTHER CASES IT'S JUST THE
LOCAL TAXPAYER.
PAYING FOR IT JUST WITHIN THEIR
COUNTY.
AND THAT MAY BE.
A BASIS FOR SOME OF OUR PROBLEM
OF NOT.
GETTING THIS EVIDENCE IN.
SO BUT WE'RE WE'RE NOW POSED
WASTE WITH JUST DEALING WITH HOW
TO FILL THE STATE LAB BACK FILL
IN NOT THE ENTIRE.
STATEWIDE ISSUE ON BUT THIS DNA
FEE THAT WE HAVE THERE IS SOME
PORTION OF IT THAT IS GIVEN TO
COUNTIES CORRECT.
SO THE COUNTIES ARE SO WHILE
THEY MAY NOT.
GET ALL OF THE JUST THE SAME WAY
YOU HAVE A BACKLOG SOME MONEY
DOES GO TO THE COUNTIES.
YES MA'AM IT'S THOSE WITH THEIR
OWN LABS TO DO GET SOME MONEY
FROM THE STATE.
PROBABLY VERY INADEQUATE TO
COVER THEIR FULL.
LAB COSTS BUT THEY GENERALLY --
USE IT THE LOCAL SHERIFF'S WILL
GENERALLY USE IT FOR COLLECTION
COSTS FOR THE REST THE PROGRAM.
BUT EVERY COUNTY DOES HAVE SOME
DNA IDENTIFICATION -- FUND MONEY
FROM PROP SIXTY NINE IN A LOCAL
TREASURY ACCOUNT THAT'S PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE ON THE WEBSITE FOR
PROP.
SIXTY NINE SO IT WILL INFO
ANYWAY WHAT WE'RE IDENTIFYING IS
THAT PROP.
SIXTY NINE CREATED THE FINE FOR
THIS.
AND IT'S INADEQUATE TO COVER.
OUR STATE COSTS THAT COVER THOSE
COUNTIES THAT DON'T HAVE THEIR
OWN LAB IT'S ALSO IN ADEQUATE IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE GIVE TO THE
OTHER COUNTIES. TO COVER THEIR
COSTS [inaudible]
THAT.
IT IT IS BUT PROPOSITION SIXTY
NINE WAS PRIMARILY -- TO TO
BUILD AND ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT THE DATA BANK
THERE WAS A FURTHER GOVERNMENT
CODE HAT WAS ADDED TO ADD OTHER
CHARGES WHICH IS WHAT WAS
AFFECTED BY PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN WHICH IS THE REASON WE
HAVE A DEBT THE DEFICIT RIGHT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT. TO DEAL WITH A
BACKLOG.
NO SENATOR THAT'S THAT'S BECAUSE
OF DECLINING REVENUES TO MAKE UP
FOR MONEY THAT WE'VE LOST BASED
ON THOSE LOSSES THANK YOU --
OKAY SO.
ANY COMMENTS FOR MORE.
BERMAN FINE ISRAELI -- GO AHEAD
LA OF IT'S NOT A CONCERN WITH
THIS ISSUE IT'S JUST IN AS PART
OF YOUR DISCUSSION.
THERE'S THE PROP SIXTY NINE
MONEY THERE'S ACTUALLY AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR DOLLAR FEE THAT
THE THAT THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED
THAT'S PART OF THE OVERALL
DISCUSSION THAT YOU WOULD HAVE
ON CRIMINAL FINES AND FEES IT'S
PART OF THAT BROADER ASSESSMENT
SO THERE'S ALSO ADDITIONAL MONEY
GOING IN THERE BUT IT'S SUBJECT.
TO THE SAME ISSUE SO I JUST
WANTED TO OFFER THAT FOR YOUR
DISCUSSIONS.
WE'RE GONNA HOLD THIS OPEN.
PRECIADO A WITH THINK WE'LL HAVE
A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF IT WE
DON'T A SOLUTION BUT WHATEVER WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE OBLIGATIONS
AND WE DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE --
IDENTIFIED EXISTING REVENUE TO
COVER THE COSTS THAT WE HAVE TO
DECIDE HOW MUCH FOR GENERAL FUND
WERE WILLING.
TO EARN.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE SIDE
OF ALL RIGHT THANKS SO MUCH WE
WILL GO TO ISSUE.
NINETEEN THE OUR CONSUMER
PRIVACY -- ACT ITEM.
AGAIN THIS IS A A TWO TWO BILLS
THAT WERE ENACTED THAT THIS LAST
YEAR.
A AND I REQUEST IS FOR PERMANENT
AUGMENTATION IN POSITION AND
SPENDING AUTHORITY. TO IMPLEMENT
THE MANDATE TO THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
THE REQUESTED RESOURCE IS WOULD
ALLOW DOJ TO ENFORCE THE GROUND
BREAKING PRIVACY MEASURE WHICH
GRANTS CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
SPECIFIED RIGHTS.
RELATED TO THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION IS COLLECTED SHARED
OR MAINTAINED BY A BUSINESS.
AND THE RIGHT TO EQUAL SERVICE
AND PRICE.
THE REQUESTED FOR TWENTY THREE
POSITIONS. FOUR POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND FOUR POINT
FIVE MILLION ON GOING IT'S
CURRENTLY THE PROPOSAL SPLIT
BETWEEN GENERAL FUND AND THE
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW FUND --
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION AS
GENERAL FUND TWO POINT NINE IS
THE SPECIAL FUND KNOWN AS THE
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW.
FUND AND I HAVE STACY IN MICHAEL
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE ACTIVITIES THE DOJ
RELATED TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS.
BILL.
ALL RIGHT I'M -- THIS IS CLEAR
AND THIS IS OBVIOUSLY --
LEGISLATION THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
ENACTED SO IT DOES -- IT WILL
REQUIRE.
SOME AUGMENTATION -- FOR
IMPLEMENTATION BUT LA -- I THINK
YOUR COMMENT WAS NOT ON WHAT WAS
THE REQUEST BUT RATHER WHAT
DEFINES SOURCE WAS.
CORRECT -- OF THE NEW THE THE
LEGISLATION CREATED AND YOU FIND
A CONSUMER PRIVACY.
FIND AND SO WE ARE RECOMMENDING
US OF A DRUG DIRECTOR
PREPARATION ALONE TO THAT FINE
BECAUSE THAT FUND WAS CREATED BY
STATE LAW TO RECEIVE.
A CIVIL PENALTY REVENUES THAT
WERE ASSESSED FOR VIOLATING THE
LAW AND THE INTENSE WAS FULLY
OFFSET DOJ'S COSTS OF
IMPLEMENTATION AND ENFORCEMENT.
AND SO.
ALONE WOULD ENSURE THAT DOJ HAS
A SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO GET
STARTED BUT WOULD ALSO COMPLY
WITH LEGISLATIVE AND THE SECOND
PART OF THAT IS.
BY DOING THIS -- METHODOLOGY IT
WOULD HELP THE LEGISLATURE
CONDUCT OVERSIGHT OF
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ACT SO FOR
EXAMPLE TO THE EXTENT THAT NOT
ENOUGH CIVIL PENALTY REVENUE
COMES IN. TO COVER COSTS AS THE
LEGISLATURE INTENDED THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT NEED TO GO IN
AND CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE ACTION.
FOR EXAMPLE CHANGING THE AMOUNT
OF PENALTY THAT COULD BE CHARGED
FOR A VIOLATION [inaudible]
OKAY.
QUESTIONS BY.
MEETING ON THIS [inaudible]
ONE BERMAN FINANCE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAME TO BE
TREATED ON A FINANCE AM.
NOTE THAT ALTERNATE RECOMMENDED
BY THE LA -- CREATES A NUMBER OF
CHALLENGES SUCH AS WHEN THE
SETTLEMENT MONEY WILL ARRIVE HOW
MUCH WILL BE RECEIVED AND WHEN
IT WILL BE SUFFICIENT TO REPAY
THE LOANS.
AND SUPPORT THE PROGRAM.
IF NOT ENOUGH SETTLEMENT MONEY
ARRIVES.
ADDITIONAL LOAN OR GENERAL FUND
WILL THEN BE NEED TO PROVIDE.
S. S. SET UP -- THAT THE NEED.
I PROPOSAL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THIS
VERY ABILITY BY PROVIDING THE
GENERAL FUND AND UNFAIR
COMPETITION LOAN FUNNY NOW.
REDUCTION OF THESE FUNDS AND
RESOURCES CAN BE REEVALUATED
WHEN THE REVENUE FROM THE
SETTLEMENT.
IT COMES DOWN.
BOTH APPROACHES SEEM TO HAVE
PROBLEMS ON THE ONE HAND.
THE APPROACH OF JUST FOR RUNNING
THE CONSUMER BINDING.
AND IT'S NOT AND IF IT DOESN'T
COME THROUGH IN IF WE DON'T
RECEIVE THAT KIND OF REVENUES
AND OF COURSE YOU HAVE TO
COMPENSATE THE CONSUMER FUND
WITH THE GENERAL FUND BUT
FRONTING THE GENERAL FUND AND
NOT BEEN.
SEEKING TO REPAY THE GENERAL
FUND WITH THAT.
SO MAYBE THERE'S A HYBRID
[inaudible]
ON IN STAFF.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
ANY OTHER COMMENT.
I MEANI THINK WHAT PARTLY WHAT
I HAVE BEEN.
IT'S NOT BEEN NECESSARILY
EXPLICIT BUT IN A LOT OF OUR
CONVERSATIONS WE KNOWTHAT
THERE'S A REVENUE SOURCE.
ON THAT WE HAVEN'T YET EITHER
MAXIMIZED ARE UTILIZED AND THEN
WE USE GENERAL FUND BUT WE DON'T
SEEM TO WE RARELY SEEM TO EVER
REPAY THE GENERAL FUND.
I'M TRYING TO ACHIEVE SOME
ABILITY.
TO AB MAXIMIZER USE OF SPECIAL
FUNDS FOR THEIR PURPOSES --
THERE ARE MORE LACK.
I'M JUST CURIOUS I'M WHEN YOU
GET A MANDATE LIKE THIS DO YOU
ET UP BY THE INDIVIDUAL.
DEPARTMENT DEAL WITH THIS AND
YOU DEVELOP A BUSINESS PLAN.
WHAT IS TWENTY THREE PEOPLE WILL
BE DOING A FOR THEY'RE GOING TO
BE DIFFERENT?
PLAYERS I'M JUST CURIOUS.
YES THAT ARE MORE LIKE WE
ACTUALLY HAVE THE THE PROGRAM
STAFF HERE WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL AND AND
MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATE BECAUSE THE STATE START.
I THINK WAS LAST YEAR YOU
STARTED WITH THE REGULATIONS AND
THAT'S WHAT KICKED IT OFF SO WE
CAN DO A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M STACY SHAS
ARE I AM THE SUPERVISING DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THE PRIVACY
UNIT WHICH IS PART OF CONSUMER.
I'M THERE ARE SEVERAL
OBLIGATIONS THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL NEEDS TO ME UNDER THE
CCPA ONE OF IT IS ENFORCEMENT
ONE OF IT IS I PROMULGATING
REGULATIONS -- AND IN ADDITION
RIGHT NOW IS THE LOG SAYS WE
ALSO HAVE A REQUIREMENT.
FOR PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO
BUSINESSES THAT SEEK OUR ADVICE.
THE ENFORCEMENT STRUCTURE WE'RE
REQUESTING POSITIONS -- BECAUSE
ENFORCING THIS LAW IS.
IS GOING TO BE A MONUMENTAL TASK
IT'S A GROUNDBREAKING LOTS THE
FIRST IN THE COUNTRY -- IT
REQUIRES A CERTAIN LEVEL OF
ATTENTION TO TECHNICAL
TECHNOLOGY AND TECHNICAL
COMPONENTS BUT ALSO LOOKING AT
HOW THE LAW HOW THE LAW IS BEING
COMPLIED WITH BY BOTH ONLINE AND
OFFLINE BUSINESSES.
AND SO THERE'S GOING TO BE --
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
ENFORCEMENT -- RAMP UP THAT WE
NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT BUSINESSES ARE COMPLYING
WITH THE LAW.
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE IT IS
EXCLUSIVELY ON FORCED AS BEST
STATUTES THAT'S WORTH BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE SO.
IT'S US WE ARE THE THE FULL COPS
ON THE BEAT FOR MAKING SURE THAT
BUSINESSES ARE COMPLYING.
IN ADDITION TO THAT AND AS CHRIS
JUST MENTIONED WE HAVE BEEN --
DOING AN EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF
WORK IN TERMS OF WRITING
REGULATIONS.
WHICH THE STATUTE PROVIDES
AUTHORITY FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO DO.
WE ARE DRAFTING THESE
REGULATIONS SO THAT THE
BUSINESSES AND CONSUMERS ALIKE
WILL KNOW HOW TO MAKE.
THE LAW WORK FOR THEM THEY CAN
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS AS WELL AS
BUSINESSES CAN.
I UNDERSTAND HOW TO
OPERATIONALIZE THE CCPA BUT IN
ADDITION TO THESE THIS INITIAL
SET OF REGULATIONS THAT WE ARE
SEEKING TO DRAFT.
AND DOING SO WITH GREAT YOU KNOW
IN A GREAT RUSH SO THAT
BUSINESSES WILL KNOW WHAT TO DO
WE HAVE ONGOING REGULATORY
AUTHORITY AND WE CAN PROMULGATE
LAWS THAT WILL ADDRESS FOR
EXAMPLE.
CHANGES IN TECHNOLOGY OR DATA
COLLECTION PRACTICES OR
OBSTACLES TO IMPLEMENTATION AND
PRIVACY CONCERNS THE STATUTES
FORTH.
A SPECIFIC.
AUTHORITY FOR US TO UPDATE THE
DEFINITION OF PERSONAL
INFORMATION OR UNIQUE
IDENTIFIERS AS THESE FAST
TECHNOLOGY CONTINUES TO EVOLVE.
TO HAVE DIFFERENT WAYS IN WHICH
WERE TRACKED THIRTY SPEAK.
AND SO GIVEN THAT THERE'S AN
EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE TO BE DONE IN TERMS
OF MEETING OUR OBLIGATIONS FOR
ENFORCING THIS LAW.
YOU'RE A YOU'RE HAVING THE JOY
OF DEVELOPING EVERYTHING.
AND IF SO HOW DO YOU SAID
METRICS FOR YOURSELF IDEA
MANAGERS OUT [inaudible]
WELL.
WE'RE WORKING REALLY HARD I
BASICALLY RIGHT NOW CURRENTLY
THEPRIVACY UNIT IS A STAFF OF
FIVE INCLUDING ME I'M A
SUPERVISOR AND WE HAVE. FOUR IN
CREDIBLY TALENTED ATTORNEYS I
HAVE THE HONOR OF WORKING WITH
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND BEFORE CCPA WE WERE ALREADY
VERY ACTIVELY INVESTIGATING
COMPANIES THAT ROOM VIOLATING
STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY LAWS.
THAT PERHAPS YOU MAY HAVE READ
ABOUT YOU KNOW IN THE NEWS.
WE HAVE PULLED SOME OF THOSE
TEAM MEMBERS OFF OF THEIR WORK
IN TERMS OF INVESTING IN
CONDUCTING THEIR INVESTIGATIONS
ARE ONGOING AND NO CRITICAL TO
ENFORCING STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN MEET
THESE IMPOSED DEADLINES -- BUT
THAT HAS YOU KNOW REQUIRED ME TO
DO A LOT OF REDEFINING -- AND
MANAGING PEOPLE'S TIME SO THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO COMPLY WITH WITH
THE THE TASK AT THE TASKS THAT
THE STATUTE IS IMPOSING.
AND SO.
I'M YOU KNOW IN ADDITION TO THAT
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF HIGH
HIRING.
TWO ATTORNEYS GENERAL ON BASED
ON THE THE WORKLOAD THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO US LAST.
LAST SESSION I BELIEVE AS WELL
AS AN ADDITIOAL PROGRAM PERSON
FROM THE SAME WORKLOAD.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT WILL GIVE US
SOME REPRIEVE SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MOVE THINGS ACROSS
THIS INITIAL -- DEADLINE I'M BUT
TO BE QUITE HONEST I MEAN WE ARE
WE'RE WORKING INCREDIBLY HARD
AND THEN ONCE THE CCPA GOES INTO
A FACT.
THAT WILL JUST CREATE EVEN
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD FOR US. FOR
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE ACTIVELY
ENFORCING AT THE MISTRESS FURRY
ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT TWENTY
THREE POSITIONS WILL DO THE JOB.
I CERTAINLY HOPE SO I MEAN I
THINK I THINK THAT THAT'S A A
MIGHTY ARMY -- FOR THIS TYPE OF
BASED ON OUR ANALYSIS AND WORKED
WITH TWENTY THREE POSITIONS YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE.
TO FILL ALL OF THEM YOU'RE
SAYING -- I THINK WE COULD
EASILY FILL THEM.
WE WENT.
I WILL DEFER.
TO YEAH SO -- WE USE ARE THE
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM YOU
ALLUDED TO EARLIER -- TO THE TO
MONITOR OR TO TO GENERATE HOURS
RELATIVE CERTAIN YOU KNOW PASSED
SO THAT WE CAN PROJECT NUMBER OF
HOURS NEEDED TO GET THINGS DONE
AND SO.
WE DO HAVE HOURS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE INVESTIGATIONS AND
DEVELOPING THE REGULATIONS AND
BASED ON THAT.
AND WHAT THAT WHAT'S.
REQUIRED IN THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD WE'VE BEEN ESTIMATED THE
NUMBER STAFF NEEDED.
I THINK YOUR POINT IS A KNOT I
I'M NOT SURE THAT WE EVER NOW
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE IMPORTS
COMING IN.
AT THIS POINT IN THE CALLS
COMING IN IN THE INVESTIGATIONS
AND AND THERE'S MORE COMING IN
THEN THEN NOT AT THIS POINT.
STRANDED I COME.
FROM EXECUTIVE POSITIONS SO
BEING A LEGISLATORS SORT OF
DIFFERENT -- I WANT TO COMMEND
YOU FOR WORKING HARD TO DEVELOP
AND JUST TO THIS LEGISLATION --
AYE.
I AS AN EXECUTIVE HAVE HAD
DIFFICULTY WITH WATCHING CERTAIN
THINGS HAPPEN.
YOU'RE AT THE STATE.
TODAY WE HAD A BILL ON THE FLOOR
ADD TO EXTEND THE CANNABIS
LICENSE YOU KNOW IF I WHY DID
THEY GET.
DONE YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT'S GOING
ON WHY DO I HAVE A DMV THAT.
TAKES YOU KNOW ALWAYS LONG LINES
WHY DO I HAVE.
THIS GAL THAT'S RUNNING A
BILLION DOLLARS RIGHT AWAY.
YOU KNOW THE LIST JUST GOES ON
AND ON OF OF THINGS THAT ARE
JUST REALLY FRUSTRATING. TO ME
IS AN EXECUTIVE TYPE PERSON --
AND SO NOW AS A LEGISLATOR I GET
LIKE WHAT TEN MINUTES OF YOUR
TIME.
THE FIGURE OUT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN AND I WOULD RATHER YOU COME
UP TO THE FRONT AND SAY.
I NEED TWENTY EIGHT POSITION.
THE COVER THIS AND TO HAVE A
SATISFACTORY RESULT BECAUSE THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH.
THIS IS WHAT'S GOING TO DO IT.
AS OPPOSED TO SAYING I GET
TWENTY THREE WHEN YOU COME BACK
TO ME AND SAY WE GOT IT BACK
BILL WE HAVE A BACKLOG OR WE
HAVE A THIS OR THAT.
BY AND ADAM HOW TO HOW TO DO
THAT TEN MINUTES [inaudible]
RIGHT -- I GUESS I NEED. TO TO
ENCOURAGE YOU THAT YOU'RE
EMPOWERED.
YOU KNOW THE THE BILL DOES THE
UNIT BUT ALSO.
BUILD IT SO THAT.
IT DOES WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO DO
THAT MAKES SENSE SO THAT SO THAT
I'M HAVE.
TO WHINE ABOUT.
NO THE FACT THAT YOU'RE COMING
BACK NEXT THURSDAY AND WELL WE
REALLY MISSED THIS ONE ARE ARE
FOR I'D RATHER YOU CAN MAGAZINE
WILL YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
PROSECUTION'S OF AT ALL.
BUT WE'VE GOTTEN LEGAL WITH
CIVIL PENALTIES BUT ALL WE DID
WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
UNDERSTOOD CENTER WERE LOCKED IN
AND WE DO GO THROUGH A PROCESS --
WORKING WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
AND AND LA OVER.
AND LOOKING AT THE WORKLOAD IN
LOOKING AT OUR ESTIMATES AND
WE'RE WE'RE GIVING THE BEST
ESTIMATE AT THIS POINT IN TIME
GIVEN THE WORKLOAD TODAY.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE WON'T HAVE
TO COME BACK I'M AND I WOULD
LIKE OR THE BACKLOG YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS IS.
IMPLEMENTATION OF A NEW PROGRAM
AND WE'RE DOING.
A REASONABLE ESTIMATE THAT WE
ASK FOR MORE SURE -- WE COULD
YOU KNOW BUT WE'RE WE'RE ASKING
FOR WHAT WE THINK IS REASONABLE
REASONABLE AND ACHIEVABLE IN THE
TIME PERIOD THAT WE HAVE TO DO
THE JOB SO.
I'M LIKELY WILL HAVE TO COME
BACK IN AND ADJUST IN THERE
LIKELY WILL BE OTHER.
LEGISLATION THAT GOES THROUGH TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
I'M WHAT WILL BRING IT BACK IN
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS --
BUT I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS IS DO SOMETHING.
ASK FOR RESOURCES THAT WE KNOW
WE CAN DEPLOY AND AND HAVE UP
AND RUNNING AND GET THE PROGRAM
GOING.
AND NOT HAVE RESOURCES SITTING
IDLE -- BUT I ASSURE YOU WE WILL
BE BACK HAVING A CONVERSATION AT
SOME POINT.
BOB THANKS FOR CUTTING TEETH ON
WHAT IS A VERY COMPLEX AND
UNIQUE SITUATIONS.
BUDGET THANK.
THANK YOU CENTER MOORLACH END UP
BUT I WHAT I WOULD RAISE IS THAT
IT IS [inaudible]
I'M.
DIFFICULT OF COURSE IN THIS
MOMENT TO KNOW WHETHER THIS IS A
WE KNOW IT'S AN INCREASED
WORKLOAD.
IS THIS AN OVERSTATEMENT OF NEED
OR AN UNDERSTATEMENT IT IS HARD
TO DETERMINE.
BUT I NOTE THAT.
THE TASKS RELATED TO THE
FILAMENT ARE DEVELOPING REX.
AND THEN PROVIDING GUIDANCE
THOSE TWO TASKS WELL THE
GUIDANCE MAYBE ON GOING IN TERMS
OF WHAT'S POSTED ON A WEBSITE.
THOSE FIRST TWO TASKS ARE.
NOT.
SO ONE GOING THERE ONCE THE REX
ARE DEVELOPED ONCE THE AND THEN
THE GUIDANCE WILL BE LESS.
I SO IT'S POSSIBLE THAT.
THIS NUMBER OF POSITIONS ARE
NEEDED NOW.
BUT ONCE THE REX ARE DEVELOPED
IN VARIOUS THINGS THAT IT MIGHT
BE LESS BUT THAT.
I GUESS WHAT I AM.
ASKING IN WHAT I DIDN'T SEE AN
PREVIOUS REQUESTS NOT RELATED TO
THIS ONE IS THAT [inaudible]
ANYTIME.
A CERTAIN PORTION OF THE NEW LAW.
WAS IMPLEMENTED HE DIRECTS WERE
PUT INTO PLACE FOR OTHERS THERE
WAS NO CON COMMIT AND REDUCTION
THEN IN LIKE -- WE'RE GETTING
THESE REQUESTS FOR NEW JOURNAL
JOURNAL FIND.
WHY WOULDN'T BE F. T. WE CREATED?
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF RAKES ON
BILL TAX. TWO YEARS AGO THAT'S
DONE WHY WOULDN'T THOSE F. T. BE
SHIFTED.
BOB THE RAKES IN THIS ONE THEN
STATE NO LONGER HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY OF DEVELOPING
THOSE WRECKED SO.
THAT THAT'S THE GENERAL --
THAT'S THE REQUEST THAT I HAVE
TOWARDS THE AT THE OJ FOR ALL OF
ITS BCP'S THAT I DON'T SEE.
I JUST DON'T SEE COMING FORWARD.
AND JEREMIH PROVIDE
CLARIFICATION AND PROGRAM FEEL
FREE TO JUMP IN.
I THINK WE DID CONSIDER IN
ASKING FOR THE POSITIONS
RELATIVE THING RAGS -- BUT THERE
WOULD BE SOME.
DIRECTOR SOME OTHER WORK THAT
WOULD COME ABOUT BUT I ALSO WANT
TO MAKE CLEAR THAT THESE
REGULATIONS OR THE REGULATIONS
ASSOCIATE WITH THIS PROGRAM WE
SEE BEING NOT NECESSARILY A ONE
TIME.
THAT WE SEE THAT THERE'S GONNA
BE ONGOING NEED OR REGULATION
WORK AND THAT WAS FACT.
THIS -- THAT IS PART OF WHY
YOU'RE SEEING THE ONGOING NATURE
OF THIS ASK FOR THE REGULATION.
RIGHT NOW ONE MAY BE DEBATABLE
BUT YOU ALSO REFERENCE AND YOUR
LAST COMMENT THE CENTER MORE
LACKED SOMETHING ABOUT
ADDITIONAL LEGISLATION AND I
WOULD JUST -- THAT THIS.
THE C. P. IS NOT BASED ON
ANTICIPATION OF A BILL THAT IS
NOT YET APPROVED.
OKAY BIKES ARE ASKED RELATIVE TO
THE FISCAL ESTIMATE WE DID ON
THE TABLE YOU BILLS A REFERENCE
IN THIS BE.
A SEVENTY FIVE AT ELEVEN TWENTY
ONE AND IN OUR ESTIMATES ARE
BASED ON THOSE TWO BILLS.
MY COMMENT THE CENTER MORE LIKE
WAS MORTGAGE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
I JUST KNOW THAT THE AG'S OFFICE
IS SPONSORING A BILL THAT HAS
SOME RELATION.
IT'S GOING TO THE PROCESS
[inaudible]
BY.
WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DOUG SUPERS ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIANS FOR CONSUMER
PRIVACY CO SPONSORS OF AB THREE
SEVENTY FIVE THE COMPANY.
PRIVACY ACT PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THE REQUEST BEFORE YOU TODAY
AMYNTAS ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF PERFORMANCE.
PORTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT I WAS ALSO
ASKED TO VOICE.
SUPPORT FOR THE REQUEST OF THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIA
AND COMMON SENSE.
THANK.
QUESTION IF YOU HAVE YOU
REVIEWED THE BUSINESS PLAN YOU
MAY.
IF YOU WERE REVIEW THEIR
BUSINESS PLAN AT ALL ARE.
THE B. C. B. S. -- THE CCP A
THAT.
THIS DIVISION IS DOING.
YEAH I THINK WE ARE SERVICE AREA
OF YOU AND IN CONTACT AT ALL
WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
YEAH I THINK A OUR TEAM'S BEEN
IN CONTACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF ENGAGED IN THE FREE WORLD
MAKING PROCESS THAT THEY'VE GONE
THROUGH AND WE'VE.
LOOK TO THE B. C. B. AND I THINK
ALL THE ISSUES THAT YOU RAISED
ABOUT YOU KNOW.
TRYING TO FORECAST THE HOPE OF
NEED FOR IMPLEMENTATION AND
ENFORCEMENT IS.
PROBABLY DIFFICULT BACK BUT WE
THINK THAT THIS IS.
YOU KNOW A GOOD A GOOD START AND
WILL EVOLVE AS IT GOES ON
BECAUSE THERE IS.
LIKELY ONGOING REGULATORY NEED
AN INPUT IN IT.
THANKS FOR THE COLLABORATION.
THANK YOU MEDICARE [inaudible]
WELCOME.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TWENTY D. A..
B. C. P. RELATED TO THE INTERNET
CONSUMER PROTECTION IN NET
NEUTRALITY ACT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THIS THE
CALIFORNIA INTERNET PROTECTION A
NET NEUTRALITY ACT.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I AND WE'RE
REQUESTING AN AUGMENTATION OF
POSITION AND SPENDING AUTHORITY
IMPLEMENT THE MANDATE TO THE
CALIFORNIA.
INTERNET CONSUMER PROTECTION
THAT IS.
REQUEST RESOURCES WOULD ALLOW
DOJ TO INCREASE ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST INTERNET SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND PUBLIC AND THESE.
WERE IN VIOLATION OF THE ACT.
IT IS ASKING FOR NINE POSITIONS.
PULLING ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AND THE UNSOURCED IT'S
THE UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW.
AND I HAVE A PROGRAM SUPPORT
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
IF ANY BACKGROUND IF NEEDED.
THE ONLY -- ABOUT THE TIMING OF
THIS.
IS A LAWSUIT.
LISTEN TO THE LA -- AND URBAN OF
FINANCE.
ARE -- WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH
THE IDENTIFIED FUNDING IS ZERO
ONE BUT WE DO HAVE -- WE ARE
RECOMMENDING BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE SPECIFYING THAT DOJ CAN
ONLY USE THIS FUNDING.
ONCE ALL THE QUIRK PROHIBITIONS
PREVENTING IMPLEMENTATION AND
ENFORCEMENT ARE REMOVED.
AND IT'S UNCLEAR TO US WHETHER
THAT WILL BE GONE IN THE BUDGET
YEAR AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
RECOMMENDING THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE.
SO IN YOUR AGENDA THEY THERE IS --
THIS IS HE'S TWENTY SEVEN AREA
DONE IT DOES LAY OUT PIECES OF
LITIGATION THAT ARE PENDING.
THE STATE ENTERED INTO AN
AGREEMENT IN OCTOBER OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHERE THE
LATTER TWO BULLETS THE LAWSUIT
AGAINST CALIFORNIA WERE
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED UNTIL THE
FEDERAL CASE WAS DEDICATED.
AND EXCHANGE CALIFORNIA READ NOT
IMPLEMENT.
I'M THE BILL UNTIL CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET.
I WILL RECOMMEND.
THIS SOMEBODY -- TERMS OF THE
COURT CASES.
WHAT'S THE TIMING ON THE WORK
CASES BUILT TO THE BUDGET HOUSE
OR YOU.
THE BUDGETING AND HAD THIS
REQUEST -- WELL MONSTER.
HOW DID YOU?
THE TERM THE DOLLAR AMOUNT AND I
REQUEST BASED ON A THE BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY SO.
PROBABLY SHOULD BE LOOKED AT IN
TERMS OF LIKE WHETHER OR NOT
THAT'S COURT CASES ARE GONNA BE
ALSO BY JULY FIRST EARLIER WHAT
DO YOU.
AFTERNOON CENTERS MICROSOFT AND
PROVIDING THE COMMISSION ON
ACTION.
THE LAWSUIT.
THE THE ONE LAWSUIT THAT IS
MOVING FORWARD AT THIS TIME IS
THE ONE THAT OR WHERE.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AMONG
NUMBER OF STATE BOTH MOTHER
STAKEHOLDERS.
SUIT AND BARBARA TITIAN YOU.
AGAINST THE REPEAL YES THIS IS
ORDER REPEALING AND NEUTRALITY.
THAT THAT LAWSUIT HAD AN ORAL
ARGUMENT ON FEBRUARY BIRTH MOVED
FOR QUITE QUICKLY.
FISHING SPOT BACK IN AUGUST.
WE'RE WAITING AND ASIAN.
AS AS WITH THE WORLD.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW WITH THAT
WITHIN ABOUT A QUARTER OF THAT
NATURE.
WE'RE NOT GIVEN AN ESTIMATE.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT.
WELL THAT WE WOULD IT WILL BE
HERE IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY THEN THERE
WOULD BE ALRP RIGHT.
THEY WOULD NOT THEY WOULD
CONTINUE TO FEEL. ONE WAY THE
OTHER SOMEBODY WITH A ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER RIGHT.
IT'S IT'S TRUE CENTER ALTHOUGH
AS YOU KNOW THIS IS.
THIS IS A PECULIAR.
ISSUE WEBER WITH THEIR POSITION
IS.
IN THE COURT OF APPEALS ON FIRST
HEARING SO THE APPEAL HERE WOULD
BE TO THE SUPREME COURT ON SIR
SO.
THERE IS CERTAINLY A POSSIBILITY
THAT.
NOT PROCEED MIGHT NOT WANT
RUNNING.
ON WE ARE NOT ABLE TO SEND THAT --
YEAH TO BE A REASONABLE PERSON
THEIR DECISION.
I'M IF THE LEAD AGAINST HER
FILED CASES AGAINST CALIFORNIA
AND THEN DECIDE. TO REQUEST TO
STAY THEN THAT PROCESS HAS TO
KIND OF KICK OFF AND HAS TO BE
LITIGATED.
AND ADJUDICATED BEFORE THEN WE
CAN MOVE FORWARD SO THERE'S
ACTUALLY TWO PIECES GOING ON AND
SO THOSE ARE KIND OF THE TERMS
AND CONDITIONS.
IS LAID OUT ON PAGE TWENTY SEVEN
OF YOUR AGENDA WHAT'S THE BOTTOM
THE TWO CONDITIONS YOU'LL SEE IT
HIGHLIGHTED NUMBERS AND SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S A
CONSIDERATION.
THE COMMITTEE WILL WANT TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT ROOMS OF THE
THERE'S WAYS WE CAN SPEND MONEY
WE CAN SEE THAT IN THE BUDGET
AND THEN THERE CAN BE LIKE A
DECISION LATER TO SPEND MONEY
BASED ON WHAT HAPPENS AT WORK IS.
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
YOU CAN DO A ONE WAY THE OTHER
YOU CAN WAIT UNTIL.
SOMETHING IS DECIDED IN A
COMMAND JUST GET A MONEY SPENT
ON IMPLEMENTING SAYING OR YOU
CAN.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT HAPPENED.
I AM A TIMING WISE -- I AGREE IT
IS KIND THERE IS UNCERTAINTY OUT
THERE I THINK.
ONTHE RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
LA -- TO PROVIDE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE LIMITING -- NOT
ALLOWING THEM TO USE MONEY UNTIL
WE KNOW THE PENDING CASES OF THE
CORE I THINK I'M WE WOULD BE
VERY COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
RECOMMENDATION -- AND THEN THAT
WAY IF IF YOU KNOW THEY ARE NOT
ABLE TO USE THIS MONEY THAT GOT
REVERTS BACK TO THE GENERAL FUND
AND THEN WE CAN USE IN THE
FUTURE YEARS BUT I DO THINK WE
SHOULD BE READY.
IN CASE YOU KNOW THEY CAN START
USING THIS FUNDING WE DON'T
WANNA HAVE TO RESPECT AND EVERY
PROCESS -- TO PROVIDE THEM THE
RESOURCE WHAT'S MORE LIKE A
PROVISIONAL ALLOCATION.
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE.
IS NOT ONLY OVER WELL WITH THE
MOUNT BE BASED ON JULY FIRST OR
WHAT.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE IT'S NOT GONNA
BE JULY FIRST FOR SURE
[inaudible]
IS DETERMINED.
BASED ON OUR EVALUATION US AS AT
THIS IS HONOR VALUATION OF THE
PCP WE THINK THAT.
THE REQUEST IS REASONABLE IN
TERMS OF THE CALCULATION AGAIN
IT'S AN ESTIMATE.
SIMILAR TO THAT -- AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE INDICATED
IT WOULD MAKE THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE IF THEY DON'T SPEND IT
ALL IT DOES REVERT BACK TO THE
GENERAL FUND YEAH AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE IN AND IF IT DOESN'T.
GO INTO A FACT THEY CAN'T USE AS
OF JULY ONE THEY START FOR
EXAMPLE IN DECEMBER AND HE WAS
JUST BE HAVING ACROSS FROM
DECEMBER THROUGH THE END OF THE
YEAR AND THEN WHATEVER.
I'M SORRY FATE MAY REALLY FAST I
DO WANT TO JUST CLARIFY THAT I
MISSPOKE IT IS NOT THE GENERAL
FUND IS UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW
AND SO IT GOES BACK TO A SPECIAL
FUND.
I'M SO THERE IS NO GENERAL FUND
IMPACT I'M SORRY APOLOGIZE.
YEAH OKAY OKAY THAT'S GOOD TO
KNOW OKAY THANKS.
I DON'T HAVE ANY MORE QUESTIONS
I GUESS.
AND AS WE'RE HOLDING THIS SO WE
WILL FIND MORE AB DO THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS WE'LL GET MORE
INFORMATION.
YOU KNOW ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON
AND THAT WOULD BE PROBABLY ORDER
LIST.
LOOK AT OR MAYBE WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION ON WHETHER THE A AG
IMPLEMENTS A BILL.
AFTER WE'VE APPROVED IT OR HE
WAY TO OF THE ART [inaudible]
RULE.
WE HAD A DISCUSSION YET AT ALL
[inaudible]
I'M WHAT.
WHAT?
A SO WE JUST HOLD WE'RE JUST
HOLDING.
THIS WILL BE A UNDER YOUR
SPECIAL NOTE FOR YOUR DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT DIVISION THEN WE ARE
BOTH WITHIN THEIR CONSUMER LAW
SECTION HOWEVER OKAY.
IS THAT.
I THIS UNIT IN AND ARE YOU
WRITING REGULATIONS ARE DOING
ANYTHING OF THAT NATURE AT THIS
POINT OR JUST ON ALL.
ON AN INEQUALITY IN THAT WE
WOULD NOT.
THIS WOULD BE ENFORCEMENT.
I'M REQUEST WE WOULD
OCCASIONALLY AS WE DO IN WITH
OTHER.
WOULD BE ABLE.
I WOULD NOTE FOR THE RECORD IF
THIS IS A FEDERAL STATE.
ON THE ENTIRE STATE.
SO THE LAW WE HAVE NO CHOICE BUT
NOT IMPLEMENTED WERE ALLIES IN
THE OTHER CASES.
WE HAD STAYS IN INDIVIDUAL
COUNTIES. FOR WHICH EVERY CORTES
HEARD THIS DAY AS LIVE.
A SIMILAR SCENE EARLIER THAT I
MISSED THAT.
NOT SURE.
ANYWAY JUST FOR THE RECORD.
BUT ON THIS ONE THOUGH WHAT I
MEAN WERE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHEN WE WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL BUT CERTAINLY
[inaudible]
IN EVERY.
THE BILL IS LAW [inaudible]
AND IT WOULD SEEM TO ME THAT WE
WOULD APPROPRIATE.
AND WE WOULD.
THEN RECOVER IT OF COURSE TO
RETURN IT TO THE FIND IF IT'S IF
WE CAN'T BEGIN IMPLEMENTATION.
SO THAT THAT IS CERTAINLY.
BACK THAT ANYTHING WE
APPROPRIATE COULD BE CHALLENGED
IN THE COURT.
IS ALWAYS AVAIL IS ALWAYS A
PRESS IS ALWAYS OF WHATEVER.
ACTOR SO.
WE WILL HOLD IT OPEN BUT I THINK
WE WILL.
YOU KNOW MY RECOMMENDATION THE
WORLD ANYWAY WILL BE.
AS WE TAKE THAT BUDGET ACTIONS
WAS WE WRAP UP TO ACT ON THIS.
ONE ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER A QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS.
OKAY SO ISSUE TWENTY ONE THEN WE
HAVE OUR OVERSIGHT THIS IS A NEW
AND EXPANDED CRIMES PCP.
THE NEW AND EXPANDED FRIENDS PCP
IS AGAIN IT'S A PROPOSAL.
RELATED TO SOME LEGISLATION THAT
WAS PASSED -- WERE REQUESTING
ONE POSITION AND A HUNDRED AND
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ON GOING.
THE INCREASED WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH UPDATING AND
MAINTAINING A STANDARDIZED SET
OF TABLES TO BE USED BY CRIMINAL
JUSTICE AGENCIES AND SUBMITTING
CRIMINAL RECORDS AND INFORMATION
OR YOU JUST OF IT.
RIGHT I LA -- WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL -- THE
DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
PROVIDE KIND OF SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION OR WHY RESOURCES
WOULD BE NEEDED AND IT'S UNCLEAR
TO US WHY.
THE STATE THE LISTS CANNOT BE
UPDATED WITHIN EXISTING
RESOURCES LEGISLATURE WE DO
ACKNOWLEDGE LEGISLATURE AN AXE
BILLS EVERY YEAR.
THE TABLES SHOULD NEED TO BE
UPDATED ONCE A YEAR.
AND SO IT'S UNCLEAR TO US WHY
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY DOING AND AREN'T
AVAILABLE TO DO IT.
I'M MOVING FORWARD [inaudible]
GOOD POINT -- WITH RC JUST
DIVISION OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
HAVE BEEN QUITE A FEW PROJECTS
QUITE A BIT OF LEGISLATION THAT
HAS -- LANDED WITH THE C. JUST
DIVISION AND THIS IS -- AN
ESTIMATE ON WHAT'S NEEDED. TO
HAVE THIS SERVICE OR TO HAVE
THIS WORK DONE ON A MORE
CONSISTENT BASIS.
AND TO HAVE A RESOURCE AVAILABLE
TO DO THAT -- SOME OF THE
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN NINE FIVE
THREE THE SB THREE FOR THE
EXPANDED TEARING BILL.
WAS TALKED ABOUT EARLIER AND AND
THOSE PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT PROJECTS.
IS A DIVISION AS A WHOLE SO THIS
WAS -- SIMILAR TO THE ONE I
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER WE HAVE A
LOT OF LEGISLATION WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR A RESOURCE ON ALL
THOSE.
WERE ASKING FOR SOME OF THOSE IN
A MORE STRATEGIC MANNER
[inaudible]
OF THAT SEEMS LIKE A BROAD.
RESPONSE BUT AGAIN IT'S I GUESS
I HAVE TO ERR ON THE SIDE OF THE
LA -- ON THIS ONE BECAUSE IF THE
WELL I A MIGHT QUIBBLE WITH WHAT
THE DETAIL IS IN THE EXCEPT
UNDER.
ONE AS OF BY SEN I DIFFERENT
SENSE I HAVE OF WORKLOAD.
THIS ONE DOESN'T DEMONSTRATE.
WHAT THE WORKLOAD IS YES
GENERALLY THAT WE MIGHT HAVE
MORE?
AND YET IF IT'S REALLY JUST
UPDATING -- LISTS THAT ARE
UPDATED ANNUALLY.
ARE THEY WHY WE NEED THIS IS
THIS KNOCKED MANAGER --
ADDITIONAL [inaudible]
ALLOCATION.
WE HAVE A MARK SAME HERE FROM A
DIVISION WHO MIGHT BE ABLE TO
WRITE A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL
AND CLARITY ON THIS ISSUE.
IF IT WOULD BE HELPFUL I CAN
DESCRIBE A LITTLE BIT OF THE
PROCESS OF THE DAY -- THE WAY
THAT THE TABLES ARE MAINTAINED
IT IS VERY REACTIONARY PROCESS.
NEW OFFENCES AS GET ADDED TO THE
TABLE AS LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES FOR THEM AT TIME OF A
REST.
IT'S NOT DONE AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR.
AT THERE'S NOT STAFF THAT
CURRENTLY SUPPORT THE STATE WIDE.
ABEL'S IN GENERAL.
IT'S DONE BY REDIRECTING STAFF
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
WHAT ALSO IS PROBLEMATIC ABOUT
THAT PROCESS IS DUPLICATION OF
STATUTES THE GIFT BUT ON TO THE
MASTER TABLES?
AS ONE AGENCY ASKED FOR AN
OFFENSE TO BE REPORTED THERE MAY
BE A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
VARIATION OF HOW THE REQUESTED
THAT IN A DIFFERENT AGENCY. ONE
AGENCY MAY REFER TO IT AS THE
CODE SECTION ANOTHER MAY REFER
TO IT AS A SUBDIVISION.
SO THERE ARE INSTANCES WHERE ON
THE TABLE TODAY THERE ARE
REPEALED CODES THAT STILL EXIST.
THERE'S CODES THAT ARE
DUPLICATED BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
REPORTED BY DIFFERENT AGENCIES
SO WHAT WE HAVE INTENDED TO DO
AS PART OF GENERAL KAMEL HISTORY
IMPROVEMENT.
IS TO CHANGE THE PROCESS FOR HOW
INFORMATION IS TABLED.
OUR INTENT IS TO BE MORE
PROACTIVE LOOKING AT IT FROM THE
TIME THAT A NEW BILL IS
INTRODUCED.
AND ANALYZING IT THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS I'M WORKING WITH HELLO
JUSTICE AGENCIES.
PRIMARILY THE COURTS D. A.'S AND
AUSTIN AGENCIES LAW ENFORCEMENT.
MAKE SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY NEED THE INFORMATION TO BE
TABLED.
SO THAT IT CAN BE USEFUL FOR
THEM IT'S BASICALLY A A CHANGE
THE WAY WE'VE DONE THINGS
HISTORICALLY.
IN AN ATTEMPT TO CREATE MORE
CONSISTENCY IN THE DATA AND TO
REDUCE THE DUPLICATION OF
INFORMATION OUT THERE.
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FOR MY
COLLEAGUES.
THIS IS RATHER MINOR IN TERMS OF
THE WHOLE AMOUNT WE'RE DEALING
WITH BUT I THINK IT IS YES AT IT
IS OUR OBLIGATION.
TO IN TERMS OF HE OVERSIGHT WE
PROVIDE.
IS THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
WITHOUT ANY.
ANY ERA INCREASE REQUEST.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
[inaudible]
ITEM.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE ALL NOT OPEN.
AND WE ARE NOW GOING.
TO OUR LAST ITEM.
WHICH IS -- A FOURTEEN IT WAS
ZERO F. AMBLING CONTROL
OVERSIGHT.
IT'S ITEM.
FOURTEEN YOU MAY PROCEED.
MADAM CHAIR STEP MISSION MáS
WHO IS HERE FROM THE YOUR FAMILY
CONTROL.
THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE LAID OUT
IN THE END.
GOOD MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON.
LOOKS LIKE I'M JUST REVIEWING
STAFF COMMENTS IF THERE IS TO BE
THREE ISSUES THE BACKLOG ANALYZE
INSPECTION.
AND THEN TWO OTHER ISSUES THAT
WE ARE DEALING WITH -- TRYING TO
ADDRESS WHICH IS THE BLACK JACK
ISSUE AND THE ROTATION OF THE
THEIR DEAR POSITION ISSUE.
I'M JUST KIND OF VERY --
GENERALLY ABOUT THE LICENSING
SECTION.
ARE THERE A BOX AND ONLY ONE
HUNDRED SOUTH ON IN THAT SECTION
WHO -- MONTHS RATHER
RESPONSIBILITIES CONDUCT
BACKGROUND INVESTIGATIONS.
IS REQUESTING RIGHT RATIONS
LICENSESAND WORK PERMITS OR
CARD ROOMS AND FOR THIRD PARTY
PROVIDERS.
OPPOSITION PLAYERS SERVICES
WHICH I WORE [inaudible]
RT PROVIDERS [inaudible]
I'M.
THE SCOPE OF EACH SUITABILITY
INVESTIGATION VARIES DEPENDING
ON LICENSE PLATE.
AND AND THE COMPLEXITY OF IT TO
THE ABSENCE HISTORY.
THE ANALYST DO THEY RESEARCH
ANALYZE EACH.
BACKGROUND UTILIZING VARIOUS
PERSONAL PUBLIC IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOURCES.
THEY ALSO LOOK AT THE FINANCIAL
RECORDS OF BUSINESS OWNERS IN
ENTITIES -- VERIFY THAT ALL
PERSONS WITH OWNERSHIP INTEREST
FOR CONTROL IN THE GAMING
OPERATION IDENTIFIED.
IMPROPERLY LICENSE.
THERE'S NOTED IN THE STAFF
COMMENTS IF YOU'RE IS FACING A
LOSS OF THIRTY TWO POSITIONS IN
THE LICENSING SECTION.
A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND IN
FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN THE PAIR OF CHANGE WELL
POSITIONS TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOG
IN THE SECTION.
ON IN FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE FOR THE
BEER WITH AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
POSITIONS FOR THIS.
WE THINK MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THOSE THAT MISSION
OPPOSITIONS -- THOSE POSITIONS
HAVE HELPED US A PRESS THAT
BACKLOG IN THE LICENSE.
THE FOR NUMBERS FOR EXAMPLE IN
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THERE WAS A BACKLOG OF THREE
THOUSAND TWENTY NINE LICENSE
APPLICATIONS.
AFTER THE ADDITION OF THE THIRTY
TWO POSITIONS AND THE REQUIRED
ONBOARDING TRAINING.
OTHER BACKLOG WAS DECREASED TO
ONE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED SIX
APPLICATIONS BY JUNE OF SO THESE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS INITIALLY
PROCESS BE LESS COMPLICATED
APPLICATIONS.
AND EVERYTHING WE TRANSITION TO
PROCESSING THE MORE DIFFICULT.
WELL THESE POSITIONS ARE FULL
TIME PERMANENT POSITIONS YOU'RE
ONLY RECEIVED LIMITED.
FUNDING FOR THEM WHICH BASICALLY
HAS THE PRACTICAL EFFECT OF
MAKING THEM FUNCTION IS
TEMPORARY.
WE'REHOPEFUL THE FUNDING WILL
CONTINUE FOR THESE POSITIONS IN
THE NECK.
I'M ALSO NOTED IN THE STAFF
COMMENTS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR IS CURRENTLY REVIEWING
THE LICENSING SECTIONS PROCESSES
A WORKLOAD.
AND BEEN VERY HELPFUL AND WE
LOOK FOR CONSTRUCTIVE COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS FROM THE
AUDITOR'S THAT WE CAN USE.
BUILD UPON -- DEFICIENCIES IN
THE SECTION AND AND ENSURE THAT
THE NUMBER OF ANY APPLICATIONS.
IS REDUCED IN ALL THE FUTURE
APPLICATIONS THAT COME IN ARE
DRESSED IN A TIMELY MANNER --
ANY QUESTIONS I CAN MOVE ON TO
WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THEAND
THE BLACK JACK IN THE ROTATION
ISSUE [inaudible]
I'M.
THE QUESTION I HAD IS THAT BE A
LIMITED TERM FIRST POSITIONS
WERE SUPPOSED TO EXPIRE AT THE
END OF THIS YEAR.
THERE'S NO B. C. B. ON THIS.
SO WHAT WAS YOUR INTENTION YOU.
DO HAVE THEM EXPIRE OR TO WAIT
UNTIL THAT AUDIT IS DONE OR WHAT.
WE'RE CURRENTLY WORKING.
WITH ADMINISTRATION THERE THERE
IS THE AUDIT IT IS ONGOING AND
THERE HAS.
THEN IT IS NOT FINISHED AND SO I
THINK WE WERE ALL LOOKING TO SEE
WHAT THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS MIGHT
BE.
A AND TRACKING WITH THE BUDGET --
SO WE ARE TRACKING IT WE ARE
AWARE AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
POSITION ARE NEEDED THERE IS A
PROPOSAL IN THE ONGOING.
POLLUTION THAT NEEDED A AND WE
RECOGNIZE THE EXPIRED AND LONG
WAY OF SAYING I THINK THEY WERE
WAITING WITHOUT A RECOMMENDATION.
AGAIN.
IT MAY IS WHEN THE RIGHT WE
WOULD GET THE MAY REVISE
[inaudible] FOR ME.
MAYES THE A BM ESTIMATED
COMPLETION DATE THE AUTO.
THERE ARE MORE LIKE.
TRENDS ARE IS THERE A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS.
WERE BEING OFTEN STATED.
BY THE GAMBLING.
OPERATIONS.
THE INDIAN RESERVATION CORRECT.
I'M JUST WONDERING IS A UBER
SPENT AT THESE ARE SAID SOME
KIND OF COST.
OR AYBE A REVENUE ENHANCEMENT
TO THE STATE.
CURRENT [inaudible]
NOT SPECIFICALLY.
YOUR NAME WE HAVE A
UNCONDITIONAL.
YES I GUESS INDIAN CASINOS WOULD
BE EXAM ROOM.
BANG ANY AND REVENUE.
OUR ROOMS WOULD.
HAVE SOME KIND OF THOUGH THE
BEER WAS BASICALLY FUNDED BY TWO
SPECIAL FUNDS ONE THE INDIAN
GAMING DISTRIBUTION FUND AND
THEN THE ON THE CONTROL FUND THE
SERGEANTS AND THE THIRD PARTY
PROVIDERS BASICALLY.
THEY'RE SO THE LICENSING THE
BACKLOG DISTRICT LEADERS TO THE
GARDEN OF THE THIRD PARTY --
WELL THE BUREAU DOES DEFINING
DISABILITIES ON THE WAY ON THE
TREBLE SIDE.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THAT FOR
THESE -- IN TERMS OF THE BACK.
WITH ALL IN THE FAMILY.
AND A COLD THIS IS NEW TERRITORY
FOR ME THAT'S BY MASKING BASIC.
QUESTIONS I'M JUST.
WONDERING IF THERE'S A AN
INCENTIVE FOR US TO BE A LITTLE
MORE.
BUT IN THE END IT WELL IT.
WHAT WHAT DOES THAT WHAT IS THE
CARD ROOM AFTER A DEALER
[inaudible]
THE STATE.
THE CARD INTO THE FUND BASED ON
DIFFERENT FACTORS SO THERE IS AN
ANNUAL FEE THAT EITHER -- IT
EITHER BY NUMBER OF CABLES BUT
IF THEY MEET A CERTAIN THRESHOLD --
FOR FOR THE MONEY THEY MAKE THEN
THE ISLAND.
WAY UP.
IN THE EAST WITH THE LICENSING
INVESTIGATIONS THERE THOSE ARE
GENERATED FROM -- IN PART BY --
EAT THEY PAY DEPOSIT APPLICATION
FEES.
A ONE TIME APPLICATION AND MEN
ARE THERE IS A DEPOSIT PROVIDED
AND BE ON AND BILL AGAINST IT
WITH THE AND I THINK.
I'M GONNA AFFECT MY ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR FOR LICENSING BECAUSE I
THINK IT DOES DIFFER BETWEEN
DIFFERENT.
PARTIES AND CARD ROOMS
[inaudible]
PM [inaudible]
THE I I AM I TO BE A DEALER.
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT SAYS WELL
WE GOT YOUR BACK JACK WE GO
THROUGH THE I GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AND I'M DOING FINE BUT I KIDS I
GOT A HOW LONG THIS IS GOING TO
A FOR DEALERS THAT WOULD
PROBABLY REQUIRE.
WITH THE WITH THE WORK.
WE HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
PEOPLE WHO.
LIKE THE OTHERS WOULD HAVE TO
GET A WORK PERMIT WHICH IS A
LOWER STANDARD OF REVIEW.
THANKS FOR EMPLOYEES THOSE WHO
SUPERVISED OR HAVE AN OF
DISCRETIONARY DECISION MAKING
WITHIN THE PROCESS.
AND A HIGHER LEVEL.
THE OWNER OF IT.
THE WORK PERMIT -- ARE ARE
RELATIVELY.
YOU KNOW THOUGH WE WHEN WE
STARTED WITH THE BAT WE DO HAVE --
ADDITIONAL.
I'M IN EVERY YEAR -- WITH THE
BACK BUT WE REALLY KIND OF
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE ANY
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE IT KIND OF
GOING THROUGH ALL THE OPPRESSED
[inaudible]
LONGER BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT --
YOU KNOW.
THE SIDE -- EMILY WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT FIRST WE IN ORDER ME A
DIFFERENT ALLEN NOT ANALYST.
WE HAVE DIFFERENT PEOPLE WORK
UNDER.
THE WORK OUT ANALYSTS THE ONES
BM.
ANALYSTS TO THE IN AROUND MORE
IN A MORE EXPERIENCED WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PARTY MODE SO THEY KIND
OF YEAH.
AND THOSE.
ARE DOOMED THE OWNER WANTS THOSE
TAKE THE AND THE THIRD PARTY
OWNERS TAKE A MUCH LONGER.
THE BIGGER COMPANIES MORE THINGS
TO LOOK AT REALLY INTERESTED IN --
ALL THE FINANCIAL [inaudible]
FUNDING.
THE TIME JUST.
YOU KNOW.
WE'RE REGULATING MINISTRY OF
WORLD WHERE THE LOG JAM RIGHT.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT?
THIS IS BENEFITING THE STATE HOW
DO WE I SHORTENED THE EMPTY LOT
YEAH I THINK IT'S SOME I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
DESPITE THE END OF THE A NUMBER
OF PENDING APPLICATIONS BUT
ALMOST EVERYONE IS ABLE.
TO WORK A LITTLE BIT
INTERNALIZED THEY'LL GET THINGS
THAT WERE NOT PREVENTING PEOPLE
FROM WORKING IN OUR I'M IN THE
INDUSTRY SPELL BUT WE DO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY'RE FULLY LICENSED --
YOU KNOW WITH A MUCH MORE
STRINGENT.
LONGER PROCESS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING.
REALLY SHOULD BE WORKING.
THANKS FOR LETTING ME ASK.
BASIC [inaudible]
HE EARLY IT'S THE POSITIONS AND
WHETHER THEIR CONTINUED OR NOT
THAT OBVIOUSLY WE WILL BE.
REVISITING ONCE.
BUT THE OTHER -- ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED AROUND R. SOME
OF THE NEW REGULATIONS THAT
MIGHT BE BEING PROMULGATED AND
I'M NOT CLEAR THAT THERE WAS ANY.
THE MEANING LEGISLATIVE ACTION
[inaudible]
YOU DIRECT.
THOSE NEW RAG [inaudible]
I'M.
JUST BACK ABOUT WHAT.
YEAH NO ONE ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT THE ROTATION THE THEIR
DEALER.
SO THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT WERE
GOING THROUGH THE REGULATORY
PROCESS.
FOR SO IT JUST A BACKUP IN TERMS
OF LIKE NOTIFICATION.
BACK IN.
NUMBER TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
COLLEGES I SHOULD'VE REYES THE
PART OF THE CONCERN IS THAT
THERE [inaudible]
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
WHERE ARE THE ROOMS ARE LOCATED?
HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN THAT
[inaudible]
THERE'S POTENTIAL.
FOR NEW RAKES YOU IMPACT THE
REVENUE THAT THEY RECEIVED
[inaudible]
AND QUESTION IS SPEND THAT SINCE
THERE HAS NOT BEEN ANY STATUTORY
CARD ROOMS.
THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT WHAT
WHAT IS WHAT IS.
ELICITED THIS NEED FOR THE NEW
RECORD [inaudible]
SO.
GOING BACK THEN SO IN TERMS OF
THE THE PIRATE EITHER ROTATION
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT WE PLAN
TO REGULATE.
SO WE ARE LOOKING AT ACTIONS
THREE THIRTY POINT.
ELEVEN BY.
LANGUAGE IN THERE ABOUT
CONTINUES A SYSTEMATIC ROTATION
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE THINGS
WE'RE LOOKING AT IN THE
REGULATION SO.
AND THIS ONE LITTLE BIT FARTHER
BACK SO I THINK BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN THERE WAS SOME
EFFORT TO ADDRESS -- THIS ISSUE --
THERE WAS A PROPOSAL IT WAS --
AS PROVIDED IN TERMS OF WHAT
ROTATION MEANS.
OF THAT WAS CHALLENGES AN
UNDERGROUND READ IN THE UP TO
THE MINUTE OF LAW.
PLEASE READ.
IT THAT'S KIND OF ARE THE
BUSINESS POINT B. THE ACTUAL
REGULATORY PROCESS BECAUSE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING IT
RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE GOING THROUGH THAT
PROCESS -- YES -- IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE HAVE DONE WE HAD
NOTIFIED THE PARK ROOMS -- AND
WE NEED A WE NOTIFY ORGANS AND
THIRD PARTIES AND WE ALSO DO THE
SAME WE NOTIFY THE GAMING.
WELL EVERYONE KIND OF HAS AN
INTEREST WHAT WE USUALLY DO IS
MEET WITH THEM ON THE SAME DAY
TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE'S GETTING
THE SAME -- BACK IN -- I STARTED
IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE MET WITH.
LET THEM KNOW THAT THERE IS AN
ISSUE.
HAVE AN ONGOING ISSUES OR I'M
YEARS THAT WE WERE PLANNING TO
ADDRESS HAD UNDERSTOOD THAT THE
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT BE.
ON THE MAP WE SAID.
KNOWING THAT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
OFF ON DOING ANYTHING -- WAS IN
THE SESSION AT THE END OF AUGUST
WE MET AGAIN WITH THE GROUP
INSTEAD LOOK NOTHING WAS.
THERE WAS NO LEGISLATION SO
WE'RE GONNA GO HEAD NUMBER AND
ADDRESS CERTAIN ISSUES AND WE
LAY THEM ALL OUT. ONE OF THEM
BEING THE THIRTY THE ROTATION IS
TO LET EVERYONE KNOW THAT WE
WERE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
RULE MAKING PROCESS -- HELLO
WE'VE DONE SO FAR IS GOING
THROUGH KIND OF THE REGULATION
WORKSHOP WE DO A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY WE DID NOT PROVIDE
ANY CRAFT -- REGULATIONS WE
WANTED TO WHAT THE STATUTE SAYS
A SAYS WE'RE TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION BEFORE WE ACTUALLY.
WE HELD -- SIX PUBLIC WORKSHOPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THIRTEEN IN
OCTOBER WE'VE GONE BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN NORTH AND SOUTH.
TO GET INPUT -- AND IS ANYONE
INTERESTED WE PUT THEM ON OUR
WEBSITE ALL THE RECORDINGS BE
THE WORKSHOPS ALL OF THE
RESPONDENTS WE HAVE RECEIVED
FROM INDIVIDUALS.
I MEAN YOU'RE RIGHT DURING THAT
PROCESS A LOT OF IT WAS HEARING
FROM EMPLOYEES THE CARD ROOMS IN
THE THIRD PARTY PROVIDERS.
AS WELL AS LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
CONCERNED ABOUT THE THE IMPACT
BECAUSE OF THEM HELLO ME IN THE
REVENUE.
I'M ALSO WITH -- LOCAL CHARITIES
AND ANYONE THAT THE KHARTOUM HAS
YOU KNOW HAS PROVIDED ASSISTANCE.
THE DURING THEIR UP IN THE IN
THE CITY SO OUT WE DID GET A LOT
OF I'M GOOD INFORMATION ABOUT.
REALLY THE IMPACT WE DEFINITELY
HEARD A LOUD AND CLEAR.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE NEED
TO ENFORCE THE LONG RICH MY TO
DO IT IN THE IN THIS MATTER VERY
AN ERRANT.
ALL WE DO PLAN HAVE ANOTHER
WORKSHOP IN SACRAMENTO WHERE
WILL HAVE SOME DRAFT LANGUAGE SO
EVERYONE -- IN.
PROVIDE INPUT I KNOW IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT JUST THROWING IT OUT
AND SAY WE JUST WANT ALL YOUR
INPUT AND PLEASE GIVE US YOUR
YOUR THOUGHTS SO.
PEOPLE HAVE INDICATED THAT IT
WOULD BE NICE TO SEE THE
LANGUAGE THEY CAN GUIDE.
MORE.
WE PLAN TO DO THAT.
I'M UNDERSTANDING THAT IF THIS
HAS A YOU KNOW AND ECONOMIC
IMPACT.
OF THE MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THIS REAR PROCESS.
FINANCE -- WHICH IS BASICALLY A
VERY YOU KNOW -- LOOKING AT THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT THOUGH THOSE
THINGS THOSE IMPACTS THE CITY'S
DEPARTMENT THE THIRD PARTY
PROVIDERS ARE THINGS THAT WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE TO EXAMINE.
I'M ASSUMING THAT THERE IS THAT --
AT RUSH IMPACT BY THE RATE.
WE HAVE NOT ACTUALLY RAPID THE
REGULATIONS YET -- WE DO THAT
VERY SOON TO GET IT OUT.
IN THE INDUSTRY TO THE PUBLIC SO
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO -- ALMOND ON
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY MY
COLLEAGUES OR ASK FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SKINNER.
CENTERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH BOB
YOU DRESS YOU MY NAME IS RUBER
MUTIS.
I AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR SELF
RELIANCE JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY.
WE ARE MADE UP OF SEVEN CITIES.
AS A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY IN
LA COUNTY.
THE CITY CITIES ARE IMPACTED BY
THE PROPOSAL'S BEAT.
THAT FOURTH BY.
THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING ROLL.
BEFORE I TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THIS I JUST WANT TO MENTION.
THAT I DON'T BELIEVE YOUR
QUESTION WAS ANSWERED BY.
THE BUREAU AND WHAT STATUTORY
TEAM.
RIGHT ABOUT.
THE NEED FOR NEW RAGS FOR THE
WILL DRAW OF BLACK TO A AND THEN
THE ANSWER IS.
THERE HAS BEEN NO STATUTORY
CHANGE.
OUR CITIES ARE FUNDED BY THE
FEES CHARGED.
OF BY THE CITIES ON THE CARD
ROOM TO OPERATE IN OUR CITIES.
PROBABLY ABOUT SEVENTY SOME ODD
CITIES THE REVENUE I MEAN BROUGH.
MOST LIKELY WILL BE WHEN HE IN
YOUR DISTRICT.
THESE REVENUES ARE USED FOR THE
FUNDING OF CITIES.
IN OUR DID IN OUR GPA YOU'RE
LOOKING AT 50% OF TO AS HIGH AS
80% ON A BAD ECONOMIC YEAR
[inaudible]
THAT.
THOSE REVENUES FROM THE CARD
ROOM.
FUND THE ENTIRE GENERAL FUND OF
THESE CITY.
CITY OF WINE BAR INSTANT.
WILL BE ADDRESSING YOU SHORTLY.
COUNCIL MEMBER FROM THE OF
HAWAIIAN GUARD.
IS CITY.
IS THAT 76% OF THEIR GENERAL
FUND BUDGET.
THEM SPEND THE REVENUE.
THE WITHDRAWAL OF OF BLACKED OUT
IS VERY TROUBLING BLACK JACK.
CALIFORNIA BLACK WE DON'T PLAY
THE LOS VEGAS [inaudible]
THE BAND.
CALIFORNIA BLACK YEAH IT'S BEEN
PLAYED FOR OVER TWO DECADES.
AND THINK OF IT THIS WAY IS.
A IF YOU'RE BUILDING A HOME OR
YOUR AND OR BUILDING OFFICE
BUILDING OR OR SOME TYPE O
RETAIL STRIP YOU'VE GONE TO THE
CITY YOU ASKED.
FOR A PERMIT.
THEY'VE GRANTED YOU THE PERMIT
YOU [inaudible]
CONSTRUCTION.
AND YOU BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
YOU YOU RELY ON THAT.
OVER TWENTY YEARS.
OUR CITIES HAVE RELIED ON THIS
REVENUE -- BY.
AND NOW.
WILL YOUR PERMIT ME.
AND REASONABLE.
AND YET THEY HAVE PROVIDED NOTE.
DIRECTION AS TO WHERE THIS
REVENUES GONNA COME FROM.
LET ME TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
THINGS -- GONNA BE LOTS.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE ANY IMPACT ON
ON JUVENILE JUSTICE AND ADULT
JUST. FOR INSTANCE MUSIC VIDEO
OF GARDENA THEY HAVE A PROGRAM
FUNDED BY THE GENERAL FUND.
NOT COUNTY MONEY NOT STATE MONEY.
THEY BELIEVE THAT REDUCE CRIME
AND RECIDIVISM IN CALIFORNIA YOU
HAVE TO GO A LITTLE BIT MORE
THAN JUST.
PROVIDE. TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS AT
THE GATE AND RUSH OUT.
ROWLY OR PROBATIONER.
SO WHAT THEY DO IS THEY USE
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS.
OUR ROOM MONEY [inaudible] TO
VIED [inaudible]
PREVENTION INTERVENTION
[inaudible]
PROGRAMS.
RED TREATMENT.
HOMELESS.
POUNDS LEAN.
WITH SOCIAL SERVICE.
AND THEIR CRIME RATE HAS GONE
DRAMATICALLY DOWN.
THAT'S A PROGRAMS GOING TO YEAR
OUR SENIOR SPIT SERVICES
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE SEVEN
CITIES.
WOULD BE LAW AND THE CITY IS A
ARE LOAD AHMAD EVERY.
CHILD IS ON THE FREE LUNCH
PROGRAM.
A YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT POVERTY
MUNITY [inaudible]
AND FOR MANY OF THE SENIORS IT'S
THEIR ONLY LUNCH PROGRAM.
AND THAT'S ONLY NUTRITION FOR
THE DAY AND THEY'RE NOT IN YOU
CAN LOSE IT.
BASED IN THE FOOD SERVICES THE
MANAGEMENT.
THE STAFF GO OUT AND CHECK ON
WHERE THE SENIORS ARE. TO WRAP
IT UP.
THERE IS BEEN NO.
TALK ABOUT HOW THEY'RE GONNA
BACK BILL ALL THIS LAW.
REVENUE IN FACT THEY HAVEN'T
EVEN TALKED ABOUT.
FUNDING RATIO OF THE CITY OF
HAWAIIAN GARDEN.
WHO'S GOING TO PICK UP.
THE THE UNINCORPORATED.
THE LOST THE REVENUE
[inaudible]
SO.
I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY'RE GONNA THROW ON YOUR
SHOULDER FIND WITH A DOLLAR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR YEP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME AND NUMBER
[inaudible] ONE GARDEN.
IT IS BAD. 7075% OF OUR BUDGET
COMES FROM FINANCES FROM THE YOU
KNOW.
AND THESE PROPOSED GAME CHANGES.
IS LAWS THAT HAVE BEEN STEP FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS OLD AT THE
STATE OUR COMMUNITY OUR
COMMUNITY WE GET CANNOT
[inaudible]
TRACK.
RIGHT IN BUSINESS -- THE ONLY
THAT WHAT THAT IS YOU KNOW WITH
THE MONEY THAT WE GET INTO THIS
YOU KNOW WE PUT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR [inaudible]
INTO OUR LAKE WHICHEVER
DEPARTMENT.
THEY HAVE A SPECIAL GANG UNIT
WILL WORK IN THE IT INDUSTRY.
WE HAVE A THAT TO REMOVAL
PROGRAM IF THEY REMOVE ALL GANG-MEMBER TAT DO THEY CAN BE OFF
GET UP THE GAME NUMBER.
AGAIN IN JUNCTION THAT THEY'RE
ON WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTEEN PEOPLE
OFTEN GAIN DELTA NOW IN THE LAST
FIVE YEARS CRIME IS DROPPED 18%
[inaudible]
I'M.
I KNOW I DON'T SHOULDN'T THEY
THEY ABOUT RECREATION BELIEVES
ARE OR AS A DETERRENT TO GANKS
WE HAVE A THRIVING PORT THING
BUT ARE YOU.
AND I JUST WANNA TELL YOU THAT
**** GARDENS WILL DEFINITELY
GOAL.
UNDER WATER WE DO NOT HAVE THE
REVENUE FROM THE YOU KNOW WE
ALMOST WENT BANKRUPT.
IN.
SEVENTY AND THE US SOMEONE BUILD
OUT AND THEN THE YOU KNOW CAME
AND WERE OF LOW.
WE WERE GOING TO BE PART OF LA
THE VALET.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF ASKING ON BEHALF OF
POINT GARDENS CASINO IN COMMERCE
CASINO.
WE ARE TWO OF THE LARGEST
BUSINESSES IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THE ACCOUNT AS THE COUNCIL
MEMBERS INDICATED FOR LARGE
PORTIONS.
OF THE GENERAL FUND REVENUE TO
THE CITIES AND OUR OPERATING
BUDGET.
WE HAD BEEN INITIALLY SUPPORTIVE
SOME YEARS AGO OF THE TEMPORARY
POSITIONS TO HELP THE BUREAU GET
THEIR BACKLOG.
BUT IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS AND
ATTEMPTING TO WORK THROUGH
DIFFERENT SET OF REGULATIONS NOW
SEEING THE BLACK TECH GAMES
AREN'T BEING APPROVED.
IN ONE CIRCUMSTANCE WE HAD ONE
GAME THAT HAD BEEN APPROVED ONE
CASINO IN SOUTHEAST LOS ANGELES.
IT WAS APPROVED THREE YEARS AGO
BUT THAT HAS BEEN BACKLOG BURN
OTHER CASINO THAT.
GOOGLE.
SO WE SIMPLY ASK THAT IS YOUR
SUBCOMMITTEE.
CONSIDERS THESE TEMPORARY
POSITIONS AGAIN BUT THEY BE
CONTINGENT ON THE FACT THAT THEY
ACTUALLY GET TO THE BACKLOG.
OTHER APPROPRIATE LEAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE VETTED FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WE NEED TO GO
THROUGH.
BUT THIS BACKLOG THAT WE'RE
WAITING ON IS OBVIOUSLY HAVING
REAL WORLD EXPENSES UNITIES MUCH
LOCATED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER.
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE SIDE OF
LET ME SEE IF I UNDERSTAND THIS
I'M IN ADDITION TO THE NOT
PROCESSING SAY PERMITS FOR
CERTAIN GAMES THE OTHER CONCERN
SEEMS TO BE REGULATE.
REGULATIONS THAT ARE BEING
CONSIDERED THEY'VE NOT BEEN
ENACTED YEAH RIGHT IN OTHER
WORDS.
THE DEPARTMENT IS NOT YET
ADOPTED ITS REGULATION.
SO THE OAKS THEY'VE SPOKEN TO US.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
YOUR RATE PUBLIC PROCESS.
COMMENT ON YOUR REGULATION.
YEAH. TO MAKE IT IS.
WE WERE TALKING A REGULATE
ABSOLUTELY PER POINT OF REGULAR.
THE OTHER ISSUE THOUGH IS FOR
THE BLACK AT GAMES.
KNOW THAT WE ARE LOOKING NOT ALL
THE BLACK TYPE GAMES THE BILL
CODE.
BASICALLY PROHIBITS BECAME A
TWENTY ONE SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
ALL THE BLACK.
GAMES THAT THE ART ROOM.
WE DID LET THEM KNOW AGAIN BACK
IN AUGUST WE WERE LOOKING AT
THOSE.
EIGHT WHICH IS A DIFFERENT
PROCESS THE BUREAU ACTUALLY --
THOSE GAMES SO IF WE WERE POINT
SOMETHING.
AND FIND THAT THEY DO VIOLATE
THE LAW IT WOULD BE A PROBLEM.
SO AND I THINK WHAT WAS
MENTIONED BEFORE WAS -- THE
ROTATION ISSUE THERE ARE -- WE
PLAN TO DO WAS ONE WE DON'T THE
FACT THAT.
WE WOULD ISSUED TEMPORARY
APPROVAL.
FOR ALL GAMES THE OTHER PARTNERS
ARE CURRENTLY.
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD WHILE WE
ADDRESS.
I'M WHICH AFFECTS ALL OF THE AND
CALIFORNIA GAMES HONESTLY
CALIFORNIA GAMES AND MEAN ANON.
WE HAVE NOT ACTUALLY TAKEN
ACTION ON BUT WE ARE REVIEWING
BLACK JACK AND WE ARE GOING
THROUGH THE REGULAR [inaudible]
QUESTION.
YOU MISTER TRIMBLE CANASTA.
HOW LARGE IS YOUR BUDGET RANDALL
BUT?
BUT IS IT [inaudible]
WHAT WELL?
RIGHT NOW TWENTY MILLION BRING
THEN WE GET ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS [inaudible]
MY YOUR TOTAL BUDGET IS.
SEVENTEEN MILLION A YEAR.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN AND A LOT OF
THE ARE TWELVE MILLION IS FROM
THE SCENE [inaudible]
YES.
AND THEN I JUST KIND OF TRYING
TO GRASP YOUR YOUR REAL ESTATE
TAXES ARE RELATIVELY WE GET NO
PROPERTY.
WHAT WE GET IT WE HAVE A LOT OF
LITTLE BUSINESSES?
NOT A LITTLE NET AND TENS AND
MCDONALD'S GIVES A LOT OF MONEY
I'M A MAN.
BUT WE HAVE BUSINESSES
[inaudible]
THAT YES.
BUT NOT ENOUGH TO RUN A CITY.
THANK YOU TO EXPLAIN THAT YOU
DON'T GET PROPERTY TAXES
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
WE WE WE'RE NOT.
WE'RE NOT PART OF THAT.
HOW MANY HOW MANY HOW MANY NO
ACT THEY BEGIN BASIC QUESTION
HOW MANY NO PROPERTY TAX CITIES?
IS THE STATE HAVE.
AMENDED THE MAP.
OKAY AROUND DO SOME RESEARCH ON
THAT AND I'M JUST.
TRYING TO VERIFY YOUR NUMBERS
I'M FAMILIAR WITH A WHEN GUARDS
OKAY.
I GREW UP IN THE CYPRESS POINT
PARK AREA.
OKAY YEAH YEAH I'M TRYING TO
THINK OF A IS A HOME AUTO SHOP --
TIM JONES -- USED.
THIS IS AN WAS A NEIGHBOR MINE
IN AND YOUR FRIEND A BUSINESS.
AND YOUR HOME ON AUTO I THINK
THAT'S IT YEAH IN AN APPLE AND
THAT'S BEEN GONE FOR A WHILE
THAT WAS A RIGHT.
I KNOW HE'S NOT A WITH GREAT BUT
YEAH IT'S BEEN GONE.
AND THE ON THAT BUILDINGS BEEN
LOOKING OVER BY SEVERAL
DIFFERENT COMPANIES THAT FAILED.
I SPENT A LOT OF MONEY THERE
WHEN I WAS YOUNG YEAH.
YEAH.
THEN YOU LOVE YOUR CAR.
IF YOU WITH.
YEAH.
I THINK TIM JONES HE HAS A NOW
HAS A CONVERTIBLE.
THE OLD STATE SIXTY CADILLAC RED
IN THERE WAS ONE IN FRONT OF ME
AT A LIGHT SUNDAY I JUMPED OUT
OF THE CAR AND IF THAT ARE YOU.
SO I COULDN'T TELL FROM THE BACK
OF YOU TIM JONES IT WASN'T RIGHT
SO.
SORRY BRING UP OLD MEMORIES BACK
OKAY I'LL DO A LITTLE RESEARCH
BUT THAT'S THAT'S A PHENOMENAL
I'VE JUST LOOK AT YOUR BUDGET
JUST YET.
AND PLEASE IF THIS IS ACCURATE
AS WELL AND SO WHAT WHAT WHAT
TRUTH WHAT IS WHAT IS WHAT IS
BLACK JACK REPRESENT AS AS A AS
A COMPONENT OF THE REVENUES
COMING OUT OF THAT CAR CLUB.
IF I SENATE.
WHEN GARDEN SPECIFICALLY IT'S
BETWEEN TWELVE AND 17%?
BLACK BLACK BLACK JACK LIKE GAME
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT I KNOW I
FORGET OKAY YEAH THIS IS USING.
TERMINOLOGY THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST
WANT TO GET.
THANK YOU FOR COMING
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT AND BACK INCLUDE.
IS THIS ONE WAS INFORMATIONAL.
WE OBVIOUSLY ARE.
GENERAL.
YOU ALL SPECIFICALLY BUT CLEARLY
BECAUSE WE DID NOT TAKE ACTION
ON OUR YOUR DAY THE C. P..
WE WILL.
HOPEFULLY -- HAVE STAFF -- WORK
OUT.
WE DON'T HAVE WE HEAR THEM.
BUT CERTAINLY IN -- BUT
CERTAINLY IF WE NEED.
TO WE WELL I'M.
AND WITH THAT.
IF YOU HAVE A THANK YOU MADAM.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE HE
OF BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE OR
TODAY